the mere acting and watching of a video that encourages bad stuff.
Now you are culpable for things that might result from watching
a videoable. There's no way. There's no way. Is it your burden?
Who cares? I'm really tired right now. Hey Hutch, you just made
a claim. Isn't your burden to like try to prove that claim? Who
cares? I'm tired right now. That is table stakes. That is your
ante to get into the conversation. If you can't say whether you
think it's right or wrong, if you just go, "Oh, it's petty slop
and I don't really care why you care so much, bro." You're a
loser.
And Hutcha just called Pisco a debate, bro. That's where we got
to. We got about an hour in. It looks like we got about They're
around about an hour in. Okay, there's a lot more left. Okay,
so we just seen Hutch accuse Pisco being a debate bro. And I
I mean, we'll just keep walking through it. Okay.
>> The video before she watched it. >> Why would
you keep No, she continued to watch it. Dude, she enjoyed it.
>> I just want to do it one step. I just want to do it
one step at a time. So, you don't have any evidence correct that
she knew what was in the video before she got >> I think
you're trying to worm out. How do you end up
at a time? Let's just do one thing at a >> I think you're
trying to worm out of the logical conclusion that you just jumped
to, which is that if the the reason why it's irresponsible for
someone to do that in her position is >> No, that person
ran Latigious Gamer. The person we looked at who was in Pisco's
like Twitter replies talking about him, that person ran away
from Pisco. That person did not show up to debate. They were
too scared to show up to debate. They couldn't do it. They lost
in every single way.
>> Because as you said, the risk goes way up that somebody
in her community might act on that. >> Here's here's the
thing. It's an how is she not cable? So So it's an attenuated
risk. It's an attenuated risk that is >> Wow. is not at
all sufficient for capability. Not even 1%. Not even close to
1%. Hutch. The mere acting and watching of a video that encourages
bad stuff. Now you are culpable for things that might result
from watching a video. >> It's like the most lazy, intellectually
dishonest thing where what's obviously happening here is Pisco
is trying to say that when you criticize somebody and you're
saying, "Hey, you did this bad thing. here's what you're responsible
for. When somebody you dislike is the person you're criticizing,
you're going to say something as crazy as like, "Oh yeah, well
um one time you smoked a cigarette in a room with my grandmother
and that obviously you knew cigarettes cause cancer and my grandmother
died of lung cancer and so you are responsible for my grandmother's
death, right?" Like when it's somebody you hate, you'll go to
that extreme extent and then when it's somebody you like, you'll
get people who are going to do like what? Oh, what's a good one?
I don't know. Trump January 6th be like he's he's not responsible
at all. He didn't do anything to make us want to riot that day.
Right. Prove prove that he caused anything that day. It's like
oh all the statements about the stolen election, the constant
raising of the temperature, right? Like it's it's stuff like
that.
And Pisco is trying to say, let's find an objective way to evaluate
these things. You've done something with some risk to it. How
responsible are you for that risk blowing up in your face? Like
what was the chance that it would happen? What was the likelihood
that you could expect it to happen? How how culpable are you
for the thing happening? Right? Technically, you go driving every
day. There's some risk you're going to get in a car accident.
Doesn't mean you're responsible. If you get in a car accident
and kill somebody, doesn't mean you're responsible. It like there's
a whole bunch of factors that go in. So, Pisco is saying, "Hey,
instead of just saying, you know, she watched this video on stream,
therefore she's responsible for this.
Any amount of participation in the system means you're responsible
for all actions of the system." Why don't we do a little analysis
here? Why don't we think just a little bit? Just a little bit.
And then we can apply. We think and then we apply. Okay. And
Hutch is like, "But they called CBS.
They called CBS."
And it's just like a It's the laziest it's the laziest intellectual
exercise I've ever seen. And I'd like to I'd like to see Hutch
go beyond that because he's being pressed on this a little bit.
And to me, he runs every single time. But I I haven't watched
too much further than this, so we'll see if it gets any better
>> No way that you would apply this standard to any other
commentator who watches something. Come on, bro. This is so bizarre
and wild that [laughter] me suggesting this is crazy.
Uh, I believe Hutch normalizes doxing by watching Destiny's content,
a known doxer, somebody who has doxed Hutch's friends, people
Hutch has worked in the same organizations as, people that he's
threatened to dox people like this and he has doxed Hutch's former
friends, people Hutch would know, right? So, I think Hutch is
obviously engaging in really bad behavior, right? He talks Hutch,
too. Well, kind of in a roundabout way. You could say in a roundabout
way. Sure. But um
man, I no I actually don't hold him responsible for that. Same
same deal as this.
He's got so many people. He has docs. Why would he say that?
I was like, "Oh, maybe you could argue with the No, but you can't."
Nah,
that's everything they say bad empanada is. Well, it's just it's
like obvious.
And I just wonder why.
Oh, man. I just wonder why.
I think that standard is by the way to me the standard is like
obviously Hutch just to be clear obviously Hutch is not responsible
for that but it's a totally standard that makes no sense at all
>> if I moderate ask my chat if I moderate like I take
steps all the time I tell my chat explicitly all the time don't
brigade I do all like there's there's certain red lines that
I understand that me as a creator as someone with the following
as someone who could potentially influence someone >> I
think anybody who is arguing this though has like an impetus
to say it's it's morally wrong to cover any Destiny content to
give him any views to do anything like that, right? If you're
going to make the argument Hutch is making, you do have to argue
the Destiny content is too harmful to support even the adjacent
stuff because obviously like if you just watch Bad Panata's video
essays alone, right? I'm sure Hutch would try to hold, you know,
Hassan responsible for bad empanada in some way. What did Hassan
say about Bad Empanada? Oh, you could watch his essays, but he's
like totally deranged else-wise, right? That that denouncement
doesn't work for Hutch, obviously, right? Hutch is basically
Connor. Well, >> I do think that I have a responsibility
to use that influence responsibly culpable. It doesn't make you
culpable. >> it doesn't make you 100% culpable, but you
are partly culpable. Yes. At the very least, here's a question
for you. If if you're saying that >> you are partly culpable,
but I don't think Pisco disagrees with that. He would just say,
"What percentage culpable are you?" And was that's the entire
discussion. What percentage culpable are you? And then based
on that percentage, what do you deserve based on that percentage?
>> Uh Charlie Kirk has blood on his hands. This is before
he's Charlie Kirk is a fascist. Charlie Kirk is trying to overturn
the, you know, the democracy of our country. He's instituting
these horrible things. Oh, this is the obvious angle Pisco should
take though, right?
Um, obviously you can't say just because you have divisive or
honest rhetoric about Charlie Kirk, you can't say that the person
saying those things is responsible for Charlie Kirk's shooting
>> you're doing the Republican thing now. >> I You're
doing You're doing the thing. >> Why do you Why do you
think I'm bringing that up, Hutch? >> Because there's a
difference.
Do you THINK I BELIEVE WAIT,
DO YOU THINK I believe HUTCH? THE FACT THAT YOU'RE ASKING. So
I I'm going to I am not going to be deterred from bringing up
this example. The question stands the question is as follows.
If you as a creator are platforming a video, you're watching
a video in which someone says Charlie Kirk has blood on his hands.
He's allowing and encouraging criminal actions from the administration
and um honestly I think that he's a fascist and there should
be no moral consideration for Charlie Kirk
I'm going to finish the question. Hutch. >> I Hold on.
He just added something kind of crazy at the end. You should
have no moral consideration for Charlie Kirk. Isn't that a little
crazy? Isn't that like a bit far?
>> I If you added that part, I'd be like, "Oh, [laughter]
I just want you to watch a video." >> No, no, you can like
I'm asking something. I will definitely watch your video after
I get an answer and then we we address it. I will definitely
Don't worry about it. Right. So, if it's the case that you have
someone who's watching a video of someone else saying Charlie
Kirk has blood on his hands, he should have no moral consideration
and he kind of doesn't do anything. He just kind of watches it.
Ends up Charlie Kirk gets assassinated. Someone comes up to you
Hutch and said you are culpable. You watched this insane uh video
in which he says no moral consideration should be given to Charlie
Kirk. You don't actually believe it and you have no you didn't
do any push back in that moment. Let me finish the question.
Let me finish the question. >> Oh, I see person in the
video. I see person in the video. >> That person who watched
that video without any push back on the notion that Charlie Kirk
deserves no moral consideration. He didn't push back there. He
let that stand. Would that person be culpable for the assassination
of Charlie Kirk? Yes or no? Did the video that was watched >> I
need to I need to ask you about the video that I hypothetical
video. Did in the hypothetical video that I watched >> did
the creator of that video suggest that someone should like
explicitly suggest that someone should unalive Charlie Kirk?
>> No. No. They he says they deserves no moral consideration.
Whatever happens to him is justified. >> No. That's too
that's too abstract then. No. There's no culpability there. So
that's this is not abstract. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait
a second, hang on. Hang on, hang on a second. Don't you Don't
you agree that there's a risk that someone could get the wrong
impression? Isn't there a risk? >> This is that standard.
>> Hang on a second. So, I'm just asking. >> You
agree with me that Yeah, I knew that she died. Salvation.
>> Isn't there a risk? You agree with me that there's a
>> What I'm trying to prove is what I'm trying to demonstrate
to you is the the mere fact that there's an increased risk does
not imply that there is culpability.
the valitional acts of others cut off the causal chain such that
we imply culpability even if it's the case even it's the case
that you have dangerous rhetoric um such such that um you know
it's possible there's a risk you agree don't you by the way that
um you know Destiny I think he's been based on a lot of his uh
assessments of the double standard hypocrisy of MAGA would you
deny that there is a risk that him saying in refusing to condemn
at times sometimes he does condemn it but at times refusing to
condemn carries risk of the assassination does it carry a risk
I I you kind of lost. So So when Destiny refuses to condemn the
assassination of Charlie Kirk, I I am telling you.
>> Okay. Um I think this is a poor example because Hutch
would have already condemned this, right? It's like a very poor
like Hutch literally is the person who's in the clip who is like,
"Hey, that's really stupid."
Why? This is not a great example of Yeah, Hutch already agrees
with this. But I guess like like this doesn't prove to Hutch.
This doesn't prove anything to Hutch because Hutch is like, "No,
I denounced that." Right? Hutch can operate in abstraction. Hutch
is like, "No, no, no, no. This I already denounced it." Hey,
Hutch, hypothetically, like this would mean that he's responsible
here, right? He's like, "I already denounced that." No, I'm asking
you, would you hold him responsible if it did happen? Would you
say Desi made this guy get shot? Desi Desi did this assassination
>> that he's inconsistent on it. Sometimes he condemns
it, but there are moments. >> I've I've talked all the
time about how Yes. I think I think his rhetoric around that
stuff is way >> Pisco is just flailing. I came into this
late, but the guy is fully aggro. Wait, Makito, but you you do
understand that he's fully aggro because Hutch will not engage
in hypotheticals. Hutch will pretend he doesn't understand hypotheticals
or thought experiments at all. So Pisco is trying to ask him
a question and Hutch goes, "Oh, I man like this is just the way
it is." But then Pisco starts being specific and start trying
to starts trying to pin down
um starts trying to pin people down on like the things they're
saying. And then Hutch basically just goes, "You're a debate,
bro." Hutch has that effect. Hold on. But you don't understand.
Okay, one of two things is true. Either Hutch is being bad faith
here in terms of him not understanding things. Like he is legitimately
doing this to [__] Pisco or he's actually not intelligent
enough to engage in this space. Like unironically
not intelligent enough to engage in the space at all. And I don't
really listen I just don't really care if somebody yells at him
anymore. Like basically Pisco is engaging with Hutch like Hut
like like Hutch is a peer. And if Hutch is incapable of being
a peer, he's either performing that he's too dumb to be a peer
or he's too dumb to be a peer. It's one of the two, right? But
like we could just keep watching. I I'm explaining to you why
Hutch why it's frustrating to watch Hutch here because he cannot
engage, right? Like Pisco is asking an abstract question here
and Hutch is just going to go, "Well, I denounced that." Hey,
hypothetically,
is this true? Uh, but I denounced that. It's literally the breakfast
thing. The breakfast thing will keep repeating. >> All
of a sudden, all of a sudden, there's a uh Republican. >> This
is inconsistent. >> All of a sudden, there's a Republican
even cite, you know, destiny because oh yeah, no moral consideration.
There needs to be equality. Whatever. That would be You would
not say destiny is culpable there, would you? >> You again.
So, so again,
right here, do you guys understand that the issue here
is
Pisco is laying out a hypothetical and saying you wouldn't think
your like former friend, a guy you know who's on your side of
the political aisle, you wouldn't hold him responsible for that,
right? Even if he had some reckless rhetoric, you wouldn't say
he got that guy killed because that's obviously too far, right?
Like when people said that Democrats were getting Charlie because
they called because Democrats called Republicans fascists, that
was obviously wrong. Here's an example from your side. So it's
more easily illustrated to you. And Hutch goes, "Man, I don't
even know. Like I already How am I inconsistent?
That wasn't the question, Hutch.
You You can identify Makito how that's not the question, right?"
Oh, so Makito, are you just saying Hutch isn't intelligent enough
to engage in the space? Is that your argument? because then I
don't really care about Pisco being mean to him.
Like he should find something else to do where he's intelligent
enough to engage. Would you
If like if he's incapable of actually having intelligent conversations,
then why should he be given like protection so that he doesn't
feel bad after the conversations where he refuses to engage?
I would just I would be curious about that. Like what's your
thoughts there? Because it seems pretty obvious to me that he
like is completely incapable here.
And I don't know, it's just very frustrating to watch. >> Well,
there would you >> hold on, I'll back up. >> They
even sight, you know, destiny because Oh, yeah. No moral consideration.
There needs to be equality. Whatever.
>> Maybe he is medicated. Dude, you can't, man. I'm sorry.
Maybe he's just really high right now is not a good answer.
And I I think Pisco's frustration is warranted at a point because
he's trying to have an adult conversation that Hutch is incapable
of having. That would be You would not say Destiny's culpable
there, would you? >> You Again, you're you're
>> again, I had breakfast this morning. Again, I had breakfast.
The hypothetical is simple. I'll just lay it out one more time
in case anybody missed it. Okay, the hypothetical is simple.
If when Destiny hadn't condemned violence in the wake of the
Charlie Kirk shooting, he'd said, "No, I refuse to condemn violence."
and then somebody else got shot and let's say the shooter actually
said, "Well, I'm a Destiny fan and I I actually don't like Republicans."
Would Destiny be responsible? Would Could Destiny be held responsible
in a moral way for that murder? Would he be completely responsible
for it? It's it is obviously the case that you say no. Right?
It's bad rhetoric. He is responsible for reckless rhetoric, for
raising the temperature, for creating an environment where that
could happen, for raising the chance that it happens. He is not
directly responsible for the act. He should not be treated as
though he did the act. And the issue with the CPS call is when
people start trying to dole out punishment. I don't know about
you, but having a.5%
participation in the CPS call is not in my opinion
sufficient impetus to financially ruin somebody, which basically
once you argue it down, everybody agrees that Ethan is just trying
to [__] with people who [__] with him,
right? So that's that's the reason this is all happening. Just
to run through all that logic for everybody again in case you
missed it, right? That's what's going on here. And so when Pisco
asked that question, how culpable would Destiny be? He's trying
to say, I don't think Destiny should be like 100% culpable. I
don't think we should treat him like he just murdered somebody.
I don't even think we should treat him like he 50% murdered somebody.
Right? But Hutch is just going uh like I don't get it. Like I
don't get it. And I think this is performative ignorance because
I, unlike you guys, think Hutch probably is intelligent enough
to engage in these spaces and that this is not him being dumb.
It is him knowing that he's caught. It's him knowing that he
can't defend his opinion and so he pretends to be dumb. That
would be my opinion here is that Hutch is pretending to be dumb
and there needs to be equality. Whatever that would be you would
not say Destiny's culpable there, would you? >> I you again
you're you're >> you wouldn't say it, would you? You are
debate
history right now. We're >> It's a totally It's like an
honestly
totally good faith hypothetical that he's not debate broing on.
I don't know how else to tell people this. He's there's no debate
broing happening here. Hutch is just incapable of engaging or
doesn't want to engage.
It's super clear what's happening.
So I legitimately I would ask Hutch if I could talk to him. I
would say do you not understand or see what Pisco is asking that
it is totally in good faith that it is totally like a he is trying
to explain his mental state to you. He's doing it directly. He's
doing it in a way that should be very absorbable for anybody
who engages in this space. Right.
Well, there's an actual communication problem.
Wait, what what is the communication problem here?
I know what the communication problem is. I just wonder if we
can all identify it together because Pisco is the person who
always engages this way. Hey, I'm saying something that's very
clear, that's very honest, that's very intelligent. I expect
people to understand. And when people go, well, I don't understand.
And then he's very calm and he gives you another hypothetical
and another hypothetical. After like the eighth one, he probably
starts to get quite irritated, right? Because it it seems like
he knows he won. The other person knows Pisco won. And the other
person is just refusing to concede because they've lost the argument.
And Pisco will not say to Hutch, like you're obviously being
bad faith here. Everybody can see
what is being communicated, right? And Hutch is just being bad
faith because he wants to maintain the same stance he's had all
along. He doesn't want to be incorrect. And he is going out of
his way to actually make Pisco look worse and play a victim in
this conversation.
I don't know why because I thought they were friends. I don't
think friends do that to friends that you just like play the
victim, right? That you just say
for hours on end. Oh, you're why are you doing this? You're like
totally debate broing me, right? Or maybe friends could do that
to friends if they really feel like the other person's doing
it. But I'm just telling you that this isn't debate broing. This
is like an it's a hypothetical that is fully and entirely tethered
to what is being talked about. There is no
um in Okay, so this is again him having like physiological impairments
that prevent him from being able to engage in this space, Mikito.
And I do think that if you're making that argument, you probably
need to stop watching Hutch and like uh like like block this
guy out of your mind entirely, right? If your argument is legitimately
Hutch just ain't quick enough, he just like a little too dumb
to keep up here, then I don't know what to tell you. Like I I
think that's crazy. You think I started? No, I'm I Okay. I kind
of thought you started because you were basically saying like
this is what I think is happening with Hutch. Maybe you maybe
you didn't. I'm just I'm kind of laying it out and I'm trying
to do it calmly so that people can understand
exactly what's going on here cuz I think when I do it in the
costic way, if I'm like talking about Hutch the whole time, then
people get really upset and they can't take in the information.
So again, just to prove how not difficult this is, Pisco is arguing
about like basically what share of culpability do you have when
you've done something that indirectly influences an outcome without
directly being responsible for that outcome and maybe not even
believing that outcome should happen. So the example he gives
Hutch is if Destiny were to refuse to disavow violence and then
somebody who was one of his fans shot someone under that exact
same pretext like oh the violence needs to keep happening. They
went yes Mr. Destiny, I will shoot somebody actually and they
did. So, would Destiny be culpable for that murder? Right. Would
it be accurate to say it's Destiny got that person killed? Would
that be accurate? Do you think that would be fair and accurate?
And Hutch goes,
"You're just kind of debate broing me." Sorry, I shouldn't do
the voice for him even. He goes, "You're just kind of debate
broing me right now. I disagree." I don't know if people think
that's unfair. I just disagree, man.
So I do but I do think that's like to me it is totally performative
because it's not unclear what's being said
at all.
>> I just want you to watch a video. I just want you to
watch a video.
>> So Hutch just keeps saying I just want you to watch
a video. I just want you to watch a video. But if he'd engage,
he knows that Piscll wants to settle an issue before going to
the video because
so morally and legally culpable are not the same thing. If you
think if you send your daughter to go get you are culpable morally.
Uh no, no, no, no, no. So even less, what this comes down to
is I don't think Pisco would say Destiny has no culpability there
or Destiny hasn't done anything to contribute to that. That's
not the argument. It's saying if you're responsible and you say
he's responsible and that you treat him as if he's responsible,
is that healthy? Is that a good like consistently applicable
principle to have? And the answer is no. What the answer should
be is about what percentage responsibility do you think is appropriate
to assign him, which I believe is where they're going to go,
right? Around what percentage culpability do you think is appropriate
to assign somebody who has had indirect influence in an event
but not direct influence? and that probably disavows it, but
due to, you know, various factors might not be directly disavowing
it. He's giving a hypothetical that directly relates to denims
in the video Hutch wants to watch. So, Piscll wants to settle
that issue before going into the video because otherwise they'll
just have an emotional discussion afterwards. He doesn't feel
like it will be as fruitful, right? Pretty simple, pretty easy
to understand. >> We don't need to do that. No, we No,
we actually we actually do because this shows that there's a
principle that we we're not going to impose capability. Stop
proposing something that is analogous. Dude, they're not analogous.
You need to explain this. You need to explain the dish analogy
then because what I provided to you. >> Yeah. So, he just
says they're not analogous.
I would want to know in what way they're not analogous because
it seems like Pisco gave a perfect hypothetical that is perfectly
analogous and perfectly illustrates what his issue is here. Uh
yeah, even less, we all agree on this. Hutch is the person who's
pretending he doesn't understand this right now, right?
Hold on. You understand that's what Pisco is saying, right? Even
less. Or are you
perhaps too slow to engage here?
Well, I'm talking through it slowly, so you at least got me to
do it for you.
But you under you understand, right, that like this is Pisco
getting frustrated that he's explained something very calmly
to Hutch and Hutch is going, "Bro, you're debate broing me, bro.
You're like you won't watch the clip." He's just totally he's
just like basically refusing to intellectually engage. He's just
being intellectually dishonest or he's not intelligent enough
to do anything here. Pisco sounds like he's saying well if you
just say somebody's culpable even less with no other information
I am going to tell you that that to me sounds like you're using
culpability as a synonym for responsible as in you are responsible
for this. I can't. If you say someone's culpable for something,
in my opinion, I think with no other information, you just say
that, I think you're saying they're responsible for it. You they
are the primary offender and then I think it's very dishonest.
Why don't they watch the clip first then talk about it after?
Because I think then it's emotionally laden and Pisco wants to
talk about it before any like emotionally charged clips get brought
in. I would assume.
Um, yeah. In any case, it's raised before the clip is brought
up. And Pisco says he wants to address this before it's brought
up, right? But uh honest to God, in Hutch's brain, I think the
way Hutch looks at this is uh is if he sees the chatters, this
if he sees this edited clip from Denims, then he will get emotional
like I do and he won't question me as much. I legitimately think
that is it might not be worded that way in Hutch's brain, but
I do believe that's what he's thinking. So long as he could see
people saying, "Oh, take his kids away." in the chat in this
edited clip, this significantly edited clip. Then Pisco will
stop pressing me. He'll understand that these people are evil
and we can like just go on. >> You said right. Wait, let
me question. You've asked me like five questions, bro. Let me
ask you a question. Would you, if you were watching a video and
then the creator of the video in the video that you're watching
suggested that someone should unalive Tim Pool, would you continue
to watch the video? Hutch is like kind of Hutch is basically
asking a question that's incredibly hamfisted, but Pisco basically
was asking this. He wanted to settle sort of the issue that Hutch
wants to settle, but Hutch seems to not really be capable of
evaluating things in a continuum. And he's just like, would you
keep watching would you? Yes or no. It's funny that Hutch's thought
process is a lot of um like binaries and Pisco is a lot of shades
of gray, but Pisco is the one who we laugh at for doing being
the yes no
>> I would condemn that. I'm just telling that's why and
I would say yes, I might. >> Would you continue to watch
the video? >> Yeah, I might I might continue to watch the
video. I watch unhinged people say unhinged things all the time
now. I would probably although unless I like forgot that off.
Come on, bro. You said POS consideration like wait are >> you
don't think you would turn that off? >> If if I saw a video
in which someone is making a threat of violence, you think I
would automatically turn the video off? >> If somebody
made a spec specific call to action, you would be banned in like
a second if you didn't turn it off, right? >> Wait, the
mere listening to it? >> I mean, you just have to disavow
it. There's like a different level of stuff going on there, too.
>> I've never heard that TS. >> You can't.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I I maybe this >> you've never
heard you've never heard a toss prefer a call to action to an
>> a specific call to action to hurt someone or harm someone.
So again,
like just looking at this situation, Hutch is saying if you watch
content that is toos, you're automatically banned.
When in fact, if he's being honest here, or if he's maybe he's
just illinformed, but you have many types of content you can
watch from a critical perspective that are to on their own, but
if you are saying, I disavow this, here's why this is bad, etc.
If you are educating with the content, there are exceptions for
that. most chiefly YouTube where Hutch has I believe close to
like 800,000 subs. So, it strikes me as odd that he wouldn't
know this and that Pisco is like obviously talking about the
exception here. It seems clear to me from the like right off
the hop Pisco is talking about the exception for critical content.
I hope Hutch doesn't push back against that, but that's clearly
what Pisco is referring to. I think the issue here is that Hutch
legitimately doesn't listen to his debate opponent when he's
debating and he just kind of restates his own opinion over and
over again. And I can understand how that would get frustrating.
And the way you overcome that is you point it out and you say,
"Hey, you're refusing to engage with this, right?" You have to
go to the Mr. Girl meta conversation and say, "Hey, I've like
pointed this out multiple times. I've done it multiple times.
Like you're you're not engaging.
What do we do about this? Like we're friends and I don't want
to just say you're being bad faith, but I think you're smarter
than this and I think you can engage with like the hypothetical
I'm giving you. So I'm curious why."
Um, notice how when when Pisco had here, hold on. Where am I
looking for this here? It's uh what is it? Lib and Learn.
Oh, do I have to go to Lunar Unboxed? I might have to go to Lunar
Unbox. Give me a second because I don't I don't remember where
this video was in the first place. Oh, it's Lib and Learn. But
>> it's not that it's connected to the IRGC though, right?
Because the RGC is also >> All right. All right. Right.
>> Moral Frogging about the Casey draw
>> like this is basically I will go to the breakfast part
here. Oh, he comes in here. Okay. >> Actually, she leaves
videos on, >> but I did have breakfast. But I did have
breakfast. I'm We're trying to get this calls him out for not
doing the hypothetical here. But where is the sniper comment?
Like this is when he has when they're a moderator. >> I
don't know. It really depends on the circumstances, right? Like
what did that person do to me?
>> Is there a Ethan Klein sniper pointing at your forehead
right now? I'll say it. [laughter] Yes, it depends. I think uh
you know in this know what happened like like realistically I
don't really have to do much here to lay this out. I know people
will say oh I'm biased against Hutch but
>> but here's Soyill like obviously just every single time
Pisco lays out a hypothetical he can process it. He understands
it and Soy Pill just goes dude why are you not like why are you
not engaging? Why are you pretending you don't understand at
all? It's very
Right. There's one other point here where like oh is it engage
soy pill calls him out at another point here too. Um
where is [snorts] it? He calls him out at another point I think
before this. Give me a second here. >> Every single
>> Hold on hold on hold on. I I do want to find this really
quickly. Um
>> Hutch these kinds of thing. >> What? Okay. Now
that now I have a very easy like moral question. Hutch. Do you
think it's okay to sue people because you want to financially
ruin them? Uh,
I don't know. It really depends on the circumstances, right?
Like, what did that person do to me?
>> Is there a Ethan Klein sniper pointing at your >> This
is the same This is the same one, dude. Soyill,
dude. Pisco was so patient.
Soyill immediately goes to where Pisco got to eventually, right?
Like, Pisco was so patient with Hutch throughout this conversation
trying to like reframe and reask questions. Like Hutch basically
pretends to not understand the same hypothetical multiple times
and then goes, "Why have you asked me five questions?" That's
because Pisco is being calm and patient with you and trying to
get you to answer the obvious question he's asking.
Which like basically he's also just getting you guys in most
of these cases, he's essentially just gut- what you already think.
But I think there's another element here, which is Hutch seems
a little scared that Pisco is going to trap him. And so Hutch
doesn't want to answer the question. Even in cases where Pisco
is basically just doing like a sanity check. Like it's not even
it's not even a gotcha hypothetical. It's not trying to push
Hutch anywhere specific. It's just like, "Hey, can we just do
a quick sanity check, man? Can we just do a quick sanity check
on this?" And Hutch basically just freezes up entirely.
Okay, give me one sec. I'll be right >> If an individual
is endorsing it, but just merely watching the video. >> Yes.
every platform that you're on. Basically, if you're watching
a video that says someone should really go on a live Tim pool
and you didn't >> and I condemn that. Wait, wait, hang
on. >> No, no, no. You would be banned if you didn't turn
that off, right? >> Wait, I'm not convinced of that. If
if I've I've watched Maybe it's just >> Give me one second.
Give me one second. >> Okay, I don't know. Have you guys
ever heard of that? Like I've watched unhinged people like say
crazy things like we consider and we've analyzed for example
Trump's incitement theories under both legal and we watched the
videos and stuff. We watched Jan 6
>> you got me shouting so I need some
>> Oh no worries. So if you watched a video where somebody
said you know what I really in pool is just the worst and you
know somebody definitely needs to go >> like oh boy that's
so the way man I feel like this would be a good place to like
to almost pull up like if I could use excaladraw to just give
you the idea. So like the way Pisco tries to talk through ideas
is like he wants to I maybe I don't even need to do this and
go like this. Like he wants to dissect the ideas. How would I
apply this here? Basically Piscoll wants to take every oh what's
the word? If he could if he could take every idea every like
independent factor that's going into your decision for some specific
decision. He wants to separate each of these independent factors
and analyze them with specific questions to see how important
each one is, right? Yeah, you could say discreet ideas. So for
this,
Pisco is saying that obviously in a vacuum without further conditions,
if somebody's just saying something bad, we don't blame them
for the thing. And like obviously the disavow might be important.
He's like pulling apart the disavow element. like did they disavow
um how what did they actually advocate for? What did their community
advocate for? He wants to pull all of these things out and see
what's most important, right? And Hutch really wants to keep
these things tied together. And normally when you don't want
to make things independent, when you don't want to pull those
out and engage in the intellectual exercise, I usually think
that means one of two things. either you can't conceptualize
the idea that these ideas are separate or you know that separating
the ideas you basically have a lot of emotional claims from one
portion and you're trying to invoke a different portion. So for
Hutch he's got a lot of emotional claims from like basically
with denims watching that CPS video and the way her community
reacted but he doesn't want the community reaction separated
from how denims acted because he wants to blame denims. wants
them mixed together, right?
Like the whole time he wants all of that stuff mixed together
as much as possible because he wants maximum emotional reaction
from everybody watching. Pisco wants to disentangle these things,
pull them apart, and engage with them all
And Hutch is, every time Hutch refuses to engage in a hypothetical,
Pisco is basically trying to say, "Well, this is the idea I'm
trying to get out." And Hutch kind of just goes, "Can we just
watch the video? Can you just see the CPS call? Like, can you
just see these people type CPS in the chat and then you'll understand?
And I think abstractly Pisco understands everything about that
call. He might not understand the exact elements, but he's trying
to create like a framework for Hutch's thinking. And Hutch doesn't
want that framework made
again for one of two reasons. either he can't conceptualize what
Pisco is doing or he knows that if he actually, you know, independently
analyzes the the pieces the pieces that make up his thought process
here, it might not come out to like as good as it he wants it
to. That's I think the issue we have >> on live him, right?
You you would continue to watch that. >> Yeah. If I was
analyzing it and saying this is a true threat, this is an example
of a true threat. I'll give you another example, right? In the
>> Well, you said you would specifically condemn it, right?
>> Yeah. I mean, it depends on the context. Like if if
if there's I think >> why bec because I do think that potentially
a there could be if I just let it play and don't specifically
address it. I think that there could be action by Twitch. But
again, just because there's action by Twitch or there's a risk
for my channel doesn't mean that I'm accepting culpability if
something bad happens. I just want to be clear about the distinction
there. And second, I do think that there's a moral responsibility
to condemn these acts of violence or even acts for example deception
or whatever. But and I think there's a potential risk and you
should minimize risk where possible. Here's the difference, right?
Mitigation of risk and an obligation to avoid risk doesn't equal
culpability if something bad ends up happening after the fact.
And this is easily you can understand that if you just apply
any of the comparisons that I've talked about that no one >> Yeah.
So basically this doesn't guarantee culpability after the fact
even if you've done something reckless, right? It doesn't mean
you're responsible.
And if you look at the hypotheticals I gave you, you'd see me
conveying that. Does anybody disagree that that's what Pisco
said cuz I guarantee you it's going to be ironic because basically
what I'll see I think from every DJer
when we analyze this ironically is going to be why can't Pisco
just be nice? Why can't why can't Pisco just be nice? Hey, could
you just be nice?
Which if you guys were ever a part of the Destiny community,
you know is a meme because that's what a lot of people said to
Destiny over the years, right? Hey, can't you just be nice? Why
don't you just be nicer to people? Can't you just be nicer to
people? Right? >> In the context that I provided that you're
examining someone saying some unhinged [__] about
Charlie Kirk and then all of a sudden, oops, someone killed him.
No one could ever come to a li and you would defend. You would
say this is insane. You know, he was watching a video of someone
else doing it. He wasn't doing what if there what if I could
show you a video of Denims herself saying that somebody should
call CPS on Ethan? Go for it. I I would say that's independently.
>> So again, this is another I honestly like [__]
how do we how do I do this? I think this is a very scummy tactic,
right? Because he just said, man, maybe I should write some stuff
down though. Okay, [__] Should I do this or should
I get a notepad out? So, hold on. It's um let's get the exact
quote there that Hutch just threw out. Okay. >> Was watching
a video of someone else doing it. He wasn't doing it. But what
if what if there what if I could show you a video of Denims herself
saying that somebody should call CPS on Ethan? >> Oh my
god. >> Go for it. I would say that's independently bad.
Yeah. >> Oh my god. I hate Excaladraw. Actually,
>> what if I told you
now Denims herself saying >> he wasn't
what if there what if I could show you a video of Denims herself
saying that somebody should call CPS on Ethan? >> Go for
it. I would say that's independently bad. Yeah. >> Okay.
saying there's a video call CPS on
>> It's on my stream. >> What if I showed you >> a
video herself
>> saying you should call CPS on Ethan?
>> So, we can all agree this didn't happen, right? Yeah.
We can all agree that this didn't happen. This does not happen.
Even in the video he is purporting to show
that this was not said. Not even the direct quote, but I do not
believe that it was even directly said as in somebody should
do something. I do not believe there was an impetus for action
Right
now, somebody correct me if I'm wrong, but I do not believe there
is any impetus. There's no there's no incitement to action in
that video.
>> Let's see the vid. >> Hold on. I don't know if
Pisco ever pulls it up. That's the unfortunate
>> Hold on. you acting like I have like a problem condemning
denims or Hassan or >> We're getting into all these hypotheticals
though.
>> Okay, so we're getting to all these hypotheticals though.
That's how you have intelligent conversations Hutch is you try
to pick apart the individual elements of your thought process.
It's very exciting stuff but that yeah that's the way it works
man. Okay so this is I believe the clip they pull if I'm not
mistaken. And then then I'm host this and see what she says.
And then now we wonder why people are calling child protective
>> But they called it before I even did this stream.
>> Oh, so hold on. Wait.
This is after that. Okay, that can't be the the video, right?
Cuz this is after.
So this is already not accurate. If he shows a video from after
the fact, then the hypothetical where we say, "Well, people celebrated
Charlie Kirk's death. Does that mean they got him killed?" Obviously,
time only flows in one direction. Yeah, I believe so. Yes, time
only flows in one direction. So, it can't be this. Maybe I'm
wrong. >> You know what I mean? Like, like I Yes.
And I think they >> Hutch, why do you think I'm doing this?
I'm doing this because I don't want you. I love you. I love you.
>> No, she claims it was after. Well, I'm telling you that
in this clip, which is the one I thought they pulled up. >> Well,
let's just listen. But not before
>> all over his mansion. >> Okay, so this Oh, no.
This is the clip. Sorry. This is the clip. I didn't let it probably
related to the fact that his former housekeeper is suing him
for a number of reasons. >> Just to be clear, this is the
highly edited clip. Okay. And we're going to watch the things
Denim said. So this is the claim. Okay.
Claim
is this. So that's the claim is he has a video of Denim saying
this. And then we're going to go to the actual Hold on. actual
actual statements. We'll see what actually gets said here. Okay.
Oh, not this one. This one. >> So, I would assume he doesn't
actually have a housekeeper anymore. Or perhaps he he lost his
extra housekeeper. So, now the house is just like covered in
dog and he's he has kids and his kids like crawl into the dog
and god forbid. I don't know what they do with it. I don't know
if they eat it or if it's just from like contact with it with
their hands or something. But now they can
Oh, so wait. I didn't even realize bad empanada. By the way,
this is how bad Empanado lies is he'll say I don't know what
happened just like contact with their hands. I think he suspects
it's just like contact with their hands or something, right?
But he includes the other because he's obviously making about
Ethan Klein because he hates him. Can't take bad empanada seriously.
>> Contracted a parasite that I had previously never heard
of. >> Yeah. Just real quick. Is this face is this the
Hold on. Is this the call to action? Is this her saying call
CPS? Is this her saying you should call CPS on Ethan Klein right
here? Is that what we're calling this? You should call CPS on
Ethan Klein the face. What do you guys think?
I'd say probably not, but if anybody wants to argue that, feel
free. >> Site that I had previously never heard of in my
life called Giarda from the dog that is all over his true dude.
How is it? How is it that like maybe once a week I I look into
what Ethan Klein's been up to and every time I manage to find
more and more terrible [__] This is where Ethan tells
a story about his family getting giardo. >> We already
have mold Mondays. Now we have Saturdays. >> Also, this
is not a joking matter, by the way. It can be very severe and
deadly to small children. I mean, much like many other illnesses,
it's very, very, very dangerous when infants get the same sicknesses
that adults get. There are lots of things that you can get as
an adult. You're totally fine. You'll be >> okay. Is this
where she said call CPS? So that is So that's a response with
a fact, right? Oh, of often times adult diseases in infants are
really bad.
Is that where she said call CPS? I'm just waiting because eventually
we're going to get to the end of this and I don't believe we'll
have a call to CPS here.
Oh no, she was absolutely reading a chat there. Wait, if it wasn't
clear,
>> get the same sicknesses that adults get. There are lots
of things that you can get as an adult. You're >> Oh, hold
on. Hold on. Let's go back.
>> Also, this is not a joking matter, by the way. It can
be very severe and deadly to small children. I mean, much like
many other illnesses, it's very, very, very dangerous when infants
get the same sickness. >> So, this is not a laughing matter.
It's very scary for infants to get this, right? That's the chat
message. And then she says, "Yeah, much like blah blah blah blah."
That you see the difference, right? Hold on. I don't I didn't
go back >> I look into what Ethan Klein's been up to. I'll
show you. >> Every time I managed to find >> right
after this, she's reading a chat.
>> This is where Ethan tells a story about his family getting
giardo. >> We already have mold Mondays. Now, >> so
there chat message. >> Also, this is not a joking matter,
by the way. It can be very >> still reading a chat message.
Also, this is not a joking matter. very severe and deadly to
small children. I mean, much like many other illnesses, it's
very, very, very danger. >> Much like many other illnesses,
that's where she's talking. Okay, so again,
I have not been writing. I'm probably going to abandon this cuz
I just haven't been writing while I'm listening. I need a different
window that I'm going to pull up if I want to do that. Okay,
actually, yeah, I'll pull this over here. And then if we wanted
to do this, we have to do it at the same time. I'm just doing
this poorly. But in any case,
I don't know where the call to action
>> Dangerous when infants get the same sicknesses that
adults get. There are lots of things that you can get as an adult.
You're totally fine. You'll be a-okay.
No problem. A child, a small infant that has no immune system
shouldn't be catching anything. >> No wonder his house
is covered. >> Uh, by the way, that's like stupid. Small
infants do catch diseases. They shouldn't be catching like very
deadly infections, but they do get sick sometimes. That could
be as simple as somebody who's an adult who is sick is around
your baby while they're not showing symptoms, but are contagious,
right? Like your baby getting sick with something is not indicative
of your parenting skills whatsoever. Right? She says that shouldn't
happen. Um maybe you think that's the call the the call to action
here. That's just a stupid take. That's just a stupid thing.
She said
in dog and his neglected children raised by nannies have contracted
parasites previously unknown to science from the feces. I wonder
why he skipped over all of this cuz everything that he said everything
that I said in this story which by the way was apparently comp
compiled by his crew playing. >> No wonder this was always
sick. Yeah. Yeah. It all makes sense now. It all makes sense
now. It makes sense why he doesn't care about Palestinian children
when he is neglecting his own. How are
>> By the way, that was a chat message
How is this happening? [laughter] How is it happening?
How How is this happening?
So, within that clip, I think we had a couple people who really
wanted to see that clip. Where is the call to action?
Where is anything? The real Dr. Cube, you should probably go
somewhere else. Like, sorry. Just head out.
Um, there wasn't. Okay. So, I think it's pretty clear that there
is no call to action here. I'll read this message real quick,
but I kind of don't want to hear from this person. But couldn't
she make the argument that her reading out chat messages like
that is in the same style as someone retweeting someone? Like,
you aren't the only one technically saying it, but essentially
you endorse it. No, I can't tell if I'm a or not. Maybe that's
too high a standard to have. Yeah. No.
No. Which, by the way, when Ethan tells the story, you could
argue that sounds like a story about neglect.
Okay. I'm just I'm just being honest with you. You could argue
it absolutely sounds like neglect.
In any case, you would never say that that is the standard when
she doesn'tow it. She doesn't say anything to make sure bad empanada
didn't tell people to call CPS, right? I have no idea. I haven't
seen the bad empanada video. Have you seen the bad empanada video?
I would love to see her reaction. I would just assume probably
even less since I know who clipped this and who put it together
and I know that it would look worse if that part was in here
and she said nothing. I wonder why that's not in here personally.
Right. This is the clip Hutch is referencing. I believe this
is the clip Hutch is referencing. Yes, I went and looked it up
and found the Reddit thread when I originally like saw this.
So, I'm pretty sure this is the the thread he is or sorry, the
clip he is talking about. So his claim was just to remind you
guys, what if I showed you a video of Denims herself saying you
should call CPS on Ethan? I'll remind you as well that we should
also engage with the fact
that very clearly Ethan under advice of counsel had to apologize
to Dems for even intimating this. Not for saying it outright.
Well, actually I think he did say it outright at one point, but
he also implied it and he had to apologize even for the implication
that she did this. even for the implication that she was involved
that she had called for people to do it. All of it. Right. So,
we literally have on the record Ethan Klein saying, "My lawyer
made me say this statement so I don't get sued by Denims." Like,
she gave him a letter of intent. I think you've defamed me. And
he went on his stream and went, "I take this back and you'd be
stupid if you thought I said this. Don't show Hutch that because
he will feel very down about himself." Okay. I hear no called
to action. I hear narrative crafting and specific seed planting
with plausible deniability.
So, she doesn't like Ethan Klein.
How many of you guys
Let's just be It's a It's a less harmful rumor, but how many
of you guys are totally happy to say JD Vance couch? Lots of
people, right? So, it's not the It's not the disingenuous like
I'm not going to deny this. I'll kind of lean into it and think
it's funny. It's not that part we don't like, right?
It's like, okay, some kind of like actionable thing that nobody's
saying call CPS, right? Sorry. Like no streamer saying you should
have called CPS on Ethan from what I saw.
All right. People were basically saying this guy's like a terrible
parent because he just told a story about his kids possibly eating.
I don't think that's wrong. I don't think that is something that
I'm going to go actually you're a horrible person if you say
those things.
Especially when you already are on record hating Ethan Klein.
I'm sorry. I just don't think so. He gave all the ways that somebody
could do that could could give that implication. I do think you
should say what Denim said after the CPS call which is it's obviously
insane to ever call somebody in real life to take real life action
over something like this or it's basically always like if if
it's there I will tell you but otherwise do not cross the line
right we are talking about how hold on but Makito just to be
clear Ethan Klein did say
it's a very fair takeaway from the clip where Ethan Klein's talking
about his kids eating to think that he's saying that right He
clears it up later. He says, "Oh, later. Oh, well, actually,
I didn't mean that." But from the clip itself, he seems to think,
"My kids got giardia. You only get Gardia from eating poop. My
kids put everything on the ground in their mouths." You take
those three statements, there is a natural logical conclusion
there that's very easy to follow. Yes. And so I think what the
actual bad action is here, what the actual bad thing to do is
is to take
in my opinion like a fair statement, which is it sounds like
Ethan Klein said his kids eat dogs on his podcast without looking
into it. It's like that's pretty
right? I I think that's you should have some level of intellectual
rigor. You should want to know if it's true or not, but realistically,
I don't have that much I have condemnation for it, but it's like
I have condemnation for so many streamers that do this that it
almost doesn't matter. So we go from there and we say what is
the actual bad action? It would be basically saying that action
should be taken based on those statements, right? Like you just
basically that is where I I call I draw the line personally is
if you're saying any action should be taken based on those statements
other than probably talking to Ethan Klein and going like hey
you you mean this or checking in with somebody like there's no
way an authority should be brought into the system at this point
in my opinion.
Okay, that more factf finding is required before including some
authority. And if you have the time to include the authority,
you have time to do more factbinding.
Okay? Because I do believe by the time CPS is called, there is
a clip on the record that exists where Ethan Klein is saying,
"No, I up. That didn't happen. I I misspoke. My bad." Right?
So that's where I would have actual condemnation is people advocating
for some kind of action. I think it's bad that Denims didn't
catch these things, but I don't think she's remotely culpable
for the call happening because of the because of the clip. And
I think the only reason people think that's the case is because
of how this clip was disingenuously edited and presented to them
at the time. Pretty easy to follow, right? that they basically
intentionally edited this chat to make it look far worse and
then after doing so presented it a way that said she was responsible
in despite the fact that Ethan Klein literally had to apologize
to her. Literally had to issue a correction when he said he felt
she was responsible. I just don't see what's even like contestable
here. So we can keep >> So now the house is just like >> Oh,
we don't have to keep rolling with this though. We're back to
the debate.
So Hutch presented all of that. Okay. Um, it's not enough information
either way to say they're fine, parents are not. I almost feel
like the nanny, they filed the lawsuit literally a week's Oh,
yeah, sure. That's possible, Alpha Kilo. I've seen the nanny
theory as well.
>> To weave out like there's no comparison here. And like
>> you're doing so Hutch just got mad that Pisco's asking
him for hypotheticals, saying trying to distill his thought process
down. >> And Pisco finally says, "You're being a weasel,
so I have to do this." >> We're getting into all these
hypotheticals, though, though. Like you know what I mean? Like
like I Yes.
And I >> Hutch, why do you think I'm doing this? I'm doing
this because I don't want you I love you. I love you, my boy.
To weave out. Like there's no comparison here. >> you're
you're doing this to avoid the possibility that these creators
did something that was extremely harmful. >> If they What
evidence is there of that? What? There's literally no evidence
of this. Like so again, in terms of good faith, bad faith, Pisco
is I' I've established Pisco's line of reasoning,
Like it's very obvious. It's very on its face, direct and clear.
And Hutch has just accused Pisco of basically operating in bad
faith of saying, "You're using these hypotheticals to obfiscate
from the fact that these people are bad."
Clear emotional plea, clear like appeal to emotion, right? That's
obviously what's going on here. And people will paint Pisco as
the person who's acting in bad faith. I just don't see it. The
times where Pisco says something where it could be framed as
him acting his bad faith, I do believe will get corrected within
like 10 to 15 seconds when Hutch goes, "Hey, why are you saying
that?" And his go or sorry, Pisco will go, "No, I didn't mean
that." or something, >> If they advocated for CPS, I'm
telling you right now, I'm going to condemn
>> Even Even if they even, by the way,
>> so Pisco immediately cuts that down, that bad faith
accusation. He says, "Literally, if they if you could show me
a clip where they advocated for this, I will immediately I can
condemn that now without even having to see it, but you have
to show me the clip." >> No, even if they're just >> Let
me watch the clip. Let me just let me just watch the clip. Hold
on. I'm pressing play. I'm pressing play. >> I'm um further
indicative of Hutch being like incapable of describing his thought
process, describing what he likes about this clip or thinks about
this clip. He's just been given this clip. He's not going to
say what happened. Well, he tried to say what happened, which
was she obviously called for CPS to be called, which didn't happen,
by the way. >> Telling you in advance. I don't even need
to see the clip. I'll I will see the clip, but I'm just telling
you in >> I want to see the clip. >> If if they laugh
about it after the fact, I'll condemn that, too. Guess what?
It doesn't resolve the issue. >> But you don't you don't
think Okay, hold on. Let me watch the clip. I'm done talking
for a second. Hold on. Yeah. >> Okay. I don't even know
if you get the audio from Pisco side. So, it's the clip we watched.
>> Denim ability
>> So, let's see. This first time H. It was Denim's chat.
>> I hope you're not. >> So, he had no idea what
he was talking about. He had no clue what he was talking about.
But he is looking at the edited chat clip. Okay.
Right. He's looking at the edited chat clip that Ethan had to
apologize for platforming as well. And he's going, "Oh, it was
Denim's chat
covered in dog."
So again, Pisco is the person who properly calibrates his confidence
and his ideas based on the evidence he is aware of. And Hutch
is the person who says emotionally, uh, CPS skulls, CPS skulls,
CPS skulls, denims did CPS.
>> Oh, hold on. >> I hope you're not going to impose
some kind of strict liability for what your chat says. That's
insane. And you're never going to >> You're nuts.
You're nut. You don't think Hang on. If if >> so Hutch
has perfectly This is a reason I don't think Hutch is too dumb
to participate in these conversations and that it's really probably
just actually bad faith. So Hutch just seamlessly went from getting
his whole claim incorrect to pressing Pisco on like you're crazy.
You don't hold chats. You don't hold streamers accountable for
their chats. Everything said in chat.
Do you see how Pisco didn't even get a chance to say so your
original claim is clearly false? you lied to me or you just didn't
care to be informed. Your confidence was way out over the skis
of the evidence you had. And realistically, Pisco, if I was talking
to Pisco, and I'm not Pisco's boy, okay? If I was talking to
Pisco, he would probably demand that I acknowledge and concede
that I've way overplayed my hand and that I looked foolish for
doing so. But because he likes Hutch, because Hutch is his boy,
he just I think he lets this go. We'll see.
If >> your chat Are you kidding me? >> Hang on. If
your chat was spamming, call the cops on Rob Noir. You wouldn't
tell them to not call the cops? >> That's not what I said.
Wait, wait. >> So he's now actually calibrating his his
confidence to the edited clip and saying they're spamming this
stuff, right? When in fact, it was not spammed at all. Right.
So he's actually switched up. He's totally pivoted. his original
point hasn't been called out for it.
Now that to me that's Pisco is like desperately trying to make
Hutch not look bad in this conversation and Hutch is desperately
trying to make Pisco look as bad as possible.
Um I'll never ever make a comment on who should be friends with
who cuz I think that is giga cringe. Okay, it's super gay to
go wait you don't think you don't think you should be you should
be friends with this guy. He's like a bad person, right? Let
somebody else decide that. What you can do is say, "Hey, you
had like some principle here that you said you wouldn't associate
with someone over. Is that appropriate to keep associating with
the person who violates that principle?" But in general, Hutch
isn't violating some principle Pisco generally has. So, I'll
never say they shouldn't be friends. But I sure wouldn't try
to do this to one of my friends to go, "Oh, like I'm just going
to never engage. I'm going to like totally be bad faith. I'm
going to totally you over in this conversation."
No, no, thank you. >> And he's gross. Gross. Okay. >> That
is not what I said, Hutch. I didn't say that. Do you have a responsibility?
>> Yes. That doesn't mean you're creator. >> Yes.
That doesn't mean you're culpable. You understand the difference
there? Just because you have a >> does. What do you mean?
>> No, it [__] doesn't. If someone ends up
So, you're saying if I failed to do my due diligence in uh like
saying and giving an affirmative thing, hey guys, I don't agree
with this and you shouldn't call the cops on Rob No. If I don't
do that and if I just let it play out either because I don't
see it. >> Sorry. Sorry. I'm saying that Pisco should probably
sort this out because this was tragic. This was like actually
quite embarrassing.
You know what I'm saying? Like I think if if someone had done
this to me, well, you saw me with Rey. Really is my friend last
night. I felt like he was being condescending. I just like called
them on it, right? I didn't let this [__] go. I was
like, "Oh, you're being like I feel like you're being condescending
right now." I said, "I feel right. I don't think that's inappropriate."
I'm saying Pisco's got to address this that like you're like
the facial expressions, the refusing to engage in hypotheticals
making Pisco chase him down and then him Hutch trying to call
Pisco bad faith irrelevant lied about Queenman. I don't think
so. I mean regardless of what this specific language was there
it was very obvious what the issue was and then they both just
kept fighting afterwards for no reason >> because I'm negligent
cuz I'm just twiddling my thumbs. You think I have >> Wait,
Bell pal, you have to understand that when people are laughing
about Kelly Jean doing it, it's because she's clearly doing it
because she's clearly incapable of like engaging with hypotheticals.
It's funny, right? It's like a It's like somebody who's trolling
but they're not trolling. This is meant to be Hutch is not a
troll, right? Hutch has a totally different role. He makes content
on a totally different basis. Hutch explicitly,
right,
is somebody who is trying to have a real world impact on politics
and be a serious political actor. So, it's a way, it's like a
comparison that you should already feel like if that comparison
is made about you, like you're probably already lost. >> Billy
[__] who does that? >> No, no, no, no. That's
not what I said, though. Let me give you a hypothetical. You
love hypotheticals. Let me give you a hypothetical, right?
Let's say all of us on uh >> Dude, so so nice of Pisco
to not point out that Hutch made a claim with no evidence like
got way out over his skis, right? Didn't do that. Didn't point
out that
he's Okay, he did point out that part of the chat where Hutch
is like I guess he didn't point out the pivot either. So he didn't
make him concede that he was way over his skis. He didn't point
out the pivot without any acknowledgement of Hutch for how wrong
he was. And that's how bias works, right? Like Hutch Hutch still
thinks he was correct despite being way like hyper overcalibrated
here. Way overcalibrated.
>> Live and learn something. >> Me Soy Pill and uh
uh IRI. >> We all watch the same video independently with
our own viewers.
>> And in that video, somebody makes a claim and then and
then and then like all of our chats are like spamming, you know,
like somebody needs to call call the cops on Rob Norn. Yeah.
>> Okay. And then somebody calls and we don't do anything.
We don't police it at all. And then somebody calls the cops on
Rob No.
>> Are are none of us culpable or are all of us culpable?
>> You're not c >> I mean it I'm sorry. Unless you've
explicitly like read the message and
>> huh, maybe you should do that. Yeah, you're not culpable.
You're not culpable for missing chat messages. Which, by the
way, the reason Hutch can't perceive that maybe
Denim's missed these chat messages is because
it has been edited, right? This clip has been edited so significantly
that he thinks there's just no way she could miss all of this.
I think if this were the real chat, I would agree with him. Like,
probably if that's how if it was like 90% of chats that were
all talking about CPS,
oh my god. Oh my god. Like I would probably actually start to
say like you do share like a significantly larger portion of
culpability than otherwise thought. But that's going to be what
this will come down to is how likely was Denims to have seen
these things or seen how prevalent it was or even thought they
were bad cuz like that's child endangerment. What's being described
by Ethan Klein is probably child endangerment. He realized it
was stupid to say it that way which is why he corrected it. Actual
worst father ever. Holy [__] That is not a condemnable
Right. So, if you want to count through these, call CPS, CPS,
social services, like these are calls to action that in my opinion
should be moderated in my opinion. Okay. He has kids and his
kids like crawl into the dog and god forbid. I don't know what
they do with it. I don't know if they eat it or if it's just
from like >> the CPS messages do show up in the top right
corner. I just wanted to let that none of us are culpable. No,
the culpable party is the party that parties that encouraged
it um explicitly with their intention, their active intention
to do so um and those who did it. That's what's that is the culprit.
>> Okay. I mean, we just have we just have philos like
major philosophical differences between like responsible content
creation because >> so I I I want to under so I want you
to apply this standard.
So I get I wish Pisco just asked like what if Denims didn't see
those messages
>> standard that you're just setting now anytime that there's
because there have been leftwing acts of violence >> oh
bro what >> standard standard that you're just setting
now >> did I miss see this >> look like there's some
major shaking >> time
there's
there have been
major acts of violence and there are chats that uh will talk
about this kind of saying you know the These people should there
are you know these people exist. You know these people exist.
>> Of course. Yeah. Of course. >> And you would never
you would never say well because you failed to moderate your
unhinged chat >> as opposed to saying okay you have a responsibility
didn't upkeep it. I would agree with that. No doubt >> but
that you're capable for the action. That's insane. That's strict
liability for what your [__] chat does. I maybe we're
getting hung up on the term, but I think like at minimum you
could say that you through your inaction and through your tacit
endorsement really of what >> you can't say something that
someone could conceivably argue they're unaware of. You can't
say they're they're responsible for something they could conceivably
be unaware of. Right. That's pretty goofy, man. That's pretty
goofy, >> That empanada was was >> Do you think Hutch
would be like this if the conversation was offline? I So there's
two options here because I don't think so.
I don't think so.
But man, it depends on what he's doing. If this is all performance,
then no. But if this is him legitimately being incapable
of like understanding on an intellectual level what Pisco is
saying,
which I don't believe, but that is probably the argument people
have to make to excuse the behavior, then it might end up playing
out like this again. was saying in that video and then you like
ignoring your chat like multiple people in your chat and you
>> straight away you think you're asking about Pisco side.
No, Pisco would be rudder like more rude. Absolutely. I'm saying
Hutch might be the same way if it's all if it's not a performance.
If he's really just incapable of understanding or intellectualizing
in any way, if he's just like a basically like a demagogue who
is pretending to be a liberal, then that's kind of rough. All
right, that would be a rough
>> Like you're looking at she looks at her chat constantly.
She chose to not like do anything about those comments in that
moment.
Like at that point,
I'm not talking about legal. I'm not I just want to be clear.
Wait a second. Wait a second. I'm not talking about legal culpability.
I am talking about ethical culpability. I just want to be clear.
I'm not complaining. No, I'm seeing people in the chat. So, I'm
only talking about ethical copility. But go ahead. >> That
Yeah, this is a major philosophical difference between you and
me. I think if you are a creator and you're seeing specific calls
to action,
especially something as serious as government
>> So, this is where these things will become a little
confusing again. Okay, the what's going to happen, you're going
to see a lot of these sort of um what do we call it like um slides.
There's these little slides that happen when somebody's being
very disingenuous
intentionally or not. So, this could also just be a ton of bias.
A ton of emotional work is being done by Hutch here where he's
he's very emotional. He's incapable of like logically analyzing
the situation. We see these slides over and over again. So the
original claim, one more time, what if I showed you a video of
Denims herself saying you should call CPS on Ethan? That was
the original claim. Now it's slid down to the chat, right? Pisco
is going to say, "Wait, you can't be responsible for the chat."
Then it's going to be, "Oh, well, she's responsible cuz she saw
it and didn't do anything." Pisco is going to ask, "Are you responsible?"
Or, "Sorry, are do you know she saw it? Do you know for sure
that she saw it?" Hutch is of course going to I I don't know
if he's actually going to cope there. I assume that's the question
and then I would assume he copes there
and tries to say yes, but obviously the answer is no, right?
And these slides will keep happening. So it's going to be here's
another slide. I'm going to predict the slide from she's culpable,
she's responsible to well she's partially culpable. And then
they're going to say well no I like obviously you could be partially
culpable for something. Who says she's partially culpable? who
doesn't say the maximal thing they think they can get away with
here, which is she's she's culpable, she's responsible, she did
CPS, she participated in CPS, which is what gets said by all
of these people, right, until they're called out. And we're going
to see that slide back to like, oh well, she's partially culpable.
And it's like a little bit, but it will never ever ever ever
just be honest from the start. And that's how you know that there's
like a lot of bias involved. That's how you know that this guy's
not operating at good faith most of the time and is not coming
to his opinions through good faith. Now, I as a drama streamer
also do this sometimes, okay? I'll I'll have things that are
like um overextended. What I found is better is I like operating
on emotion a lot of the time because it tends to be better content,
not be super dry like I'm being right now, where I like pop off
and joke and have a great time. I think that's better content
most of the time. that can offend people and I found the best
approach for that to deal with it is just to be humble when somebody
says I think you're being like extreme here I'll go oh you know
what I'm that's totally fair maybe let's let's evaluate it I
might be I I like have some bias here I might be right so you
just need that humility but I don't see that humility in Hutch
or basically anybody who argues this stuff ever
see the humility except for in that one case that one guy who's
on I think I think Pisco stream that he was eventually on loner
box. He was like from loner box community. That guy I talked
to that guy when I talked to him right that guy we were like
laughing at
when I talked to him I literally said I literally was like oh
like I think you're being like way too um you're way too overconfident
for how much information you have. And he was like yeah that's
probably true. I regret that. My bad. It's like oh well that's
all I'm dude if you're intellectually humble about it. That's
all I need. Thank you. Bye >> vention on somebody that
you don't like. you have a responsibility to step in at that
point and say, "Guys, otherwise you're culpable way too far."
>> Excuse me. >> Otherwise, you're culpable.
>> Otherwise, you have contributed to like that event happening
in some small way or you could at the very least potentially
have done it. The the reality is we can't know who made that
call. Was it someone from Assange's audience? Was it someone
from her >> That doesn't relieve you of the burden of showing.
We don't know. That doesn't >> in it in it. >> That
doesn't I don't know what is the point of like we we knew this.
What what's the butt here? Yeah, we don't know. It can't be but
we do know some people who are like a little bit maybe responsible
so we can hold them responsible in wake of a actual
Is that that can't be where you go here, right? That's like obviously
speaking of like a liberal ideas. [laughter] I think I think
we should treat them like they're guilty until we find the person
who is guilty. Sounds kind of crazy to me. >> Relieve you
of your burden to show that that they are culpable. You just
because it's hard to to find evidence of the particular thing
that shows culpability doesn't relieve you of your responsibility
to show it. But you're >> culpable. Do you hear like 100%
>> No. I I hear I would hear morally culpable for the thing
occurring >> as in it is as a I think this is what Pisco
should have said but I'm thinking about it after the fact. It's
not that easy in the moment. I think basically the way you test
this is if you say
X is responsible for Y.
That feels like a good statement in a vacuum. And what I would
say there is probably they need a plurality or majority of the
blame for that to be an accurate statement. Unless if you want
to be you could be more accurate. You could say denims is partially
culpable in some way for CPS, but you don't do that because you
need to reach your what you believe needs to reach the level
of your emotion here, right? So if you say, well, she's kind
of partially culpable, like she definitely holds some of the
blame, maybe not that much, then you can't argue that she deserves
to be sued and have like her livelihood threatened, right? That's
that doesn't reach that level of culpability. So I like I don't
know what else to say to people there. It's just obviously bias
that makes you say she's culpable as a statement in a >> That's
what I understand it to be. >> So he's So there is this
there is the predicted slide of wait when I say she's culpable
for this or responsible for it. Like she deserves the blame for
it. Are you hearing that she deserves all of the blame for it?
Cuz I got a lot of blame to go around. It's like well when you
only say her name you say she's responsible for it. You say she's
to blame for it. You say she's culpable for it. I get the in
my head. And then by the way, and then your statement to start
the segment
is, I will show you a video of Denims herself saying you should
call CPS. You just believe this. You believe she is personally
very responsible for this at a level that way exceeds reality.
It's way out past reality, and you can't defend that. Okay. So,
when Hutch says, "Well, are you hearing mostly responsible?"
Yeah. Based on what you've been saying in this debate, I'm hearing
mostly responsible. I'm hearing like all like a ton of the responsibility
here. And again, literally at any point if anybody wants to call
in and argue any of these things, go ahead. I'm perfectly happy
to have anyone on who wants to come and argue what I'm saying
here cuz this feels totally inarguable. And I don't know how
you can look at Pisco and say, "Oh, Pisco is being bad faith
here." And take yourself seriously
like as any sort of intellectual person who's trying to do things
intellectually on the internet.
She's not culpable at all. I mean, she shares the it's like a
level of culpability. I think I've used the example of like you're
smoking at a restaurant and then somebody 10 years later in that
restaurant gets cancer. Like you have you probably contributed
in some way or you could have actually contributed in some way.
But it is an evaluation of how likely that is to happen, how
much you could have expected it happening and what you knew and
did at the time. How aware are you that cigarettes cause cancer?
Right?
But it's like a very complicated question for that level of sort
of like disconnected causible or disconnected causal culpability
and nobody wants to engage in that. It's just Denims did CPS
and what if I showed you a video of Denim saying her Denims herself
saying you should call CPS on Ethan. So boom. >> You're
you there's a shared culpability is my point. And you're you
you I think you're using that like uncertainty about where the
call came from as a means to just like not culpable in a way
that is considerable to me. Um I think you could say that Denims
did a bad thing by not moderating her chat at all by like not
seeing it. Like basically if she saw it and she didn't moderate
it, that's like a pretty bad thing. That's pretty frustrating.
But you can't pretend that she foresaw her chat going and calling
CPS or somebody calling CPS even, right? because it probably
wasn't very foreseeable based on the circumstances.
I just disagree. >> Like deflect all responsibility. Like
you're saying that they had no ethical obligation to moderate
their own chat as they're like like making suggestions to >> What
what you're culpable for what you're culpable for is what you
>> like I would say I would say even for the people saying
call CPS. I don't think you have to ban those people. I think
you could just put your opinion on the record and say, "No, that's
insane." You would never call CPS over this. You'd like ask for
more information before doing that. That's like a crazy thing
to do, right? >> You did wrong. What you did wrong was
failure to moderate appropriately your chat. What you're not
capable >> No, I don't think you have to ban them. That's
like saying swat them. It's bad.
The tough thing for me is when somebody says call CPS, it's like
uh in my head I'm like I do believe it's really bad. But I do
think that you could easily say no, that's totally deranged.
Stop calling. And I would say stop calling for that or you're
going to get timed out or something. I wouldn't have to like
ban those people immediately. I'd probably personally I think
the way I've handled in the past when people are saying we got
to take extra judicial action if somebody says that it's like
that's crazy. Do not say that. Off. You'll be timed out if you
say that going forward. Right. able for is actually calling CPS.
That is >> if you were in Ethan, if you were in Ethan's
shoes, just try to imagine. >> That's not No. So, so we're
>> Oh, yeah. Exactly. is also that K1 Dev is like you're
responsible for the things you could foresee based on you not
monitoring your chat in this instance with regards to Ethan Klein
and the CPS calls. And it's like realistically,
if she was just like not paying attention, I don't think there'd
be a lot of moral culpability there. Oh, hi by hi by hi by hi
by. Now I need to go see who that was. Who just joined my voice
chat and then dipped out. Who did that? Who did that [__]
Morow. Get the [__] out of here. Morow. >> I
can totally grant that if I accept all of Ethan's priors. If
I take his point of view. We're not talking about from his lights.
Does he think it's justified? He's doing it. I suppose. >> No.
But I'm asking you. I'm asking you to just imagine like >> who
would you have blamed? Do you think
so what Hutch is literally saying he's he's this is Hutch's argument
here which again I think people would probably feel is absurd
coming from anybody on any other topic right but because it's
coming from Hutch and because it's against Pisco and because
it's on the topic of Ethan Klein people are willing to excuse
this argument Hutch's argument here is can't you imagine that
Ethan would blame this Um, okay. I don't Yeah. Why do you think
Why do you think we don't let like the the parents of some kid
who got murdered decide the penalty for the murderer? Like, yeah.
That no, he's going to have you're you're literally saying, would
we expect the person with compromised judgment to blame these
people? Yeah. And it would be incumbent on you as somebody who
cares about them or purports to somebody who is like their friend
or is like pseudo network to them to say while I understand their
emotion I obviously disagree in principle on
right
pretty obvious pretty clear think you you you could understand
blaming like the whole pool of creators that were all dogpiling
and encouraging it and joking about it laughing about it even
encouraging it >> blaming them for the [__]
CPS showing up at your house. >> That's unhinged. That's
unhinged. That's what they're >> That's unhinged. No, you
would. >> So, so I want to hear you say it then. So, so
I'm going to give you another >> You'd be like, "Well,
we can never know. We can't blame any of them." You would not
do that, bro. >> If your comm >> Well, we don't know.
So, you can't blame any of them. >> Wait, but that is Hutch
is like arguing that Ethan needs a martyr to be taken down. He
needs like some totem of responsibility here that he can direct
all of his anger towards, right? Like, is that what is the argument
there?
unhinged. No, you would. So, so I want to hear you say it then.
So, so I'm going to give you another example. >> You'd
be like, well, we can never know. So, you can't blame any of
them. You would not. >> What? What is the argument, man?
What is the argument?
>> So, we can't blame any of them because we don't know.
That is what he's saying. Yes. Listen, that lady got murdered
in Central Park and there's a Central Park 5. And until we get
somebody better to blame, those black kids got to go to jail.
Okay. Those black kids got to go until we find somebody else
better to blame. That's that's Hutch POV. Okay, Hutch POV, those
those totally anim animalistic blacks from the Central Park 5
need to be imprisoned. Okay, that's the one hyperbolic moment.
We're just going to go back to being regular again. Do that,
bro. >> If your community
actively encourages doxing
and you fail to moderate that doxing and then doxing in fact
occur,
is the streamer culpable for doxing? I'll tell you. I'll tell
you what how I would feel. No, I'm asking if you could. >> No,
I'm telling you. I'm telling you exactly. I'm telling you exactly.
Like like I like I'm imagine me. All right. And and I found out
that >> I love that Pisco is explicitly defending me here
is explicitly saying that like like even under the argument,
even if I granted you everything Destiny says is true, would
that mean that you can dox other people in return? Hutch. And
Pisco says, "No, that would not mean that. Thank you, Pisco.
You got my back up high. Let's go." High five. Boom. Let's [__]
go. >> Somebody in my community docked someone and and
there was a thing that maybe we missed like I was looking away
from chat or something like that. I would feel like I would feel
>> distracted. I'm giving >> I would feel responsible,
but we're not asking about your emotions, Hutch. I we the handle
for the emotional argument is like I could agree with you and
I understand that you'd feel responsible. I understand that you'd
feel emotional. We're not asking for emotions. We're asking for
we're going to sit down after the fact and try to logically analyze
this situation and figure out who's responsible and what happened.
That's what I would want you to do,
right? So, while I understand your emotion, I respect that that
you're an emotional guy and you got emotional and you feel responsible
in that situation. It wouldn't really be helpful to like ban
yourself from the platform for a month because you you missed
a chat message, right? That wouldn't be that wouldn't be responsible.
That wouldn't be justice
if they just took your emotion and you like self flagagillated
and punished yourself. That wouldn't make any sense. Like I man
I don't know. I But apparently Pisco is the the crazy person
in this conversation. >> Giving you an example. >> I'm
giving you an answer. >> So no no you didn't answer that
question. You said what you would do that you would feel responsible
if some other happened even when you you were negligent. That's
not what I'm talking about. I'm talking about a situation in
which community doxes, you're aware of it and you don't moderate
it and intentionally you don't moderate. You see it's there and
you don't moderate.
>> I think I think he means advocating >> streamer
culpable for the doxing.
>> I think they are partly responsible.
>> Okay. So it's a standard you would apply that the >> sure
that by the way with nothing with no other information Hutch
just said nothing. That could be from 0.001% 01% to 99.99999%.
He just said literally nothing. And if you guys have been keeping
score at home, he's essentially not made a rational statement
in about 10 minutes.
Unless I'm missing something. I do not believe he's made he's
put forth an argument that hasn't relied on emotion directly.
I do not believe he set an example that he hasn't up because
of his
It's just been emotion after emotion after emotion and very little
in the way of any dispassionate [clears throat] analysis of the
situation >> that the mere non-modderation decisions >> as
to your community gives you culpability for the attacks however
attenuated
um to that might occur because uh you know you you failed to
moderate your community even though those actions >> that's
what I'm saying because I [clears throat] don't know what attenuated
means because I don't know what attenuated means I assume Hutch
doesn't know what it means and Hisp has been using the word a
lot. So, having been reduced in force, effect or value, it appears
likely that the courts will be given an attenuated an attenuated
role in the enforcement of these decisions. As in like it's not
the thing, it is a far more diminished version of the thing.
Okay. I I >> I can't I can't I listen I can't believe that
I'm I'm a bit incredulous right now because you seem to be you
you seem to be totally closed off to the possibility that is
I'm going to actually lay it out here at least since I've started
on this stream. I do not believe Hutch has said a thing that
Pisco could concretely engage with and I can't possibly believe
that he's unaware of this fact.
Right? Is there any way he could be unaware of this fact that
he has not actually laid anything out? Any any claim, any concrete
claim he has made, he has been incorrect on. And yet
propagandists would tell you that Pisco this conversation up
that Pisco is the person who ruined this conversation. And Hutch
is sitting here and saying, "It just seems like you're really
closed off to the idea that anything could happen." What, man?
Man, what are you saying? Right? Like I I think it's kind of
bordering on a miracle that Pisco stayed this calm. streamer
has any any reasonable um like expectation of being
>> because other
I literally said the opposite >> that's
yeah so now he's actually misunderstanding and again this one
I don't think is intentional I think he is emotional again and
he doesn't understand what Pisco is saying Pisco's already said
I think you would be uh culpable for not moderating your community
you'd be culpable for the action you did not the action that
resulted um in some part because like uh possibly without knowing
the probability you're you're not directly responsible for that
thing and you would have to you know do some analysis to figure
out what portion of that responsibility you might share. Yeah.
Okay. >> So I want to be clear that >> like if and
this could go all the way up to like 99.999%
right like there's some circumstance where somebody says hey
I'm going to dox this person if you don't talk to me if you don't
like you know if you don't read this message on stream. Oh man,
no. I somebody you know that you had like a coordinated effort
with to dox somebody and you you say you read the message where
they dox the person. It's like there's some way that you could
be as culpable as that person, right? as a chatter, but it's
like basically fully endorsing, having full awareness of and
totally like aiding and abetting that action taking place, which
is obviously not the case here
that I literally >> What's the point? What's the point
of first? I'm going to establish that what you just represented
is literally the opposite of what I said. So, you heard me, didn't
you, when I said that there is a responsibility to moderate.
You heard that. >> Did you hear that? What >> did
you hear? So, I asked I'm asking you if you heard me say that.
>> So, Hutch has just accused Pisco of something Pisco
has stated the opposite principle of in this debate.
And so Hut so Hutch just made a bad faith or illinfor uninformed
like he's not listening accusation
that is like directly undermining Pisco's integrity.
And Pisco says yes or no. Did I not say you're you're responsible
for moderating your chat? And Hutch will not answer that. Or
sorry he might. He might eventually. We'll see. >> All right.
You heard that? >> Did you hear that? What? >> Did
you hear as I'm asking you if you heard me say that? >> I'm
trying to make sense of what you're saying because I just want
to make sure you heard it when I said it. >> Hang on. What
you're saying is contradictory to me because otherwise Well,
what is the point of moderation >> So, I just want to make
sure you heard me. Can you answer that question? >> I will.
But can you answer? >> Yes, I heard you. What's the >> Okay.
So, so when Pisco says, "Did you hear me?" He's basically asking,
"Did you just intentionally lie about me?" Right. Did you just
intentionally lie about my position?
And realistically, I actually don't know if I could blame Hutch
for this one. Awesome sauce, thank you for the five gifted. Let's
go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. It's another hour on the
stream right there. You love to see it. >> You love to
see it. Thank you so much, Awesome Sauce. Appreciate you. So,
I don't believe I believe this is Hutch has now become emotional
and he is not capable of collecting himself and having the conversation
any longer. Now there might be some secondary there might be
some secondary culpability here for Pisco within this conversation.
Okay, where you could argue like hey at some point you have to
understand that this person is not capable of having the conversation
anymore. You need to empathize with that and move on. Pisco,
for worse in this case, you could argue, is a lawyer and has
probably been trained to work his emotions out of his argumentation
as much as possible, even if he feels he's getting heated, to
continue to work his emotions out of his argumentation.
And I don't think he'd be trained to see somebody else struggling
with this, but he'd probably be trained to continue to hit his
arguments while somebody else is struggling because they're struggling
without really analyzing why. Because he's supposed to be providing
the best defense for somebody, right? or the best prosecution
or executing his duties to the best of his ability. There's probably
a lot of reason to think that Pisco is not going to ease up on
Hutch, but Hutch is like Hutch is totally disconnected from being
capable of having this conversation that not he is not attached
to this conversation anymore. He is just saying things that are
untrue that are like bordering on lies. Like I would feel if
I told somebody I'm against this thing and then they're like,
"You absolutely refuse to denounce this thing." I would feel
like they're lying, right? like you're either not you're not
listening to me, you don't hear what I'm saying. Anyway, let's
get >> what's the point of what's the point of >> There's
self-standing obligations to moderate uh to reduce risk that
you know a streamer I think has it's where it's there's a low
cost of compliance and where there are obvious potential uh benefits
to a lowcost compliance incident. The fact that you have a self-standing
obligation to mitigate risk, I'm going to repeat it, make sure
you hear it. So, I'm going to say it twice. that you violated
your duty to moderate does not mean you are culpable for actions
that underly. It means that you're not culpable. >> Oh
my god. I I I mean, so you understand that there are two obligations,
right? Two moral. >> What you're saying makes no sense
because if there if you're saying you're there to mitigate risk,
but you're not culpable if something happens. Well, then what
the >> contradiction? So, [clears throat] dude, I honestly
want to be able to draw this on Excalibur draw because I think
it would be helpful.
just using it for notes right now. But it's like there's a continuum,
okay, of this is just the the act versus rule utilitarianism,
right? So this is the Mr. Girl, I maybe should keep it off of
the I've been told to keep it away from the like extremely risque
hypotheticals. So again, based on you smoking, you're aware that
there's some risk of giving cancers to the people around you.
Um, you have some level of culpability.
What what a moderator does in this case, okay, with a chat, what
a moderator would do is you have some risk to your chat doing
anything to them offending somebody to being racist to making
bad statements to there's some risk for your chat's behavior
that you know you're responsible for you have the ability to
moderate that platform. So there is some responsibility to moderate
that chat. Okay?
Now, if somebody says something bad and you don't moderate it,
you have a responsibility for what you could reasonably foresee
as the outcome of that statement. So, this would be something
like mandatory reporting. Okay? If somebody came to a psychologist,
I would ask Hutch, and they said
they said, "Hey, I have like a you know, I'm I have like intrusive
thoughts about robbing a bank. I don't really I don't want to
do it, but like I have intrusive thoughts. I think about robbing
banks like all the time.
And would it be incumbent on the therapist or would the therapist
be responsible if they didn't report that to the police
and then that person robbed a bank? Answer pretty clearly would
be no, right? Like they're not responsible for that. Even though
they heard it, even though they have some responsibility for
hearing this information, there's like a list we've decided of
things that a therapist, for example, would report on. One being
direct and imminent harm, right? Saying, "Hey, I hate this person.
I like planned to kill them and I'm going to do it." Well, they
would have to report that and then they could be held responsible.
The same thing works in a in an attenuated way, in a in a similar
way for streamers and moderating the chat, right? There'd be
some responsibility for moderating your chat, some people in
the chat are making jokes about calling CPS there. If you leave
them unmodderated, how likely is it, you know, in terms of when
your chat's joking about something, how often does that thing
happen?
Right? Because I would say probably the one thing we joke about
here the most often is which actually has, you know, negative
implications. I feel quite bad when somebody tells me they like
I've had people tell me, "Hey, you told me to off myself and
that made me feel bad." And I feel bad when they tell me that
and then I try and I I would like venture not to do that again
in the future, right? But would I ever be responsible if I did
my whole thing after doing this for a long time and the chat
jokes about it too, but I'd be responsible if somebody did off
themsel there? Probably not, right? It's like what could I reasonably
foresee? Well, I've told people to off themselves like a trillion
times now, and it's never happened yet. What could I reasonably
foresee happening? Well, probably them shaking it off or even
feeling a little shaken by it and leaving. But realistically,
I'm not expecting anybody I hate to say this. I hate if it ruins
the immersion for you guys. I I'm sorry, but if I've ever, you
know, told you to yourself, which I, by the way, we're on Twitch,
so I just mean in a video game. I don't actually mean do that,
okay? I don't actually mean go do it. I mean like you just said
something stupid, whatever. Like it's it's hyper uh it's hyper
hyperbolic,
right?
Yeah. And like people are saying this, it's like just said this
in the chat, which I think is obviously a joke. I don't think
I'm culpable for for him doing this. Okay. Like obviously obviously
we're all participating in something here. So that's what Pisco's
argument is. And Hutch is going like you're telling me you're
like not responsible for that. No, he's saying there's a separation
of the claim made in the chat or the message in the chat of even
if they're calling for some action and the actual action where
your culpability is not one to one, right? You're not culpable
in the same way somebody who did it is. And I think the funny
thing is would it would Luigi Manion be a good like gut check
here? Because I think this would depend what was Hutch's take
on Luigi Manion because for me Luigi Manion actually took the
Ethan Klein ethos and and put it into practice, right? Cuz I
said this I joke I jokingly said this at the time but when Luigi
Manion that CEO that healthcare CEO it's like that's one of the
highest up people at one of the biggest healthcare companies
in the world.
Is there somebody more responsible? Right? And that's kind of
what Hutch is doing here. He's going, "Well, is there somebody
more responsible than Denims?" Well, probably bad empanada actually,
but is there somebody more responsible who we could reach with
the arm of the law? Maybe not, right? It's like in terms of I
am going to commit a totally vigilante like self-serving
act of retributive violence.
It's like, well, if you had to pick a target, there probably
isn't a better target, right? I don't think there's a better
target if you're just going to engage in like totally illogical
retributive violence.
And that's basically what Hutch is arguing here. And it's probably
a really bad argument. And I'm guessing he could identify how
bad an argument it was when it came to Luigi Manion,
right? But he's seems to be failing to understand how bad an
argument it is when it comes to blaming these people for CPS,
making them very significantly morally culpable for CPS and then
saying anything that happens to them as a result of that thing
happening to Ethan is justified.
>> What's the contradiction? You say makes no sense. >> What
risk are you mitigating? >> Yeah. Yeah. So the the risk
that you're mitigating does pertain potentially to later on events,
but that doesn't mean that you're coping. >> What does
that mean, dude? Come on. Don't say events. Risk of what? >> Of
So again, um not an argument saying, "Hey, I want you to do the
emotional thing." Now, I do this when I want to evoke emotions
explicitly, but I know that that's the tool that I'm using it
for, right? I believe Hutch is under the impression that he is
arguing like logical points, like the facts are on his side.
He's actually just evoking emotion, right, from his audience,
saying, "Well, what was the thing? Say what the thing was." Yeah.
So, when you when people call for like uh CPS to be called on
Ethan Klein as a result of the dog eating clip that he put out
there, okay, that bad put out of frame, even worse, and Ethan
put out there himself. When Denims fails to moderate her chat,
she has some tiny level of culpability, but because it is so
small, it's almost totally it's I would say it's totally disingenuous
to say she's culpable in a vacuum, right? Like she has something
there, but it is very small in a way that is almost not worth
acknowledging and certainly can't be used as a as like a pretense
for going after her legally. is very silly to do this >> of
uh either bad conduct, malicious conduct, whatever is responsible,
whatever is down the line. Absolutely. So, so I I just want I
just want to make sure that you understand the distinction
>> I don't know why he's asking that question because he
literally doesn't know. Do you understand a distinction between
a duty to mitigate risk that is by properly moderating and action
people who are doing the thing and the the reason I'm asking
this of you is if you don't understand that difference I think
that there there's like a huge issue in communication here because
just because you fail to moderate and fail to uh optimally minimize
risk doesn't mean that you're responsible for the valitional
malicious conduct of other >> No, you're not. You're not.
Obviously, listen, whoever called CPS, that was >> Okay,
so Hutch sort of understands. So again, this all operates in
a continuum. He sort of gets what Pisco is saying now, but I
don't understand why he was he was accusing Pisco of being bad
faith. And Pisco is repeatedly communicating the same ideas,
right? If Pisco was like changing was like, you know, moving
goalposts the whole time, I could call that out. But he's obviously
invoking the same idea again and again and again.
So in terms of saying somebody's bad faith in this conversation,
I'm just not really sure at all how you could accuse Pisco of
being that when this is how Hutch is operating their decision
ultimately they're responsible for their actions. But you seem
to be like aloof to the idea that people with tremendous levels
of influence, especially when we're talking about that particular
>> I'm not going to get distracted. So So >> So again,
all superlatives, people with tremendous influence
or is Caseyron have tremendous influence if that is that how
you describe Caseyron? Tremendous influence. Okay, >> I'm
not trying to discount you. You're acting aloof to the idea that
these people could potentially influence their own audience
through through >> again. He's he's not saying that. >> So
Hutch is misunderstanding. Hutch thinks the way Hutch sees this
right now because he's emotional is he says if Pisco if you don't
match my emotional state and the the hyperbolic things I'm saying,
right? If you don't match my superlatives, if you're not willing
to say these people are like the most the the most highly influential
people, tremendous influence who do all of this stuff. Do you
think, okay, evil Johnny Bravo, do you think he meant tremendous
influence over their chat or do you think he meant tremendous
influence in general as in they influence a lot of people?
I think pretty obviously the second, but
I'd listen to an argument for the first. Maybe. I just hadn't
really considered it, I guess. Um, I guess I would like to see
how often they can get I feel like for Casey Tron that's obviously
not true, but maybe for >> action or inaction
to to do something like that. So, is Denims 100% responsible
for what happened? No. But she's partly culpable in my >> Aren't
they call Aren't they called influencers? They are. So, what
did Denims advocate for in terms of her influence? What did she
use her influence to advocate for?
Because again, I'm telling you, at worst
she is ignoring the chat messages saying CPS. She never directly
engages with the CPS messages. She never says CPS. She never
advocates calling CPS. And so, what was she influencing people
to do? Right? Cuz now your argument is, well, chatters have a
lot of influence on chatters, which is a very different argument,
right? opinion because she contributed to that culture in that
community and that rhetoric that led to ultimately the call happening
in the first place. I can't give you like is she this percentage
to blame or that
significant
culpability? >> So, so does Denim have significant culpability
for the CPS call that she did not place that there's no evidence.
>> Yeah. So now it should come down to and if Hutch doesn't
believe this is like like 50% or more, I do believe he's been
acting in bad faith with regards to Denims the entire time. Hutch
would have to say she's at least 50, maybe not 50, she's at least
30% culpable. >> Which to me would be insane to say she's
30% culpable for this. But I do believe that's what you'd have
to say to just say, well, she's culpable for this as a vacuum
statement. She's responsible. She should be held responsible
for her actions. She should be held responsible by being sued
for all the money she has. I'd say if you're not sure that she's
like 20 30% responsible at a minimum, you sound insane to me,
right? >> That I seen her encouraged before the >> I
never said that. >> Wait, wait, wait. I'm just asking you
the question, Hutch. Do you think that there is significant culpability?
>> And that that is the entire argument, by the way, is
how culpable is she? How responsible can you hold her? How likely
was right? You you do all these things to say you do all of these
questions to distill down what percentage of culpability does
she have for the CPS call directly right because you're trying
to hold her responsible for it. So what level of culpability
do you believe she has? And if you haven't or you if you refuse
to engage or you haven't engaged in that thought exercise, you
are just calling for somebody to be harmed. Right? You're saying
she deserves to be harmed with no thought behind that. And I
would wonder why you feel comfortable doing that to thousands
of people.
That's probably like a really bad thing to do to refuse to engage
in that in that entire thing to say, "Okay, I you know, she's
this percentage culpable, so I think Ethan's within his rights
to do whatever he wants." If you haven't thought of that percentage,
if you've never once considered that, if you refuse to engage
in it, I think you are doing something incredibly harmful. You
are like a creator who should not have a platform. Now, I would
never advocate for you to be deplatformed, but I'm saying that
like I don't respect your opinions. I think you are just
I think you are like a dangerous person who's willing to advocate
for people's harms with no intellectual rigor done beforehand
whatsoever, which is bad. Obviously, obviously terrible >> or
buy denims or case >> find significant are we talking percentages
here? >> That is a primitive and I will but I will say
I'll put a percentage on it. 5%
>> maybe. Yeah. So you the fact that Hutch just realized
that more than 5% is unlikely. So he just said maybe, right?
So it's it's not even he can't even get he can't even guarantee
he can get the percentage up to 5%.
>> And he thinks it's reasonable to destroy someone financially
over less than 5% culpability of something happening.
That's I I don't think it's crazy to say that that's totally
unreasonable,
right?
And I can go up the the levels of abstraction here. We could
talk about this at a totally abstract level. I can go down all
the way to the concrete. We're going to go through every single
line of text in Denim's chat and I will maintain this opinion.
And I just don't understand how Hutch could could possibly like
that 5% would be, "Oh, maybe I could get it that high." And then
he's advocating he's totally cool with these people having their
lives destroyed is wild. >> You think that Denims is 5%
responsible? >> I don't know. I at least responsible way
to give you a maybe that is and and and >> so if you have
no way and you haven't thought about it, if you don't have something
you believe personally, I think you're advocating for someone
to be financially destroyed with no
How do you argue you're a good person when you do that
genuine question? You are advocating somebody have their life
destroyed for something you have no idea how culpable they are
for. Right? So there's an event that happened. You think there's
some percentage culpable. You have never done the work to figure
out what that percentage is. You refuse to do the work to figure
out what that percentage is. And you defend the person who's
going to try to destroy that person's life who's some, you know,
tiny percentage culpable. That's insane.
That's like like that would be categorically disqualifying for
me to ever consume your content in like a normal I'm not criticizing
this way in the future. Like I think you are a an actual dangerous
person to have a platform and I feel like it is a moral good
to watch your content and explain how bad your thought process
is to people. And I'm not coming to this lightly. I'm not sitting
here mocking him the whole time. Right.
Yeah. This I don't know if you were here earlier, but this actually
what I brought up was a Central Park 5. Exactly. Like if you
Dude, you haven't done any of this rigger and you you haven't
been rigorous about this at all and you're advocating in favor
of Ethan Klein with no thought put into it on pure emotion
for things that you would obviously think are disgusting otherwise.
I think what I need to do here is try to go find did Hutch cover
Luigi Manion at all because I think that's the question, right?
Because I think basically this is more or less the same logic
from the Luigi defenders
and
Hutch here. >> It would probably be bad if he >> So
Luigi
Manion Manion Luigi there's no way he didn't cover it. It's It'll
be in streams or something. Somebody can look through his streams
or some [__] He'll definitely have covered this.
Okay. He has to have covered Luigi,
right? Yes. So, basically what Hutch has been arguing, what he
just argued earlier was who the like obviously I'm not going
to fault Ethan for thinking she's to blame when we don't know
who else is responsible, right? And I would argue that's the
logic of anybody who defends Luigi Manion. Luigi Manion, if you
wanted to defend that, you would say, cuz I I did this, you know,
devil's advocate thing where it's like, okay, like this guy had
his life ruined. He's got nobody to rage at. He's gonna probably
rage at someone. Could you pick a better target he should have
raged at? I think the answer is no. I think the answer is like
that's the guy despite his tiny level of culpability for Luigi
Manion's situation or anyone else. I think that's probably the
best target, right? And so, but that means you cannot allow the
actions, you cannot say these actions are good with no analysis
because he picked the person he thinks is most culpable. That's
like a totally disconnected from reality way of thinking. It's
super harmful to society.
Yeah, it's it's like horrible. I don't know why I don't know
why we'd pretend that that's a good way of thinking, but he's
laid that out here. I think it's totally like there's nothing
respectable about the way Hutch has argued this or any of his
actual intellectual positions up to this point. There's nothing.
There's maybe the tiniest grain of which I could give him, which
I don't give him in this case, would be well, he's able to emotionally
empathize with people. But unfortunately, in this case, it's
ruinous empathy. He's use this empathy to override any logical
thought he has in his brain and advocate for stuff that's way
outside of what he would really probably expect as punishment
for anyone who is this level of culpable for a similar level
of action in the future. >> In what percentage is Caseyron
>> 2%. I don't. Who cares? It doesn't matter. At >> at
a bare minimum, Casey trying, as I understand it, insignificant
responsibility there.
>> It's You're missing the point. There's a shared culpability,
friend. >> So, first of all, I I don't even accept >> Pisco.
1 plus 1 plus 1 is three. Okay? Between these people, they might
be 3% culpable, and I think that's disgusting. Okay? Like, I
would even be willing. Okay? There's I'll be super good faith
here. Okay? Even though none of these people would do it with
me, there might be some escalation here. You would think in terms
of well, I think I think there's a group of people who collectively
they could have some percentage of responsibility, right?
Collectively they could have it together and by all engaging
in the same rhetoric, they'd have the same level of responsibility.
Okay. So, I would say that it's probably inarguable
that anything Ethan Klein does to any of these people, no matter
how deranged, Hutch is responsible for it, right? If a if a chatter
broke away from this had been advocated for in let's say who's
on Hutch's side of this Asmin Gold's chat. Okay, Asmin Gold and
Hutch on the same side of this thing working in this culture
war culture war against Caseyron, Hassan, Denims, all of these
people. Somebody in Asmin Gold's chat
actually says,
"We got to kill this Caseyron bitch." And they miss it. And then
he goes out and Caseyron
Hutch by his own logic is now totally culpable. He is he has
a level of responsibility where we can treat it as though he
has done the thing, right? Because of the shared responsibility
because he has never done the work to go and check all of his
peers because he has never done anything like that, right? Hey,
touch. Is it your responsibility to go and make sure that every
one of Aszmold's things he says about Caseyron is up to snuff?
That it's not saying any that he's not saying anything unhinged?
That he's not allowing chatters that are unhinged?
That's obviously insane, right? That would be obviously crazy.
But it's the world Hutch advocates for, which to me is like pretty
terrible. I just I totally disagree with that. I don't want to
live in that world. >> That we would apply the the the
culpable standard to the actual act itself. we would apply a
culpability the the failure to moderate and uphold the normal
moderating but it wouldn't extend to the the actual act itself.
But even assuming that we would the notion that you would put
five or greater percentage on a call that you have no evidence
that she encouraged no evidence that she knew about it. The only
thing you have is chat comments that you can't prove she
>> um that provided in a video to you. That's all you have
and you're willing to say you're willing to say risky, right?
You said that was risky. >> Wait a second. So if she knew
about it percentally what I'm trying
>> Oh my god, this is crazy. So I
>> No, but like that's again So do you think it's 0%. That's
not a real question, right? But also Pisco is not advocating
that she should be held responsible. That's on you, Hutch, right?
To advocate why you think she should be held responsible, why
you think life ruination, financial life ruination is the appropriate
penalty for what she did, right? That she's like two what? One
one to 4% I will say probably is around Hutch's ballpark culpable
for this thing. You think financial life ruination is the appropriate
punishment that you're advocating for? >> I just want to
lay out. >> You say my lay I'm going to lay out the >> You
think it's 0%.
>> For me it's 0% 0% capability for the call. Unless you
>> But wait, you just said a minute ago that if you don't
moderate there's a risk that someone in your audience could do
something, right? >> Correct. That doesn't mean that you're
culpable for the actual >> How could it be 0% then?
>> It's not. They're not the same. >> So I don't
think Pisco ever said 0%.
He's saying she's like like saying you're Well, maybe maybe this
is Finally, Hold on. Maybe I can get Pisco on one thing here.
He is saying she's not culpable. Holding her responsible is crazy.
I do think there's something there in Hutch's head that says
like 0%. I think what what Pisco could say to make it more clear
is under 5% under 10% I don't think it's appropriate to hold
them individually responsible for the action. Right. But I think
for Pisco it probably be like under 20% or something like it
would be quite a bit higher. Again just with regards to the Asminold
example from this culture war if somebody were to go Caseyron
how culpable is Hutch
cuz I would say in this case almost certainly based on him lying
about Denims here right he is he is actually going and lying
to people. He is misrepresenting things. He is not approaching
it factually or rigorously at all. I would say he's probably
at least as responsible for Casey Trron's death as Denims is
for the CBS call. Yeah.
Which is I I think pretty wild. Like if you Dude, I man I don't
know. I If somebody wants to disagree with this, I would love
to talk to somebody, you know, but I don't think anybody will
because it seems like it would be really hard to argue from the
other side.
>> Wrong. Do you understand the >> I'm being told
I'm being told to finish the clip. Hold on. There's more to the
>> Go for it. >> I already lost the clip. Hutch.
Hutch. She says that Gardia might be bad for infants. Hutch.
HUTCH. SHE SAYS GARDIA could be really bad for infants. She reads
a chat message.
It says Ethan doesn't take care of his kids. Hutch. Hutch. She
reads the chat message. Hutch. So, I don't know if you're watching
the same thing, but she's telling her audience that uh you know,
she's she's strongly implying that Ethan's children might die.
>> What is she Sorry, where does she say? What does she
say? Give me the words. >> She's strongly implying that
Giardia would be bad for an infant. I don't know how true that
is. Kind of a statement to be honest. >> Like just click
to a minute into the >> dude. No, no, no, no, no. See,
Hutch, this is another thing that where you can see he's obviously
bad faith here, right? He's obviously bad faith. So, he's out
over his skis again with a with a slightly hyperbolic claim,
but he doesn't want to make the claim himself. Pisco says, "Just
read the transcript. Just say what she said to me."
Right. I wonder I wonder how much of this is Hutch realizing
that if he says if he tries to like recall what she said even
though he just watched it, he's probably going to be overemphasizing
or hyperbolic again, right? He's going to be overexaggerating
it again. >> Yeah, I I don't know what video I don't I
don't see any video. I put it in the >> Oh, okay. One sec.
An image >> in their house. And then then I'm host this
and see what she says. And then now we wonder why people are
calling child protective services. >> But they called it
before I even did this stream. >> Watch that clip and try
to tell me she's 0%, bro.
He lets his dog [__] all over his mansion just and
he just leaves a on the floor. Something that is probably related
to the fact that his former housekeeper is suing him for a number
of different reasons. So I would assume he doesn't actually have
a housekeeper anymore or perhaps he he lost his extra housekeeper.
So now the house is just like covered in dog.
You think Hutch hearing it again will mean he's accurate going
forward? No, because realistically, dude, he's like eye popping
off into the corner. Jesus. Um,
Jesus. No, that's his eyelid. That's his eyelid. He's like kind
of He's kind of out of it. Never mind. I thought this was I thought
this was the white of his eye. And he's he has kids. >> No,
no, no. We're good. We're good. We're good. >> He's like,
"Crawl into the dog." >> So for Hutch, I think what's happening
here is
he's like calibrating his statements based on his emotion and
then he is just standing on business when asked to like, "Is
that what really happened?" He's saying, "Of course that's what
really happened." All you have to do here is say, "No, I'm like
probably kind of heated." And we should actually just go see
what was said. >> And god forbid, I don't know what they
do with it. I don't know if they eat it or if it's just from
like contact with it with their hands or something, but they
contracted a parasite that I had previously never heard of in
my life called Giarda from the dog that is all over his >> true,
dude. How is it how is it that like maybe once a week I look
into what Ethan Klein's been up to and every time I manage to
find more and more terrible This is where Ethan tells the story
about his family getting more Mondays. Now we have Saturdayities.
>> Also, this is not a joking matter. It can be very severe
and small children. I mean, much like many other illnesses, it's
very >> So for for this here, I think unfortunately what
Pisco has to do is So again, the original claim Hutch had for
this clip was was this. I wrote it down cuz I wanted to know
what if I showed you a video of Denims herself saying you should
call CPS on Ethan. This matches his level of emotionality
and everything. This tells you what he thinks and everything
after that is complete and utter cope. Okay. So, he doesn't believe
5%, he doesn't believe 3%. If he thought Denims went on her stream
and said, "You guys need to call CPS now," do you think he'd
really say 5%, or do you think it's that he had to go watch the
clip, realize that he totally overstated what happened, and then
tried to recalibrate from there? Would any of his rhetoric make
sense if he truly believed that Denims was one, two, 3% responsible
for the call? Could he really advocate for based on 3% responsibility
for an event? Could he truly advocate for financial ruination
for this person? I don't see how. I just don't get it, man. I
just don't get it. >> Very, very dangerous when infants
get >> So, Pisco being the nice guy that he is, has never
called out that Hutch has massively overcalibrated every statement.
Okay. Ba basically what you want is you want a nice tight alignment
between reality and the things you say about reality. Hutch has
a huge a wide band that goes that reality is nowhere near where
Hutch is, right? And you should always call that out when it
happens. And Pisco is being kind because Pisco is Hutch's friend,
right? So Pisco is being kind and he's not calling him out. And
that is being used to show Pisco's bad faith somehow. I really
don't know. It's bad. the same sicknesses that adults get. There
are lots of things that you can get as an adult. You're totally
fine. You'll be a-okay. No problem. A child, a small infant that
has no immune system shouldn't be catching anything. >> No.
One day his house is covered in dog and his neglected children
raised by nannies have contracted parasites previously unknown
to science from the feces. I wonder why he skipped over all of
this cuz everything that he said everything that I said in this
story, which by the way was apparently compiled by his crew playing,
>> no wonder always sick. Yeah. Yeah. It all makes sense
now. It all makes sense now. It makes sense why he doesn't care
about Palestinian children when he is neglecting his own. How
are you? How is this happening? How is this happening? How How
is this happening? >> So, we can all agree that um dude,
like I would say there's an implication that maybe Ethan's kids
might have been at risk of dying to Giardia. That is like that
is like what's said there. And I just don't understand how Hutch
gets off saying Denim said her kids Denim said his kids are going
to die. I don't think Denims thinks that they have giardia now,
right?
>> I fail to see how this is encouraging someone to call
CPS. >> I didn't say that it encourages someone to call
CPS. >> Okay, you don't have to. >> Um, okay. Now,
we actually should go to the transcript cuz I I literally just
have to go find this now. Uh, oh god, the transcript's really
big. My browser's crashing. No,
hold on. I'll save my time stamp here. We're going to actually
have to go back and see these two statements back. >> You
don't have to. Okay.
So now, uh, hold on. I need to find what was the statement. Uh,
what if I showed you a video? Showed you a a video of
herself. Okay. So, let's go back on here first just a little
bit. >> This is always sick. Yeah. Yeah. It all makes sense
now. Watch it back. It all makes sense now. It makes sense why
he doesn't care about Palestinian children when he is neglecting
his own. How are you? How is this happening? How is this? How
is this? >> I went back too far, but we're gonna get >> How
is this happening? >> I failed to see how this is encouraging
someone to call CPS. >> I didn't say that it encourages
someone to call CPS. >> you don't.
>> So, the original claim was >> What if What if
there What if I could show you a video of Denims herself saying
that somebody should call CPS on >> Go for it. I would
say that's independently bad. Yeah. >> Okay. Like I'm sorry
when you tell me that Pisco is the bad faith person in this conversation.
Okay. Now after this just real quick after this Hutch does realize
that she didn't say that but that is where he emotionally calibrated
to start the conversation. He was arguing this and he went around
arguing this
all over the place. Okay. No, we haven't done the Iron Mouse
stuff yet, but um he went all over the place arguing this thinking
that was the case. He calibrated all of his takes based on believing
that Denims said you guys should call CPS. And I'm I'm telling
you that that is someone you cannot take seriously. That is somebody
that you shouldn't speak to in a one-on-one situation because
they're willing to use like underhanded techniques, underhanded
methods to make you look bad because they are emotionally attached
to this. They need Ethan to be the good guy. I don't think that's
unreasonable to be honest with you. I really don't. don't have
to you don't have to encourage
>> do you have to encourage someone to call CPS to contribute
to the risk of someone calling it? >> So this is by the
way Pisco's position from the start of the conversation
is not as bad. Pisco's position from the start of the conversation
remains the exact same. Hutch's position completely changed in
a way that realistically you can't possibly defend and he refuses
to defend like on its merits. Okay. Pisco literally said
he literally asked him hey Hutch you think based on 3% culpability
that she deserves this and he goes no it's like a whole group
man no there's a whole group there's a shared culpability
cannot say that denims based on her individual actions deserves
this >> okay but what I'm trying to to sus out for you
is the mere uh you know potential increase of risk and I agree
I mean like the the mere fact that she's reporting like even
viewing the video at Paul, right? Even in a critical lens might
increase the the risk of someone uh calling TPS, right? The even
if you were call even if you were examining a video just to criticize
it, right? Just to tear it apart. Um if you're a big enough streamer,
that might contribute to a risk on net that you you don't know
everyone who follows you watch it. So what I'm saying is there's
a self-standing obligation to moderate 100%. But that doesn't
coextend to um substantive and here I'm not talking about legal
ethical culpability that I'm going to impose some kind of uh
ethical breach with respect to the substantive act that we're
talking about and the notion and I'm going to lay it out here
cuz we I I watched the whole clip. There probably is something
to be said on a content creator level where Pisco would benefit
like tremendously
from dumbing down his rhetoric and studying like literally a
guide on how to dumb down your rhetoric as a lawyer because I
think he he finds these tools very helpful to be as precise as
possible and some explicit like intentional strategy to say things
in a more colloquial way but maintain the level of rigor would
be very helpful to I think sometimes he absolutely
sometimes he absolutely
says exactly what is correct and I think for Hutch
Hutch doesn't want to say I don't understand what you mean and
that probably leads to like bad interactions for him like like
Pisco has said the same thing over and over and over again and
I'm not certain that Hutch is aware of that which is not great
that >> you're going to give denims as you certain sit
here 5% or greater responsibility. You came up with that >> Let
me you bought it, right? So
P bought it as in like maybe I could get that
>> Wait. Oh man. Pisco Pisco should have actually been
playing the guy here instead of just trying to state principles.
Pisco is trying very much not to like push Hutch in this conversation,
right? Like in a debate, you can attack the thing someone says
or you can attack, you could try to like build out your own positive
model and help them understand your position. And he is very
wary to go and knock over Hutch's sand castle, right? But Hutch's
sand castle is like totally shoddily built. One tiny little tap,
even a gust of wind might knock it over. And Pisco is being polite
and not going to knock it over, right? So in my opinion, what
Hutch just said, I would have keyed in immediately when Hutch
said, "Oh, maybe 5%." Right? I would have said, "Wait, is that
too high or too low?" and then gotten him to because that's the
entire conversation. How do you pin him down on anything here,
right? Because it's the entire conversation. How culpable is
she that's directly related to how much you think she should
be punished, right? And he basically is arguing, I can't know
how culpable she is. I don't I can't advocate for how much she's
being punished. Okay. So, next question would be, how do you
advocate for what Ethan Klein's doing? It seems like you're actually
categorically barred from making those like those arguments because
you refuse to engage with how culpable she is. Like realistically,
oh man, realistically she could be completely
not to blame at all. Right. There's a there's a set of circumstances.
I'm going to do Hutch's favorite thing. There is a possible thing
where somebody did that call to CPS. Like let's say the land
lady or sorry the the nanny did it, right? The nanny they let
go and sued them. Let's say the nanny did it. In that case, Denims
is not culpable at all. Now, you've been advocating for something
based on not taking information in at all. Hold on a second.
Uh, hold on. One week. Yeah, one week. Okay, we're good. >> Yeah,
you've been advocating for something based on not thinking about
it at all, right? You haven't thought about it even a little
bit. Why would you be would it be okay for you to advocate for
it? It's literally the Trump Central Park 5 thing again. It's
um God, there's just there's a lot of examples.
I But people are normally smarter. If you ask Donald Trump, probably
the dumbest person Hutch thinks, like one of the dumbest people,
you know, Hutch would think exists. If you ask Donald Trump,
hey, how responsible do you think the Central Park 5 are for
that murder? He go 100%. 100% they should be guilt. They're guilty.
They're guilty. Get them in jail. Right? He'd never be dumb enough
to say like 1% while advocating for them to be jailed, right?
That would be insane.
But Hutch is out here going like, "Yeah, maybe 5%.
Maybe 5% culpability or something." The >> fact that I
said it, you didn't have to adopt that. You didn't have to say,
"Yes, I agree more than 5%." You didn't have to. If you asked
me, "What do you consider significant?" I gave you a number,
5%. And you said yes. No one put a gun to your head, Hutch, that
you had to accept that number. So for you, it's chicken right
now for you to be like, >> "No, but you're trying to box
me in. I'm not thinking about these things in like percentage
points, my friend. >> You adopted it. I'm thinking about
I'm thinking about I'm at a much more top level view of things.
>> I'm not >> Oh, this is the part where Hutch over
and over again wants to go concrete, right? So when you talk
to somebody, there's like a level of abstraction you can operate
at like some level of scope you can operate at where you you
you know zoom out and you say these are my principles about the
world or you zoom in and you're arguing about a specific example.
Hutch was just trying to force Pisco to argue about a specific
example, right? And now Piscoll has an argument for why it's
kind of crazy for Hutch to be advocating for total financial
ruination for denims, right? That that's an okay outcome
based on her tiny amount of culpability. And Hutch is now saying,
well, I don't think of things in terms of the example in at the
level of granularity of like going all the way down to thinking
about that, which is insane by the way, like totally insane.
Totally abdicating your responsibility to have this conversation,
right? What is incumbent on you to have this conversation? You're
advocating punishment for somebody and saying at the same time,
I don't think about how culpable they are for the action I want
to punish them for. You just said that. You just said that directly.
It's not even arguable. That's
That's completely insane. So, basically, when Pisco went down
to a fine level of granularity instead of the hypotheticals,
Hutch was saying, I don't I don't want to talk about hypotheticals.
Let's watch the clip. And then Pisco watches the clip. He makes
a point based on that low level of granularity. We're going to
analyze the examples and now I'm going to ask you a question.
And Hutch goes, "No, I don't want to do like low-level granularity.
I want to go back to like abstract. We just think at a high level.
You brought us to this level.
This is your example.
You totally it up. You didn't understand what happened in the
clip. The way you presented it was just an overt lie or misremembering."
Right? That's how you calibrated every part of this conversation
was with your emotion. And now that that's being exposed, you
feel very uncomfortable and you'd like to go back to hypotheticals
and operating on principle, right? Talking about our principles
instead of this specific example.
[__]
[snorts]
brother. Okay, that is cowardly.
That's unfathomably cowardly. Are you
Of course, Hutch will never engage with these criticisms. And
based on like the hub hug box that is live and learn, I don't
think anybody will ever actually hold him accountable for this
level of argumentation, this level of thinking. If somebody I
associate, dude, this is like playing this is like Michael Jordan,
okay, being on the basketball court with [__] Kevin
Hart, okay? I think it's respon I think everybody who's on the
Bulls, which we'll call that live and learn, okay, has a responsibility
to go, wait, why are we sharing revenue? Why are we building
something with Kevin Hart? He can't play basketball. He's incapable.
Hutch is showing that he is incapable
or he could answer for any of these criticisms, right? He has
shown he is entirely incapable.
And anybody who wants to defend Hutch in this conversation has
to look past all of the ways he is being either slimy or illequipped,
like unequipped,
categorically unequipped to have this conversation. And they'll
have to say, but Pisco is getting like mad at him.
Like Pisco is getting really mad at him and that's really mean
and rude and like evil. So, actually, we we have to defend Hutch,
right? That's that's the only argument you could have against
this is like Pisco is being mean. Just be nicer, Pisco. Just
be nicer, Pisco. But I think Pisco has also calibrated his meanness
perfectly to how bad Faith Hutch is being. Hutch has to like
totally weasle out of of something and then Pisco will go, "Oh,
like you're why are you doing this? Yes or no? Is this the case?"
He's not doing it without reason. Or at least I haven't seen
that yet. There might be there might be some times Pisco can
infamously use the yes or no without like it being required in
that moment, but I've missed it if it's happened so far. I haven't
seen any super bad examples. Okay. Yeah, Pisco is so good at
balancing things. Not really. Okay. Pisco probably at a base
level is overaggressive. Okay. But it's not like Hutch is unaware
of that. It's not like Hutch doesn't talk to this guy on a weekly
basis. It's not like Hutch is confused. Pisco really, really,
really does like go aggro most of the time. It's like his style,
but
the thing for me is like this is if that was in a friendship
alone, maybe you could criticize it, but this is their profession.
This is this is like saying, "Dude, Michael Jordan, Michael Jordan
just like he gets way too aggressive when he plays one-on-one,
and it's really up." It's like, "Okay, but you are the person
who said, "I want to do this one one-on-one tournament for
You said you said that you wanted to participate. So, and you
have played one-on-one against Michael Jordan before. You've
played in games against Michael Jordan. Why the are you here
saying, "Actually, this guy, this guy's really rough when he
plays basketball." No, you're you're doing the thing. You're
you're doing your profession right now. Damn. >> I'm not
I'm not going to tell you 2% for Casey, 5% for this. My brain
is not >> Your lawyer brain is going there and I'm not.
So, I think I'll just say that I genuinely think you are categorically
disallowed from commenting on a situation like this, okay? If
you refuse to engage with that question, right, man, I I'll draw
I'll draw an like a diagram later or something, but essentially
you have like multiple contributing factors to some outcome happening,
right?
And you are arguing because you don't have anybody to blame at
all who are the direct causal factors in this event happening
that you can take the non sorry the like the uh what is it indirect
causal factors the indirect factors and you can blame them at
a level where you're punishing them like they did the thing right
and that's obviously no I like I like sketching out ideas and
I'm going to get more into it because I think it's quite good
to create artifacts of your ideas and crystallize them so they
can be criticized but I don't think I'm going to do it on stream
yet because I'm not quite there. What I should do is write a
note and do this off stream after we're finished and I I could
just go back and and cover this again because I think it is actually
important to do um I don't know why I clicked over to it because
I was never really intending to do it but essentially like if
you haven't thought about what percentage culpability
denims has it's more of like it's actually pirate software Canadian
caller when I was a logging pirate software I was like oh I really
want to do diagrams like this I think it's a way better way to
do it right but if you haven't thought about the level of culpability
denims has You cannot defend actions taken against her based
on that culpability. Right? You can't say, "Well, she's culpable
for this, so I think she deserves something." When you have not
thought about how culpable she is, right? That's that seems very
obvious to me. That seems like an obvious principle we would
all have. You have not considered or looked at the evidence to
say how culpable somebody is for an event and you are advocating
for them being punished based on that event happening. Yeah,
super easy to understand.
So, first of all, when I say significance, I the 5% significance
threshold. That's more of like a statistical, if anything, it's
not my lawyer background. It's like my I don't know, econ statistics
background from undergrad. Uh, that I know that there's a 5%
significance level, 1%. And so, here I'm giving, you know, 5%.
But, you know, I wouldn't even give 1%. So, I'm being more generous
in saying, okay, significant in this in this range. Um, uh, I
guess I'm being less generous with 5%, but but I just want to
be clear. So, I'm going to lay it out. So, you got to let me
lay it out. All right. >> You are because you did adopt
it. Unless you want to come back and say I'm not I I take back
5%. Are you gonna say that? >> I I'm gonna stick with it.
I'm sticking with the 5%. >> In fact, I'm saying it's specifically
5%. That's what I think. >> Okay. The fact that you would
say that Denims deserves 5% culpability, not for failure to moderate
and her norms with respect to her moderation responsibilities
and her norm to minimize risk. >> Hold on. I'm back. I
am very very concerned. Okay.
I am very very very concerned. And if you're dishonestly portraying
her actions, you're even more disqualified.
Um Dustin Suggs, do you think I or Pisco are dishonestly framing
her actions? Or are you saying that Hutch is dishonestly portraying
her
Because I can tell you for a fact he dishonestly portrayed her
actions already in this. So that's not even like a mitigating
or it's it's not even like a mitigating or extenduating factor.
Hutch directly misrepresented what she did and what she said.
But I have to go back because I walked away from my computer.
I had to be right back. And I did not get to see when Hutch was
Hutch memeing when he said I'll stick on the 5%.
Oh yeah, Dustin. This is cool. I I I didn't know, right? And
I'm hoping I'll get like some Hutch supporters who will come
on and and like actually argue. Um hold on. I'm actually going
to I'm going to put the Hutch thing in the title and I'm actually
going to say
any Hutch supporters want to call in looking for disagreement.
Guys, I'm on Twitch. Okay, it's twitch.tv/jstlk.
Would you guys go over there? Oh, also blastoff tweet. Okay,
hit the blastoff tweet as well. Um, if you haven't interacted
with the blastoff tweet or retweeted or liked the blastoff tweet,
I suggest you do so. It's not even pinned in the chat. Uh oh.
It's not even pinned in the chat. Oh boy. That'll be why it got
no interaction. Uh oh. Uh oh. Okay, there's the Twitch chat.
There's this. I just want to get anyone who would come in to
defend Hutch here because I think it's I think it's absolutely
wild personally that anybody would say that Pisco was being bad
faith in this
Right. To me personally, I think you are crazy.
You want us to go to Twitch? I'm just saying open up Twitch if
you can hear my voice in both places. Okay. Participate in both
chats. I don't I don't actually know. Where's Lav? Um I don't
know. You could probably go ask her. discord.gg.
We're not talking to Lav right now.
Okay.
Although I do appreciate your support for Lav, so don't go away.
But just if you're interrupting me in the middle of a different
segment, I'm probably going to be annoyed.
I like people being on kick more than Twitch if you have to choose
one. But if you guys want to open the Twitch, I'm just hoping
if we get enough traction, we'll get some people jumping in on
uh on Twitch who would want to argue this from the other side.
Cuz I legitimately just can't see the other side of this like
at all from a logical perspective. The only argument you have
is one of
Hutch is incapable of having this conversation at a high level
intellectually like he he is intellectually incapable of having
this conversation
or
I guess that's actually it's just one thing and that's leading
to Pisco should be understanding of that and Pisco should be
nicer because Hutch is like his Lenny and
and Pisco should just tell him about the farm. Okay. How can
you focus on denims and CPS and Skulls when John Cena just wrestled
his last match? I don't care. Sorry, man. Sorry, man.
Anyway, we >> Hold on. >> Oh my god. >> Oh,
hold on. Wait. He said 5%. >> That's what I'm going to
stick with it. I'm sticking with the 5%. In fact, I'm saying
it's specifically 5%. That's what I think. >> Okay. The
fact that you would say that Denims deserves 5% for failure to
>> like he's kind of he's kind of memeing a little bit,
but I don't think he was memeing. I was a little concerned that
he would just meme that away, but it's actually very critical
to answer that >> All right. and her norms with respect
to her moderation responsibilities and her norm to minimize risk.
>> Hold on. Wait, hold on. >> Oh my god. >> Hold
on. Wait. It's I want to I want to It's I'm going to say it's
5.25%.
>> Okay. Greater than Okay, never mind. He's memeing. He's
actually memeing.
I I don't understand how you like it's again I see so many things
that feel like they're actually disqualifying for having honest
political conversation on the internet. like like the idea that
you think you can have this conversation reasonably and minimize
how important it is to determine Denim's culpability,
right? That's embarrassing. Like I would be embarrassed if I
if I couldn't identify how important that is.
Jaw, couldn't you explain Hutch's defense as simple team sports?
Oh, that's the Sorry, that is another option. The Sorry, the
other option is yes, that he's totally disingenuous. he's performing
specifically because he knows he's being dishonest and he knows
he wants to portray Pisco is like unhinged and crazy in this
argument because he doesn't have an argument of his own. Whether
that is intentional or like um under the surface he's just like
totally emotionally overcome. It's like one of the two. Yeah,
if you if you want to say that Grandandy. So Grandandy is suggesting
that maybe this is just team sports and it's a bit of a sunk
cost thing where Hutch has to defend his old opinion. I personally
believe that one. I do not believe Hutch is intellectually incapable
of having this conversation. I think he's emotional and I think
he is intentionally trying to be as bad faith as possible to
hurt Pisco here for even questioning this. And it could be unintentional
that he just is used to when he's wrong in a conversation. It
could be some malformed behavior or sorry mal maladaptive behavior
where he when he's losing a conversation of some kind like actually
just starts like trying to paint the other person as bad maybe,
but I don't think so. Yeah, you guys are trying to connect this
to Really? I don't think it's the same. I just don't I don't
think so. Um, mostly because I don't think if I if I ever like
messaged Really in the middle of a conversation was like, "Hey,
it feels like this is happening." I think I could even confront
Really with something that's wrong in the middle of a conversation
and we could just have a normal like cool down from that and
it's totally fine, right?
I don't think Hutch is even attached. I don't think he can introspect
and see
where he's at,
right? I don't think he can see it.
Really can usually see it. Like if you call Really up for it
if you say it, right? I think he can he's capable of that level
of like detaching from his own thought process and like at least
entertaining. There's some level of intellectual humility there
at least. I >> 5% fair. Okay. Yeah. Well, how you're >> I
think the the issue with um I think the issue with
he did complain about interrupt getting interrupted a lot. I'm
guessing he's developed that from Tik Tok debates rhinox. So
when people aren't interrupting him as much as he's interrupting
I'm guessing on Tik Tok that's like an effective tactic
probably. Um
what was I about to say though? Oh, I think the issue with is
is if he comes in he's like I'm unaware of stuff on the topic.
I probably shouldn't debate with him. I should probably say if
you want to go figure that out, I would love to debate with you
on this topic. I think that's what I should do, right?
Which sucks because I would love to or at least if we're if we're
having like contentious conversations on the thing cuz I can't
help but think like
cuz mostly what he's doing is he's trying to like gut check ideas
and I do feel like when I suspect that he has some some level
of bias, not like extreme bias towards the H3 stuff, right?
and he's just gut- guting with too much bias towards H3 and that
I don't like that. I feel like and then when I say like I it's
just difficult to call out. It's like I would like to gut check
but I think it's un I think some of the things being said are
unreasonable and I just don't know I don't know how to deal with
that. I didn't think it was bad faith. I didn't think is like
incapable of seeing evidence and being honest about it. I think
he has like a slight bias as most people do
and I I just disagree that he's anything remotely close to Hutch.
I do think Hutch is pretty bad to be honest. >> Doing this
right now sounds like you're kind of like being like you're trying
to say that what I'm saying is ridiculous that uh >> a
little bit. Yeah. So >> yeah. And I think
so the idea that you should know how responsible someone is when
you support punishment for them, right? Somebody has done something.
Somebody is accused of being a part of something and someone
wants to punish them for it. Hutch is quite literally saying
it is absurd to suggest that he should know how culpable that
person is in order to to support their punishment. Right? Punishment
fixed. Um action fixed culpability for action unknown unknown
unknown and probably reasonably like quite low. and he is supporting
a punishment that seems borderline commensurate with the action,
not even just like the low level of culpability she'd have for
the action
based on no analysis. He's supporting it based on zero analysis.
And then he said Pisco is being absurd. Pisco is being ridiculous
or silly.
It's crazy. It's like actual crazym when that is the heart of
the issue. It's very weird.
Again, we'll see. I'm trying to do this calmer style as we react
to this without all of the, you know, hyperbolic hypotheticals
and stuff because I'm hoping that it en encourages people to
engage and come and disagree because I would love to talk to
anyone who
if we could find them. >> So, what's the is your point
with that? How would we assess significance in any other degree?
How would we supposed to? So, clearly you're arguing that they
because you're not going to say that if they have insignificant
responsibility that they should be punished this way. Fair. So,
how else am I supposed to assess their culpability in relation
to what happened?
>> Oh, I did not listen to what Pisco said, and I should
listen because I'm going to call Hutch out for not understanding
it if he doesn't. >> Is ridiculous that uh a little bit.
Yes. Listen again. >> So, what's the [__] is
your point with >> Back to this. Okay. Uh Kger, we actually
didn't cover I literally haven't cover like recovered anything.
>> I We just didn't get to it last night. We ended up arguing
about stuff and we literally never got to it last night. >> How
would we assess significance in any other degree?
>> A little bit. Yeah. >> Yeah. So, so, so, so what's
the [__] is your point with that? How would we assess
significance in any other degree? How would we supposed to? So,
clearly
>> dude, dude, there's no way he just hit him with this.
There's no [__] >> What the [__]
is your point with that? How would we assess significance in
any other degree? How would we supposed to? So, clearly you're
arguing that they >> Dude, dude, dude, dude, really?
Um, I don't I really don't like the way argued like almost at
all. I It's basically like uh I can't explain it. I'll have to
think about it and go through what I didn't like about it. It
just feels like it's not the same as some other conversations
you have, right? It feels like you shouldn't be able to say,
"Well, I'm going to excuse this behavior by saying he's like
silly
and then also argue he's like competent in other places like
selectively." I just don't I don't like it. But I would have
to go and watch it again to see exactly how it played out. But
man, this conversation is rough. So, what we just watched, I'll
go back to it again. What we just watched was Pisco identify
the core heart of the issue, right? What level of culpability
does Denims have that you're arguing that financial potential
financial ruination is acceptable? Ethan can sue her and try
to destroy her financially because of the level of because you've
said because they called CPS on his family. You imply Denims
is responsible for that. You said, Hutch said personally, Denims
advocated calling CPS, which is wrong
And then he and then Pisco identifies the heart of the issue.
How culpable is she that you're advocating for this level of
punishment? And Hutch goes, I think you're being ridiculous right
now. That's the entirety of the argument is how culpable do you
think Denims is that she deserves this?
Because you have said, you know, around and find out you you've
advocated Ethan Klein's not a bad person for doing this. You've
advocated he's like totally understandable. you've defended him
and then you say it's absurd to try to figure out how culpable
you can find her for this. If you, my brother, if you haven't
done that calculation in your head, you need to delete your channel.
You cannot say that. And
not just that alone, but you actually don't understand how that
is the critical part of the issue that you have totally sidestepped.
Right? you actually it's like outside of your brain that that's
the critical part of the issue that you've entirely sidestepped
and you've called Pisco absurd for dealing with it. So now if
Pisco is going to go off about this, I totally understand because
you have somebody who is either figning ignorance or is so unintelligent,
so intellectually not rigorous that they've just took the heart
of the issue and said, "Oh, I've never thought about it. It's
really silly." Right? This is like arguing free speech with while
being unaware of what's written in the First Amendment. This
is like the core critical piece of thinking or knowledge you
need to have as a an ante to step in and talk about the topic.
And Hutch has just said you're absurd for saying I should think
about that. Frankly,
I think that's like disqualifying
for political conversations. I think you have disqualified yourself
entirely if you can't admit that that was just bad faith or if
you can't admit you were wrong on this because you are obviously
>> Cuz you're not going to say that if they have insignificant
responsibility that they should be punished this way. So, how
else am I supposed to assess their culpability in relation to
what
>> Because I think you're trying to come at it from a direction
of of like you're you're you're hitting it with this like degree
of specificity that I don't think like that I think you're using
that to try to to try to like weasle out of some pretty just
obvious observations to make. Like if you were in Ethan's shoes
and you couldn't know for sure like >> I'm not saying you're
wrong, just curious how you're evaluating your own bias. I'm
hoping other people will and I'm trying to be intellectually
humble if somebody suggests that I am biased. So if anybody wants
to disagree with Hutch has said about the core part of the issue
that Pisco is silly for trying to get to that for trying to ask
Hutch about it. If you think that is not like categorically disqualifying,
if you think that is not like actually a serious issue that needs
to be pointed out, needs to be acknowledged and needs to be apologized
for in some way, right? or acknowledged at least, I think you're
crazy. But if like I I will put that opinion out on like Twitter.
I'll put that opinion anywhere and hope I receive feedback on
it cuz obviously I went into this I was trying to like just slowly
watch through and and collect
I've not seen any push back yet.
And like this has been crazy. This has been
>> From who's Yeah. So anyway, intellectual humility is
how I try to approach it. And just if somebody says I'm wrong
on something, I'm totally happy to go back and analyze the facts.
Yeah, totally >> Community this caller came, >> you
would do a shotgun blunder
regardless of their responsibility, >> any No, what I'm
trying to say is any reasonable person in that position would
have a shared kind of like animosity or sense of blame towards
>> But hold on, hold on. So he's again arguing that Luigi
Manion
like you have to say you cannot do this
right Luigi Manion is the comparable
you cannot refuse to give your moral argument for whether it's
good or bad what the punishment is right it's a little easier
in the Luji Manion case right but this was the argument that
a bunch of people used to excuse and tacitly support the Manion
shooting was well there's like not a better target and he was
really mad obviously something's got to change right that's
that's how people supported Luigi people in Pisco's chat were
saying that Hutch was watching a video in the which Denim's chat
is edited same one Ethan showed yes he was I went and pulled
it up he was using the edited chat version which probably was
calibrating his his outrage again and it was kind of silly
whatever whatever
with this I >> it's just the whole group >> even
for people who have insignificant responsibility that would be
reasonable.
>> I don't think there's anything >> reasonable or
not Hutch. >> But this is what this is what I think you're
doing with like you're using these words like significant and
trying to get at these percentage points just like try to engage
with what I'm saying without trying.
>> So so Hutch is literally saying why will you not engage
with my appeal to emotion? Why will you not engage with my appeal
to emotion? And the simple answer is I can agree that I understand
why Ethan thinks that these people should be held responsible
for this in lie of somebody who he can actually hold responsible.
But just like I don't let the father of a girl who got murdered
go and the killer, I don't let Ethan Klein do whatever he wants
with zero criticism. Obviously, right? So you can't just say,
well, why wouldn't you engage with my appeal to emotion? It's
like, well, he could. And I I think every single person who argues,
who does like this kind of logic road debate stuff would do the
same acknowledgement. While your emotions are important to understand
and control, they don't allow you to engage in whatever behavior
you'd like. And you support Ethan Klein. You've defended Ethan
Klein and you've basically mocked people who think he's being
absurd here.
That is tacid support. Absolutely.
Not to mention with this exact mental model, okay, with this
exact mental model,
if someone in Asold's chat that wasn't moderated had murdered
Caseyron, let's say, while Hutch is in this whole sphere and
he's got some shared culpability and nobody was thinking about
what percentage is there, Hutch couldn't complain if that group,
that leftist group, now said he was responsible for her murder.
Right?
That's the level of sc that's the the type of argument he's making
right now, which I think would be absurd and I'd defend him on
that. Right. But he would have to agree with them. He would have
to say, you know what, you're right. >> You're trying to
say that person a person in Ethan's position uh given the fact
that he can't pinpoint exactly whoified
who among the culpable parties is most responsible would be justified
in being angry at the whole group. >> I understand what
you're suggesting, but the question is there's a [clears throat]
minimum threshold. You wouldn't say that a a person in Ethan's
position. Um, he >> But this is unquantifiable. >> Oh
my god. Hudge, let me talk. So you wouldn't say that >> it's
not unquantifiable.
It's literally not unquantifiable at all. Literally, there are
entire statistical fields for dealing with entire statistical
like um abstractions for dealing with uncertainty.
You can't be very certain, but obviously in a in a society where
you live by the rules innocent until proven guilty, if you wanted
to advocate for something, you probably say like, well, you know,
I'm going to lean towards the smaller part of the error bars
here, right? The the lower part of the the spectrum of between
zero and 100. Like if I if I can only be, you know, at minimum
0.01% certain, then I like I probably can't blame this person
for this. I can't really say they're culpable in a vacuum. that
someone in Ethan's position it would be reasonable for them to,
you know, target someone who has like no culpability, right?
>> Wait. Okay. K okay.
Yeah. Cuz like like
if Hutch says he hasn't done this calculus at all, which I don't
think is true, by the way. He thinks that they're somewhat culpable.
Like pretty he probably thinks they're like quite culpable, actually.
He's probably done the analysis. He's just embarrassed to share
it. But if he says that he's not done the analysis, then it's
like, okay, could feasibly be it could feasibly in some scenario
be 0%. And you're saying it's okay to have never done the analysis,
to have never tried to figure out and distill it down, right?
I'd say also the act of trying to distill it down forces you
to go through the intellectual exercise of going through all
the evidence, right, and being critical about it and trying to
put a percentage on it that you feel like like vibes with your
credibility will will not destroy your credibility.
is already an important exercise by itself. But by not doing
that, if it were 0%, you'd still be saying it's okay because
you're arguing Ethan's Yeah. You're arguing Ethan's emotional
reaction and wanting someone to blame is okay.
>> Fair. [laughter] >> Like, yes, of course. >> All
right. And you would also you would not accept that he target
people who have trivial responsibility.
Um, if other content creators were equally informed on the ETH
caseron lawsuit, which major figure major figures do you think
would disagree with your take? Um, wait. I think lots of people
are informed and I think a lot of big creators would disagree
with this take. I think um, Nicholas Dioro would disagree with
this take. Although I I think probably very few people have the
size of platform Hutch does with the total lack of intellectual
rigor Hutch has. I think there's a big disconnect there that's
leading to Hutch both like growing in some ways and getting attacked
in a lot of ways, right? Like Hutch has a very low level of intellectual
rigor. He doesn't really care how correct he is in a lot of things.
He's just like very emotional rolling through stuff, right? And
that could be that's like a different model.
But I think he basically should categorically deny debates like
this and just say like I'm a propagandist cuz that's what he's
operating as, right? Unironically, the funny thing is is he's
probably the most comparable to Hassan.
No, like actually he's he's super comparable to Hassan, right?
low intellectual rigor. I'm going to roll my emotions and say
things. He's very, very, very similar to Hassan in a lot of ways.
Asminold?
No. I think Asminold's got more intellectual rigor than Hutch.
I actually think Asminold might have more intellectual rigor
than Hutch. I think if Asminold and Hutch debated, I think Asminold
would roll Hutch. I'm not even joking. I actually think that
I don't think Asmin Gold is more correct on the opinions than
Hutch, but I think Asminold would roll him in a debate. Like
this is this is frankly dude like the idea that he can't understand.
I don't know how culpable she is and I'm advocating for a punishment.
Like I I literally can't know. It's like yeah, you can. You could
totally know. What if What if somebody in her chat called? That's
your upper bound. What if somebody in her chat didn't call? What
if What if the person who called didn't see that stream? Lower
bound.
Somewhere in between those. And that's like your thought process.
That's literally you, by the way. that percentage, that's who
you are as a human, right? All of the things you think about
in this given moment, that's like a distillation into one like
actual point of fact that you can put your name on.
You think it's x percentage,
right? And it's it's just baffling to me that people would accept
this idea that, oh, I don't have to say it. I don't have to do
that. Oh, no. It's Pisco, you're being silly by asking for that
number.
>> Huh? How? >> Whatever word you want to put on
it, man. I mean like >> I don't think but I don't think
it's certain though
that's what we're talking about and
>> basket lotion. Thank you for the primer. Appreciate
it buddy.
Appreciate it. Appreciate it. >> That's why you're asking
for specific percentages. You did ask. You did ask. What do you
mean by%? >> You did. You're the >> What did you
mean by significant? >> But but yeah, exactly. But like
you're the one that's
>> Dude, he he does this sometimes. Did you guys just see
the the It's another Hutch technique. It's just ignoring the
other person. Hutch asked for a percentage. Oh, he asked for
a percentage, too. There's no way he's just lying. Oh, there's
no way we could do it again, is there? Hold on, bro. What?
I missed him asking. I knew he asked how significant it was.
He was asking Pisco like what what level of responsibility do
you think they have? Because that's the obvious heart of the
qu the heart of the argument.
Obviously the heart of the argument. But hold on. Oh, I'm going
through. Hold on. Okay, this is the first time percentage is
called for here. Oh, hold on. We'll go back to here. I'll roll
this back just a little bit and then we'll watch.
You're acting aloof to the idea that these people could potentially
influence their own audience through through action or inaction
to to do something like that. So, is Denim's 100% responsible
for what happened? No. but she's partly culpable in my opinion
because she contributed to that culture and that community and
that led to ultimately the call happening in the first place.
>> So there's no way that he understands that that So I
think this shows me again that it's not intellectual um
He understands what the heart of the issue is when it supports
him. But when the heart of the issue doesn't support him anymore
and he has to say something and stand with it on like say it
with his chest, stand on business, he runs. I can't give you
like is she this percentage to blame or that percentility
>> so does think your responsibility as any kind of content
creator somebody who says that is a weak spineless who you shouldn't
watch spider that is a weak spineless position refusing to take
a stand on anything when there's a clear moral question here
a lot of people arguing that this is way overboard for what was
actually engaged in a lot of people arguing that it's totally
justified
whether or this punishment is justified is a moral question that
you don't have to be a loser. You can just answer what you think,
right? And I think that's that is table stakes. That is your
ante to get into the conversation. If you can't say whether you
think it's right or wrong, if you just go, "Well, it's petty
slop and I don't really care why you care so much, bro." You're
a loser
off.
Leave. Nobody wants you around. You shouldn't have the right
to vote. We should take your vote away for that position. Okay?
You shouldn't be engaging in society. You shouldn't have a say.
You don't have opinions. You're too scared to actually stand
on business. Off. Okay.
Leave. Leave now. >> Have significant culpability for the
CPS call that she did not place that there's no evidence that
I seen her encouraged before the fact. >> Oh, whoops. Wrong
wrong one. This is where we are with the new time stamp. >> Right.
Fair.
Like,
>> Sorry. I got to roll back. >> So, you wouldn't
say that someone in Ethan's position it would be reasonable for
them to, you know, target someone who has like ability, right?
Like yes, of course. >> All right. And you would also you
would not accept that he'd target people who have trivial responsibility.
Whatever words you want to put on it, man. I mean >> but
I don't think it's though none of >> So this is so it's
substantial and it's not trivial. Now for me personally, if you're
less than 5% responsible for something, it is absolutely trivial.
Now once you get to like 10%.
It's maybe not like trivial anymore, but I guarantee you if they
actually went through this exercise, you'd have to give whatever
percentage to the actual actor, which is probably like 70 or
80% at least, right? And then you'd have to go and dole out percentages
to like Hassan and Casey and Froggen. He just wouldn't have the
percentage to get it up to significant for Denims. I don't believe.
Okay. I really don't. But that's that's the issue is he can have
the position he does because he's not willing to put any thought
into it. And so he's out here on Twitter every day, on his stream
every day, arguing for Ethan Klein, which is okay. But what you
can't do is do that. You can't have that opinion. You can't say
you have that opinion and then go, "Isn't it kind of weird that
you guys want to be rigorous about this? Isn't it kind of weird
that you guys want to like walk through and like know stuff about
this? Isn't it kind of weird that you guys like actually want
to prove out the things I'm saying? Don't Don't you know about
CPS? Don't you know about skulls? Don't you know about the sword?"
Right? like that. Obviously, once you've engaged in the conversation
and decided to take Ethan's side, you don't get to say, "Isn't
it weird that you're being like intellectually rigorous about
this?" Isn't it weird that you're like trying to make a big deal
out of this when it's not? No, he's like advocating for ruining
a bunch of people financially or trying to or using the threat
of it to extract concessions, make Casey Tron dance in a circle
and say all these things. Ethan Klein is a very big, right? That's
what he's trying to do.
Well, I have a problem with that. And if you can't defend why
you don't have a problem with it, then opt out of the conversation,
you loser. Thank you. Bye. >> That's what we're talking
about. And that's why you're asking for specific percentages.
You did ask. You did ask. What do you mean by%? >> You
did. You're the >> What did you mean by significant? >> But
but >> uh I think I think Hutch said
the thing is is Hutch basically wants to use words that obfiscate
his true opinion.
Right. Pisco is saying we like obviously whatever percentage
you put here it's not really something that can be known known
but it's like it's totally instruct uh instructional on your
opinion right if you give me your percentage I now know why you
have your opinion I now know why you think what you do and we
can walk through the conversation from there it's like actually
it's critical it's the heart of the issue if you don't give your
opinion you just use words like significant well significant
means different things to different people you're just giving
people away to like reinterpret your opinion in a way that works
for them
because again I think you probably understand that your opinion
is not really that acceptable if you break it
>> Yeah, exactly. But like you're the one that's introducing
these like individual values that we can't quantify. The point
is someone in Ethan's position I think would be justified in
being suspicious of everyone in the sense that like you know
like I don't know who who's committed but it could have been
any of them and and and dude this is this is insane. I don't
know who to hurt.
this is like, dude, do do you care about like the
would it be like the Afghanistan war when 911 happened and you
just kind of like invade the Middle East without a real target,
without knowing who's responsible? Hey, we're going to go we're
going to go bomb some brown people. Do you believe in that? Do
you think that was awesome? Yeah, it is. This is the collective
punishment thing. We talked about this a lot before that that's
what it breaks down to for a lot of people. And he's he's like
arguing for it explicitly.
And it's very weird to me. What's really funny though, I think,
is while I don't I don't think it's like a perfect analog for
the Israel Israel stuff, I do think that every person who is
a Zionist knows how to defend Israeli collateral damage, right?
That's Israel does everything they can to make people aware there's
going to be collateral damage. Israel does anything they everything
they can to avoid collateral damage, right? That's how you defend
what ends up being what looks like collective punishment. Okay?
You have all of these same levels of of like you walk down a
dialogue tree of how you're going to excuse whatever war crime
today, right?
You can't apply any of that to Ethan. Ethan explicitly skipped
warning anybody. Ethan explicitly skipped every single step that
in that situation, right, where Israel, you know, bombs somebody
and some other people get hurt or they don't know who's responsible,
so they just bomb some things that they suspect are Hamas compounds
in some way, right? Normally their arguments are, hey, actually,
we dropped flyers. We did doornocking or sorry, roof knocking.
We did we like tried to strike this group over here. They were
intentionally doing like surrounding themselves with civilians.
They've got all of these things to do all this arguing stuff,
right? And Ethan did none of those things. So all the ways these
people usually defend some form of what ends up being collective
punishment or ends up looking like um collateral damage, every
way of defending that is not valid and not applicable to Ethan
Klein. So I just want I wonder how they defend it in this case.
How they defend having this opinion cuz it feels like they're
used to making this argument. Well, you know, you've got some
enemy who's like really decentralized and it's difficult to know
who's leading them or or who's actually doing what and that's
a tough situation. It's like, well, there are techniques for
that. Did Ethan try to do that? I don't know that he did. I've
seen no evidence he did.
So, yeah. I'm just I'm just saying it's very funny to me that
the people I think who would normally argue this because it broke
down on Israel Palestine fight, that's what led to the whole
culture war we're witnessing between the Hassan kind of camp
and the Ethan camp.
It's just very funny that I think a lot of people would defend
Israel in that way. You can't defend it in this way, right? Can't
defend Ethan in this way. So, how do you defend the collective
punishment collateral damage thing without any of those tools
you're naturally used to? It would be very interesting. I guess
maybe we're going to witness it now cuz I'm guessing Pisco's
getting pushed very hard into saying like, "So, you support collective
punishment?" And just being angry at like all of them. And certainly
he was justified in feeling a sense of like what I would think
would be like righteous rage that after the fact it became a
joke. It was like a joke to these people. And at at that was
at best it was a joke. At worst at worst the
>> uh I thought when those when those conservatives like
got a whole bunch of people fired who laughed at Charlie Kirk,
I thought that was awesome. According to Hutch, Hutch thought
that was cool. Hutch thought that was great. Somebody said, "Aha,
you Charlie Kirk bitch." And then them getting fired was justified.
Hutch was totally on that side. Hutch was like 100% there. Oh,
dude. Well, Charlie Kirk died. Of course, conservatives being
upset is like understandable, right? Of course, he had they had
righteous rage towards people joking about it. Is he even listening
to himself? Does he even understand what he's saying?
Difficult to say. >> Same creator. Again, by the way, one
of these people is abandoning all of the values they would normally
state they have. One of these people cannot engage in a single
hypothetical. One of these people has moved goalposts on every
single point they've attempted to argue. And one of these people
is being accused broadly of being bad faith. Shockingly, the
person who did all f the first three is not the person who's
getting accused of being bad faith. Very interesting. Very interesting
stuff. after the fact, including more recently Taylor Loren,
who was making a joke about it. Like they they thought it was
like the like a source of comedy.
>> Like that would I don't know about you, but that would
make me I would boil with rage if I if that was me.
>> But that that's not funny. There's nothing about that
that's funny. We're well beyond internet beef at this point.
The government, you're in the system now. Like you you're maybe
you're asking yourself like, "Oh my god, are they going to take
my kids away?" That is way too far and I don't think it's trivial
>> Yeah, shooting Charlie Kirk was way too
Just wake me up when there's an argument here that doesn't apply
to Charlie Kirk,
right? Just wake me up. Wake me up. Wake me up when it doesn't
all apply to the Charlie Kirk situation. One to one. >> Mark
that or make light of it or justify >> Whether you think
it's trivial on some other norm of being like
>> Yeah. So basically,
if you asked Hutch, was it cool? Do you think it was awesome
that Asminold doxed and tried to get people fired who laughed
at Charlie Kirk who laughed at any part of his assassination?
You think that was awesome? Hutch would have to say yes, right?
Like that's totally righteous anger. We can totally justify that.
It's totally okay. I think anybody criticizing that will not
engage in the argument will not engage with me and my emotions.
respectful to people, you know, after some tragedy occurs of
like, you know, having some standard of decency. That is a separate
inquiry as to whether or not they're after um, you know, conduct
behavior
like it violates some separate norm or standard of decency separate
from the act itself, right? Be I'll give you an example, right?
If someone laughs at the fact that Charlie Kirk got assassinated
after the fact, you wouldn't say that they're culpable for the
act itself and you would recognize that that's that having their
own like moral violation in the laughter is separate from extending
culpability of the assassination itself. You understand that,
don't you? Yes. It would be a different kind of
>> so basically if so I mean I hate to do the Destiny example
because he leaned into the violence but in the Charlie Kirk case
like Destiny would have been calling Charlie Kirk a fascist.
This is going to be totally dispassionate though. He would have
been calling Charlie Kirk a fascist beforehand. Charlie Kirk
gets shot. Destiny refuses to disavow the violence and laughs
at Charlie Kirk being shot. Right? And then
Destiny gets his YouTube monetization taken away. right
now. I at the time kind of played with the idea. It's like do
I really feel that bad for this guy cuz like he's been like a
total piece of [__] to any everyone around me. It's
like I don't feel bad. Probably principally shouldn't want his
monetization taken away for that, right? That's free speech.
Sucks this guy, but that's free speech. Okay.
And
Hutch has to argue now that his monetization financial potential
financial ruination for him is totally appropriate, totally fine
that he advocates for and supports YouTube taking Destiny's monetization
away because around and find out.
I just don't think he would argue that necessarily, but be interesting
to know.
>> Wait,
I know Pisco brings that up because I unfortunately had this
video up on my laptop and it played at some point in the middle
of the night like my internet went out and reconnected and it
autoplayed the video. I'm pretty sure he brings that up at some
point, >> right? But but this is not this is both. This
is a both situation. So like all of those creators were number
one saying that it was justified and number two they were joking
about it after the I have I have been I've been asking for people
to present when one of these three creators said that calling
CPS was >> you just watched a video. You just watched a
video >> in which she never said that this >> uh
again free speech has nothing to do with YouTube monetization.
um it doesn't but I do believe the platforms should broadly if
something's like not necessarily I think the platforms should
broadly if something's not outside of the toos like not necessarily
enforced on stuff like that or like probably it shouldn't be
monetization probably should be like a strike
right like financial ruination which YouTube demonetization or
termination is is not necessarily
is not necessarily
good for somebody who makes a comment like one time right like
I I don't think the appropriate response to Destiny saying I
don't disavow that violence is financial ruination. I might think
he deserves financial ruination for a bevy of other reasons,
but I think explicitly saying that he deserves it for the Charlie
Kirk jokes is insane. >> This predates so so I just want
to this is the logical intell you agree that that that video
edited in the way it was represents and purports and it makes
sense that it does that this happened before the CPS called.
So she can't say you can't say that it is her justification of
the CPS event because linear times. Correct. >> Yeah. Yeah,
that's the point. That's the >> What do you mean? >> This
This was before like Okay, hang on. Let me walk you through this.
Okay. >> Wait, what?
>> Oh, he's going to say that like the CPS video with Bad
Empanada was before, but
Pisco is just responding to Hutch talking about joking about
it after the fact. That's all.
>> did did she agree with the claim that Bad Empata was
making in the video that Ethan's kids got gardy because he was
>> Uh, she says that it's dangerous. said it was dangerous.
>> No, no, no, no, no. Um, >> she she did she agree
is what I asked. >> I'm not sure that. Uh, hang on. I'll
I'll I'll rewatch it. >> All of this because everything
that he >> I'll rewatch it too.
She's very clearly saying like, oh, this explains so much.
>> Wait, so Hutch, do you think she's advocating calling
CPS there? Do you think she's saying anything other than, oh,
I guess Ethan Klein's a parent,
which by the way does not necessarily mean lots of parents can
pass CPS calls.
There's no evidence that she thinks there's a persistent issue
that requires intervention from the government, right? You could
call somebody a parent because of some event and then obviously
not have that apply to like taking their kids away. Hey, this
guy's a parent. Hey, this guy did some things like he had a house
or something. He's very obviously sense. It all makes sense now.
It makes sense why he doesn't care about Palestinian children
when he is neglecting his own. How are you How is this happening?
So >> I actually don't even agree that she ran with the
premise. I actually disagree entirely. Makito, >> someone
asked that and she's reading from a viewer who said who says
it makes sense that he doesn't care about Palestinian kids because
he's negligent about his own. >> No, no, no, no. Like it
start at like >> This is one of those moments where it's
like it's kind of embarrassing for you to say how upset you are
about this thing once somebody else is sitting there watching
it with you. like you, this is like you got really imagine you
got really outraged about the Kyle Written House thing um emotionally
because you thought this guy like a bunch of black people and
you like sit down to watch the video and you realize that like
that's not what happened at all and like you you actually sit
there and you're like [__] I advocated for some really
embarrassing things based on what I'd heard about this and based
on what I felt about it and now I'm watching it actually happen.
It's like, oh, do I really think I feel like that's what's happening
to Hutch here a little
>> Is it How is it that like maybe once a week I I look
into what Ethan Klein's been up to? And every time I manage to
find
and more terrible [__] This is where Ethan tells
the story about his family getting
>> By the way, when when Hutch engages in like the group
thing where he's like, "Oh, this is like they're all part of
a group and they share culpability."
That's his way. Okay.
Uh that's his way of smuggling in bias.
Like he has a bias. He he doesn't like denims because of the
entire situation since October 7th, right? So he doesn't like
denims based on that. When he says there's group responsibility,
he's just smuggling in his bias. He's just advocating for like,
oh, I should be able to think she's terrible. If you took this
and you ran this through, if you could somehow
if you could somehow wipe somebody's mind and just get them to
listen to this in a vacuum, if it wasn't Denim's doing her smug
ass smile, being annoying as Okay, they would never accuse her
of like genuinely advocating to call CPS here, which again, I
hate to keep driving it home, but is like, oh, did this go away?
Oh, this went away. Uhoh.
Uhoh. Well, I had it written here before, but it's genuinely
what he said. He He said, "I have a clip. What if I showed you
a clip, Pisco, of Denim's advocating for the CPS call?" He didn't
have that.
Sorry. That was the claim and I had it written down on a Excalibur
page before, but I don't anymore. >> I'm not seeing what
you're alleging. So, what did you say? Did Did she agree with
the assessment of negligence? I'm not seeing what you're alleging.
So, what did you say? Did Did
>> she agree with the assessment of >> I'll give
I'll give you the exact time stamp. Hold on, dude. >> Dude,
why does he need a time, bro? You can just watch the whole thing
through.
You can just watch the whole thing through, man. When Okay, the
sad thing is is like I I have a whole bunch of people in my regular
audience. Not a lot of people here right now from that regular
audience or what used to be my regular audience is probably quickly
migrating to some other streamer who's willing to support totally
disingenuous losers like Hutch.
um who I could just like walk through this and I feel like I
could be like soft and gentle with and they it's like the the
bias against this is so strong. It doesn't matter if I'm willing
to have like a totally genuine conversation with these people.
They actually just reset every time. It feels like very distressing
to me that humanity is like this. It's another thing that makes
me think democracy is kind of cooked. Unfortunately, I just think
people are
people aren't just like bad at figuring out what they should
think. People are like especially like specifically equipped
to reinforce their own biases. >> Okay, hold on.
So 144, she goes, "What do you think she meant
by that?" >> Wait, hang on. So So 144, she goes, "What
do you think she meant by that?" >> Wait, hang on. >> Do
I really have to engage with that? Like this guy's a serious
actor. This guy says serious things. He has serious
What do you think? H
Oh, you know what? I actually do think she should lose all of
the money she's made in the past 5 years now. Actually, wait.
She said this [__] said
actually take her take close her bank account. Send it directly
to Jerusalem. Not even Ethan Klein. Just for her hatred of the
people. She deserves to pay reparations directly to not Jerusalem.
Tel Aviv. Sorry. Tel Aviv. Okay. Take her entire bank account,
all of her investments, her home, any property she has. Sell
it. Liquidate it all. Send it to Tel Aviv. Now, >> so this
is I'll
go to 129. >> Start at 13. Start at 1:30 but start at
>> So it it cuts the first cut after 1:30. It it goes to
bad >> is covered in dog [__] >> No wonder
it's covered in dog [__] Let the children
infected parasites
known to science from science. I wonder why she got kicked over
all of this cuz everything that he said he's kept over this story
which by the way was apparently compiled. >> What does
that mean? What does it actually mean?
It actually means that she knows bad's probably making up some
bull right now and she's going to go because she doesn't want
to say I disavow that entirely because she's like on her in Klein
arc. Okay, which explains a lot of this. And trust me, she should
be culpable for being on her Ethan Klein arc. But being unable
to like I guess get those messages cleared out of chat is not
enough to make her culpable in any significant way whatsoever
for the CPS call >> by his crew. No wonder this. >> Okay,
so I'm willing to say based on that reaction. >> No wonder
this bad said that. Hm. She's kind of being cute and suggesting
that Ethan is hiding.
>> What am I saying? What what I mean to say is I I'm going
to grant you something. Okay. Can you >> This is literally
trying to concede that that hm is not totally meaningless, right?
Oh, I would even go further to say she's probably signaling to
her audience that like this is something you could pay attention
to, that she's not going to disagree. She's strategically not
disagreeing. I'd even grant you that. But here's the thing. What
is what is bad empanada saying there? That is not okay to say
based on the clip of Ethan Klein, right? You have to go to the
next thing here and say based on the clip of Ethan Klein, where
is the lie from bad empanada right there? That previously unknown
to science. Do we really think Gardio is previously unknown to
science?
>> Are you Are you listening? I don't know if you're listening.
I I'm listening, but I want you to She keeps going and it's pretty
[__] important. >> Always sick. >> No,
no, but did you listen to the It makes sense now.
Makes sense why he doesn't care about >> She says, "No
wonder."
So, she's like obviously
granting that uh Bad Panata's claims are correct. >> Okay,
listen.
>> I don't think so. I don't think that they're all correct.
I think she's saying she's strategically like refusing to disavow
and then
she's not saying
And again, that's like
and probably if Ethan Klein did this in reverse, right? If somebody
was saying something about denims, has has Ethan Klein done that?
I feel like Ethan Klein's put stuff up about a [__]
that he knows is not true and actually specifically like ran
with it. No.
Wait, did Ethan or did Ethan not run with the brothel story?
Could someone tell me? I know I know people would know, but off
the top of my head, I'm guessing that Ethan Klein has tried to
run with the brothel story and anything he can about Hassan [__]
regardless of how accurate it is, right?
And so to me, it seems like this level of refusing to disavow
some lies, some malicious lies about other people, right? Just
going, hm, oh, I guess so.
I personally think that seems to be like kind of part for the
course. And it sucks that something came of one of those lies
that's like unexpected and nobody advocates for, but it's really
also not appropriate to just blame and go after people and say
that they're responsible for those actions just because they
refuse to disavow somebody saying it on a video or somebody I
guess saying it in a chat that they may or may not have seen.
And I think that she uh by her uh tone and indication there is
suggesting that she probably is sympathetic to you that uh this
is neglectful. Okay. >> I think that that that's pretty
much implied by her conduct. I don't think it's explicit. But
but here's what I'm going to ask you. Hutch. >> I will
accept that. But I think
very mild interpretation of what she said because when she says
dude this guy people people actually think like
okay
there's some it's not to meme on the conversation but it's possible
that you do this and isn't Roman P one of the snark mods maybe.
I don't know. Oh wait maybe maybe I do. Is he the guy who gets
like um
Oh, that's just Kathy then. If it's If it's like That's probably
just Kathy. Roman P. I do get it cuz that could be the guy in
the um that's the guy who said he worked for Reddit in the
the thing in the legal mindset video, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry. I I got there before you got there, Ry. I got there before
you typed it. I don't know who Kathy is. Good one, Kathy. That's
Kathy 100%. Roman P is Kathy 100%.
I have I have no doubt in my mind. Same person. Get them in a
call together. Otherwise, they're the same person.
Okay. Um
what was I saying? Oh, so it's possible that her going hm like
if if bad empanada had said this guy is a terrible
father and it's incumbent on everybody to go and call child protective
services in California. Here's the number. And if Denims had
gone h
to that,
I think you'd start to have an argument here about how culpable
she is and how it's like substantial and how like like realistically
that is her kind of trying to dog whistle at specifically
like signaling and saying okay CPS though like call CPS, right?
But that's not what happened. She says hm to like this guy has
dog all over his floor which like I think is a direct quote from
one of the videos man. So, I reject the idea that she's significantly
culpable.
And I reject the idea that where Hutch is talking about the Hm.
This also should just be a huge flag. Okay? Massive flag. If
you're ever going listen to the way she said h there, what do
you think that means? If that's your argument ever,
I might suggest you should find a better argument. You should
find a topic you're more you have a stronger position on. What
is this? You serious, Smatic? You serious? You good? You good?
This is me though. This a black guy. Yeah, you actually got it.
You nailed it 100%. Let's [__] go. Thank you for
the link. >> No wonder dot dot dot dot dot dot. That is
her very obviously saying >> she's suggesting that she
she believed that what he was saying was correct. >> She's
suggesting that um by her kind of like demure or kind of like
little koi little thing that um she thinks that there's something
like either negligent or up or that like there's potentially
credence to what's going on. >> I'm gonna ask you this
Hutch.
Does taking the view that that Ethan was neglectful
in the contraction of Yardia as described by Ethan is having
that view that it in fact was neglectful. If that is your view
is does someone with that view who expresses that view are they
culpable or >> now I'm going to let me ask the [__]
you won't let me [__] talk because you know you know
IT'S ABSURD. IT'S ABSURD. LET ME FINISH. I'm not going to move
on. >> I'm going to lawyer you. I'm going to lawyer you.
I'm not moving. I am not going to respond unless you let me.
>> You're doing But you're doing the [__] You
can't take You will you will you would >> You can ask your
question. So you presented that to me. I granted you something.
I My question comes first touch and then you can ask and I will
answer. I've answered all your >> Why are you let me
>> Dude, I totally just missed whatever this You're doing
the You can't take You will You will You would >> You can
ask your question. So you presented that to me. I granted you
something. I my question comes first touch and then you can >> wait
it actually was it actually was relevant it said things that
make you go >> ask it I will answer [laughter] I've answered
all your questions why are you let me
start getting into my question I start to ask the question ask
the question >> so again a whole bunch of people will just
show you this clip right and they'll go isn't it crazy that Pisco's
like so mad at Hutch and they won't show the previous like two
hours of straight up gaslighting and emotional appeals Right.
Like I think Pisco is kind of getting to the point where he's
like appropriately calibrated here. Hutch is being legitimately
like horribly bad faith in this in this conversation,
right? And like I think Pisco is like actually calibrated correctly
here.
I I think Hutch has just been a total piece of this whole conversation.
But you're doing the You can't take You will You will You would
>> You can ask your question. So you presented that to
me. I I granted you something. I My question comes first touch
and then you can ask and I will answer. I've answered all your
questions. Why are you
>> Every time Hutch has a hypothetical, Pisco does entertain
it. He answers and then they move forward. Right.
And every time Pisco has a hypothetical, Hutch goes, I don't
think that's analogous. I don't think that's right. I don't I
already do that. Yes, I did have breakfast this morning. Yes,
I did have breakfast this morning.
I think it's appropriate
given Hutch's lack of capability in this conversation for Pisco
to be frustrated at this point. Let me I will answer
my question. I start to ask the question. Interrupt me. All right.
So these question ask the question again. Go ahead. Is is the
expression of the view that one feels that Ethan Klein was in
fact negligent with respect to the Jarda incident. So basically
what Pisco is doing here is he's trying to say how do you Hutch
know that she wants to signal that CPS be called versus wanting
to signal that she believes Ethan Klein was a negligent father
and kind of a
and what reason would you have for considering those the same
level of of thought or action right cuz what there is not commensurate
with her believing Ethan Klein's kind of a person and kind of
a negligent dad
but rises to the level of oh CPS must be called now, right? Cuz
obviously if she doesn't believe CPS should be called, let's
grant her that she doesn't believe CPS should be called and she's
just saying that cuz she's like Ethan and he's like a kind of
a person. I do believe he's a little bit negligent with his kids
but probably not CPS level negligent. How do you distinguish
that from where she is with this one? Right. And then how do
you, by the way, when you're saying this is a predicate for the
actual call to CPS, how does the person who called CPS distinguish
that? And should Denims be responsible if that level if that
how they distinguish it or how they determine it is completely
nonsensical?
>> Does ex. >> So that's what I believe Pisco is
going to try to ask here. And that's a good question, right?
It's investigating Hutch's possible bias. I don't think you have
to say that you believe denims doesn't want CPS call to ask that
question, but it would be like what are you using to differentiate
here? The answer is going to be I'm going to use my bias to differentiate,
right? >> Expression of that view on one stream pres one
culpability
for a CPS call later on by some unknown
>> in a vacuum with no other factors. No, that alone would
not be enough to convict. Okay. But you're familiar >> But
if you're familiar, hold on. But you're familiar with the concept
of like factors, right?
>> You're familiar with the concept of factors, right?
Um Yeah, >> I I understand factors. >> Okay. So there's
other factors. So like it's so I would ask why instead of stating
those other factors, Hutch came into this conversation very confident
and told Pisco explicitly, I have a clip of Denims telling her
chat to call CPS. Why did Hutch come into this conversation and
instead of explaining the other factors which by far would contribute
way more to his opinion is what it sounds like. Why would he
come into this conversation and say, "Pisco, I have a call or
I have a stream clip where Denim says you should call CPS." She
advocates for calling CPS. That's that's all you need to like
really figure out what's going on in this debate. Figure out
what's being asked here, right? Like or figure out what's being
stated, what the positions are, how each person is participating.
It's just crazy, man. >> It's her substantiating
bad empanada's claim. Like, she very clearly is telling her audience,
"Oh, wow. This makes so much sense now. She's very clearly >> implicitly
doing that
>> very clearly and then she also says very clearly implying
dude people get really mad. Normally when I I understand sometimes
pedentry can upset people but normally if somebody gives me a
correction that makes it more accurate I'll say oh yeah I was
just wasn't thinking my bad was not being like was not being
rigorous. Wasn't thinking thank you. Right? even if it is pedantic.
But Hutch gets like very offended if you're um if you're clear,
right? If you're explicit. She explicitly says it. No, that's
like saying she literally said it. She didn't. She implicitly
said it. She said
cuz she didn't literally say it. Hutch. Literally saying it is
a
Okay. By the way, guys, this is really serious. His kids could
die.
And then also, >> so I'm going to ask I'm not done. There's
one more factor. Okay. And then also there's hella people in
her chat spamming. Somebody should call CPS.
>> Oh, dude. And by the way, just to reiterate, he is using
the badly photoshopped and edited clip that is totally disingenuous
to back this opinion. So he came into this conversation with
this is his basis for the chat and with this clip also is the
basis for saying she explicitly called for people to call CPS.
So hold on let me let me uh go grab that really quickly. I just
want that clip because it's actually very important. Uh denims
hold on hold on hold on hold on. Is that it? Oh hold on hold
on. I got to I got to find it. It's actually important. So you're
you're just waiting for a second. Had a video. What was the quote?
I actually lost it. No, this is the Yeah, this is the this is
the Reddit thread right here, Riy. I've got it up here already.
I'm looking for the the quote from Hutch in this debate, which
was like, "What if I told you I What if I Here, here it is. Finally
got it." Jesus, I couldn't remember the precise quote cuz I don't
have it written down
Oh, that's muted. There. What if I could show you a video of
Denims herself saying that somebody should call CPS on Ethan?
Go >> for it. I I would say that's independently bad. Yeah.
Okay. So that is what he came into the conversation thinking
he had. Okay. Pisco has now seen the clip of Denims debunking
the chat spam CPS rumor and he realized Hutch must have been
lying. Well,
Hutch,
this is a genuine like
um a conversation has to occur between these two and if you want
to maintain a friendship that conversation has to happen off
stream. I'm sorry to cut content. That conversation cannot happen
on stream because for Pisco to say the things he wants to say
given that Hutch is a content creator if Hutch is going to concede
to any of the things that he would have to to maintain that friendship
that happen that has to happen in private otherwise that is way
too like egotistically bad. And I would advise Hutch and I know
he wouldn't take me seriously but I would advise him.
The only thing that could prevent you from apologizing about
the level of condescension you had, the level of confidence you
had with no evidence, with bad evidence, right? The only thing
is it's all an apology. You would have to apologize because this
was an embarrassing display where you clearly were trying to
signal to your audience that your friend was wrong while never
being able to mount a significant argument of your own and constantly
appealing to emotion.
you tried to this guy and I would be a little concerned if I
were you that some people might have a vested interest in buffing
up your confidence on how well you did in this conversation or
how bad Faith Pisco might have been. I don't think he'll watch
this. I don't think that's going to happen. But I'm just saying
if they wanted to save this friendship and they want to be friends
going forward, I don't think this content can continue to happen
on stream because I think basically Hutch would have to keep
either Hutch keeps lying or he totally like in a way where he
loses his audience and it's like with his money.
Yeah, I'm like I'm I'm sorry. It's rough, man. So again, Hutch's
opinions are based on emotional
like emotionally modified memories that are not real that he
can't defend and he's condescending to Pisco about how Pisco
is treating the conversation. Totally crazy, man. Totally wild
stuff. Now, would you agree that that is some level of possible
culpability? >> No. Okay, that one I think um Okay, that
one I think that's a language issue because I actually disagree
with Pisco there. Like there is some level of culpability there.
It's just not worth calling culpability. I think it's a language
thing, right? Like in terms of
factors going into that CPS call. I don't think it would be unreasonable
to say Hutch or sorry, Den Denims has like a 0.01%
like contribution. The thing is it's a contribution that is so
negligent. I'm sorry. No. So
tiny, right? That you probably don't have to you probably don't
have to support saying that that it's like it's proven or it's
shown or it's anything, right? It's like a tiny tiny little
>> Not for the action itself. For the CPS call that's unhinged
to think that she has culpability for for that merely that >> I
would say it's unhinged to think she has significant culpability.
It's probably Yeah, it's like negligible. Yeah, that was what
I was looking for. negligible culpability, right? Like that it's
essentially not worth acknowledging
>> for the CPS call. That's unhinged. >> Okay. And
and let me explain why because we're we're gonna get into it,
right?
Do >> you think it's >> Dude, I feel like this conversation's
gone on so long and Pisco still hasn't gotten to make his like
overall argument, which is hilarious.
Like Denim's, sorry, not Denims. This is how arguments will always
go with like H3 types is they will get you to go through the
hardest part of the conversation for you and God help you if
you stop there. Okay,
you have to defend all of Denim's comments watching that bad
empanada video. You have to take all of the negative optics of
that. I'm going to totally app you in front of your audience
right now. I know your audience mostly comes from like a Destiny
adjacent sphere where they all hate Hassan and they all think
Ethan's in the right and I'm going to you in the Pisco, okay?
and make you defend things that will make them freak the out.
Even though you're correct, even though you're intellectually
rigorous, I'm going to make you defend those cuz you Pisco. Okay.
And then now this has happened to me multiple times. I hope it
doesn't happen to Pisco. And then run away. There's no way he'll
run away after like after like like talking about and litigating
the worst part of this whole conversation for Pisco, right?
>> I
that can't be possible. 0% chance. >> So she So that I
think is a violation. One, I don't think it's necessarily negligent
what you're talking about. Kids will do things and uh accidents
>> See, I do understand how now optically people will like
frame Pisco is bad faith here. I think the thing that got them
here is pretty rough. Okay. Like how how you get them here is
pretty rough cuz I've seen Hutch act in like aborant ways at
this point. And now I don't like the way Pisco's acting, but
it's very difficult for me to figure out how to handle that because
I do think it's like totally understandable after hours of Pisco
being bad faith to feel like this is the way it is. Okay, hold
on. Okay. All right.
Sorry, I'm being sent stuff out of order maybe. Sorry, in order,
but I Here's the clip. It's >> great video. Give it a watch
from Hassan Fer. Great video. >> Yeah, Hassan uh restoried
it.
great video. Give it a watch. It's funny because on one hand
everyone was trying to give him credit like, "Oh [snorts] yeah,
I'm against CPS. Don't call that. That's crazy." Obviously, which
I agree with. And I was like, "Good. [snorts] Thank you." But
at the same dude, remember the sniffer? Remember the sniffer
timeline? People complain about the coughing timeline. Remember
the sniffer timeline? That was so much worse. Thank god we're
on the coughing timeline. Okay. Holy [__] >> That
That's crazy obviously, which I [snorts] agree with. And I was
like, "Good. Thank you." But at the same at the same exact time,
he's restoring a video entitled the YouTubers back to genocide
with a picture of me in it contributing directly to the environment
in which
people think it's uh acceptable to call CPS on me. >> So
total disavow from Hassan. What does that get Hassan disavowed
for contributing to the environment? Hey, you think these guys
actually contribute to problems in Palestine? You think they
contribute to normalizing to manufacturing consent for a genocide?
Well, that's contributing to the environment in which it's acceptable
to call CPS on me, guys. So, it doesn't matter if you diss about
it. Literally, go [__] yourself, Assan. Okay, bro.
Okay, bro. Okay, dude. And then there was Sorry, there's one
other one here being sent this stuff. This is coming from the
guy who literally said his go
hold on, let's go through here. I've said since the beginning,
it feels like they want me to kill myself. This is their goal.
Unironically, the heartbreaking reality Ethan has Yeah. After
that Casey trot apology, I don't think it's crazy to suggest
that that might be Ethan's goal, too. Oh,
speaking. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Speaking of Wait, I actually have an incredibly relevant clip.
Wait, I forgot there's an incredibly relevant clip here that
I can play. Give me a second. Give me a second. This is Broen
breaks down crying unable to make enough money streaming. >> And
Twitch streaming sucks. I [__] hate it. [snorts]
It's been bad for a few >> Yeah, but just just have fun
with it. Like, if you have fun with it, it doesn't matter. Forget
about the money. Just have fun. >> It's my job though.
I have to focus on the money.
>> I know. I know you do. But that's unfortunately like
you can't control the money. You can only control the content,
you know? Like you can't control how many how much money people
give you. That's not going to be something you can control. You
can just control on how much fun you have and then hopefully
the money will come. You know, >> I've said this since
the beginning. It feels like they want me to kill myself. this
is their goal unironically.
>> No, no, no. It's f like when honestly like you can't
control it. People are hurting right now. It's not a It's not
a great time for anyone to like be giving, you know, discretionary
funds. So, if you just have fun, like you're going to make money.
Like, do your fun stuff. I I love when I see you. I'm not I was
just [__] with you, but I really do. >> Oh,
dude. This is going to be brutal. Sometimes you got to be honest
with people. Like, maybe maybe it's time to take a break. Maybe
it's time to take a break for a little bit. Okay. Trust me, I
think every single dude, I've watched I keep like a pretty solid
eye on how much streamers make in income and I've watched stuff
dry up for literally everybody. Like there is basically nobody
who's making what they were making 6 months ago or 12 months
ago right now. I luckily was making enough that the stuff I'm
making now is still like good. But holy [__]
Like I'm I'm looking at this and I'm like, dude, I if you were
barely making money before, I don't know how you keep streaming
as a job. Like that's that's rough, dude.
There was a commentary bubble for sure. Well, it's not even that
there's a bubble. It's that um I think people just like the viewership's
not really all that different.
Like the viewership in engagements in terms of chats not very
different. I think it's like a lot of people are either stressed
and they don't want to watch anything serious and or like they
sorry coupled with the fact that they're just making less money
or they're economically like feeling anxiety. It is it is just
tough, man. It's tough times. So, I just I I get it that like
I feel probably everyone's going to get squeezed pretty hard.
I I understand. I feel empathy. Okay.
Not enough to personally give money, but I do feel empathy. >> Like
when you do like >> Oh, and he's about to tell her like,
"Dude, like your video game content that nobody pays money for
or watches, which >> silly stuff. You're really funny at
that stuff." Like the Joker thing that we did together. That
was hilarious. >> Or wells have run dry and tastes are
changing. I don't think so. Makito because I don't see people
like leaving this ecosystem overall. I don't see everything getting
way less likes in this ecosystem overall,
right?
I don't think that's the case. I do think honestly
that just I think I legitimately think it's economic anxiety
for people like they're actually it's tough to want to spend
money on a stream. Speaking of which, guys, if you like the content,
okay, you can add more time to the stream by subbing or donating,
okay? Hey, you can sub on kick. You can sub on Twitch. You give
a Twitch Prime if you're watching via Twitch right now. You can
go and write exclamation point donate the chat. There's TTS messages
you can pay for on the stream. Okay, Kickbot lets you do AITTS.
Streamlabs is $3 minimum. It saves your payment info. It's a
little different. Okay, we just have two different platforms
there. Use either one. Isn't December the worst month for streamers
historically? Maybe. Um I think ad ads wise it's supposed to
be good, but for other stuff it might not be good. Yeah, guys,
give kicks, give whatever you can. Uh, every dollar you contribute
adds more time to the stream.
All right, we are four five subs away for another hour on the
stream right now. Okay, we're going to get through this stuff.
I know it. I feel it. I can see it. It's going to happen. Let's
go. >> Okay. Apparently, there's a video. >> All right.
Show us. >> It's on my stream. Just pull up my >> Can
you share it on Discord? I
>> Are there any streamers getting ad revenue like they
used to? No, I think basically everything's down like across
the board
like like there's significant economic contraction everywhere
and the only reason you don't hear about a
this is Pisco let his mental state show through for two seconds
[laughter]
[screaming] people are tired of ads. Well, I don't get ads on
kick. I'm just saying I think literally I think there's just
economic contraction everywhere. Everyone's trying to cut to
make sure they don't lose like their companies. I think you're
going to see that. I think on kick there might even be a little
bit of a cut on kick right now. It's not significant.
The I I'd say yesterday was the first time I've ever looked at
the amount of money I made, which is good. You don't have to
worry about it. I'm not in trouble at all. But the first time
I ever looked and it was like off of what I had expected. Like
I normally have a very good eye for how much money I'm going
to make for a day of content. And I was off by like a hundred
bucks, which is not normal. I'm normally like on by like give
or take 20 bucks usually. I was off by like a 100, but I like
I'm not worried about it. It was still good content. As long
as you turn out good content, you can make it through this. Plus,
I built up like a bit of a war chest anyway, so we can keep going
with it. Gambling does great during a depression. Oh, boy. Well,
time to get a steak contract, guys. That's
That's not kick.com, but stake.com/jstk.
All right, guys. Don't forget forget to put the code in. Um,
up to $200 free with your first deposit. Let's go. Uh, wrong
video. were on this one. So, >> I don't think that it shows
negligence. I just want to be clear about that. That um they
>> you did take a few more days off this month. Well, last
month I took a lot of days off. So, I do have to also grind on
being cons consistent because I think I took almost 10 days off
in November.
So, I think I have to grind to be consistent to make sure I'm
like actually getting viewership consistently each night, right?
Like you can't take 10 nights off fairly unpredictably and then
have the same viewership when you come back. You're going to
have to grind that back up a little bit. the accidents happen
and I don't think that it shows negligence. I just want to be
clear about that that um they contracted a disease. All right.
So I want to be clear that I don't agree that this is uh necessarily
indicative of negligent behavior just to be honest with you.
Okay. And I >> with Ethan with his f Okay. Yeah, I >> I'm
just expressing why do you like say >> I agree. What like
what do you like >> dude? Oh Pisco's realized it. He's
looked at Hutch's stupid [__] face a couple times.
>> We're going to get into it. >> Hold on. Hold on.
What was that? Hold on. Is that that far away from this? It's
like back here, isn't it? Now, I'll >> We're gonna get
into it, right? Oh, give >> You think it's a zero% chance?
>> So, she So, that I think is a violation. One, I don't
think it's necessarily negligent what you're talking about. Kids
will do things and uh >> Hutch no like Hutch no like >> accidents
happen. >> Dude, I'm doing the thing. I should be calm
about this again. >> And I don't think that it shows negligence.
I just want to be clear about that. That um they contracted a
disease. All right. So, I want to be clear that I don't agree
that this is necessarily negative.
Does is he actually listening to anything that Pisco is saying?
Pisco is saying that like
it could be this, but I don't actually agree that it is this.
He's like agreeing with Hutch and is he not maybe I'm missing.
>> I don't think it's necessarily negligent what you're
talking about. Kids will do things and uh accidents happen and
I don't think that >> Oh yeah. No, this is the obvious
dude. The fact of the matter is sometimes kids be putting poop
in their mouth. Okay. You cannot be everywhere at all times.
Sometimes a little baby gets some poop in their mouth. Okay,
kids are they will put random [__] from the ground
in their mouths. That's true.
If your dog goes poop and your kid happens to be there and they
see it and they put in their mouth, that sucks. That's why CPS
shouldn't be called just for Ethan telling this story. By the
way, that's like people who have never owned a dog and also had
a toddler in the house. That's like straight up. Yeah, they eat
dirt. They do all kinds of They put all kinds of things in their
mouth. That's literally a phase of development where you put
things in your mouth. Don't you put it in your mouth. Okay. Just
it's like a thing. And so Pisco is saying that like I don't think
it's indicative of negligence that he tells this story which
is yeah true. That's obviously true. But Hutch just like me,
okay, cuz I had to go back and rewind. Wasn't paying attention
and he's just performing a bunch of faces >> that it shows
negligence. I just want to be clear about that. That um they
contracted a disease. All right. So I want to be clear that I
don't agree that this is uh necessarily indicative of negligent
behavior just to be honest with you. Okay. And I >> with
Ethan with his fan. Okay. Yeah, I >> I'm just expressing
why do you use like
>> it's actually like so rude, right? It's so condescending.
Unfortunately, this guy Pisco does go a little he can be yappy
cuz he does restate his like positive position a lot of the time.
That's like Pisco's constant state is he's like reinforcing and
and describing what you could hold him accountable for cuz he
actually wants the intellectual exercise, right? So, he's like
forming an idea where he's like, "This is what I think about
how you could think about your kids eating poop. This is my entire
thought on kids eating poop right here. There it is, PC." And
Hutch is like, "Uh, yeah. Okay, I guess." >> Like, I agree.
What? Like, what are you >> I don't know how we got there.
What are we doing? Are you
>> okay? What is Pisco doing? Pisco is saying
so this goes back I believe to how do you Hutch know that Denims
isn't just saying that there was some negligent behavior here
and but she is actually escalating from that and saying CPS needs
to be called as a regard as regards that negligent behavior.
So she is saying, "I don't even know if he cares about his kids.
What a fuck." But how do you know that that extends into he's
so negligent so often that he has to call that somebody should
call CPS,
right? And so Pisco says, "I don't even necessarily agree that
it would be negligent to be able to tell the story that this
story is indicative of negligence. But if they argued that, how
would you answer?"
Man, I don't even have to I don't even really have to pay that
much attention cuz all of Pisco's opinions kind of just track
onto reality and how you should be thinking about the situation.
I could just go, wait, what was Pisco saying? Oh, I can reconstruct
it. How >> So, the thing is, I'll say things and people
will distort everything I'm saying. So, I want to be clear about
where I stand. I don't think that the mere fact that your kid
contracted Jardia, which Ethan states very strongly uh that he
believes that his children have during the video, I don't think
the mere fact that they contracted it, even through feces, even
through dog feces, even through uh even a perfectly responsive
parent, this kind of [__] happens. And I don't think
that you've shown negligence by the mere fact that they've contracted
this disease. The reason I'm saying this, Hut, because it feels
like I need to justify everything I say to you, is to make sure
people understand my view on whether or not this entails negligence.
It's not my view that it entails, >> but the notion that
the if one, >> so he goes all the way out of his way because
he knows people are going to get very, very, very, very mad when
he says, I don't think Denim's really justified calling CPS,
right? Like I don't think I don't think she Sorry. I don't think
she's responsible. I don't think she advocated for it. I don't
even think she implied that she was advocating for it. Right.
But Pisco wants to say that I don't think there's negligence
there because I'm going to make an argument for what I think
Denims thinks and what I what I'm asking you to differentiate
from and I don't want you to freak out and say that I am arguing
that Ethan Klein is a negligent father because I don't believe
that.
But again, this is like this is extreme levels of thinking that
baffle the minds of people like >> has the belief that
it is negl. Wait, hold on. I don't know why JTO keeps spreading
the lie that kids ate literal poop. Oh, sorry. We're basing this
all on the fact that Ethan Klein said his kids ate literal poop.
Archangel,
that's what we're basing this on, right? So, I'm I understand
that Ethan Klein said came out and said actually they didn't
eat dog poop. But the argument we just engaged in, so Archangel,
you're actually the example of Hutch now for us. The argument
we just talked about, what we just talked about in general was
explaining that even if that happened,
that still wouldn't be a reason to call CPS. But Ethan Klein
did say it and so we were saying if you were operating from that
perspective, it's not our opinion, it's not anyone's opinion
that CPS should be called, you know,
and they express that belief that they feel they say, "Oh, yeah,
that's negligent. Why how could you let you I would never >> Wow,
how condescending. I am very condescending to my chatter sometimes.
Sorry, Archangel.
Uh, I'm sorry. I was I was condescending there. If that affected
you understanding what I was saying, that sucks. But um yeah,
I hope you don't take the condescension personally. My bad. Extreme
persona. >> Never let my baby do that. That's just irresponsible
parenting at the expression of that view in by in isolation or
in conjunction with the the different things that you've said
that that constitutes culpability for some whack job later on
who calls CPS. That is bizarre, untenable, totally up, not true.
And you would never apply this standard to anyone else. I mean,
it it really just boggles the mind that you think that that independent
conduct now they could be violating their own norms of moderation.
They could be vi violating the the uh like I understand Pisc's
wordy. I I truly believe Hutch is just not understanding him
at all.
Man,
it's too bad they went for so long cuz I guarantee you a ton
of people would have reacted to this conversation if it wasn't
like 4 and 1/2 hours. And now I don't know if people will react
to it. I don't know if people have reacted to it. I would love
to see just because to me if you're like tracking the arguments
it seems very obvious that like Hutch kind of can't he kind of
just can't understand what Pisco is saying most of the time.
>> Um you know a standard of decency with respect to other
graders to give caveats etc. But that is a different ethical
violation and culpability for the act itself which I want to
get to.
Dude, dude,
dude, why?
What is this? What is this streamer? What is this streaming technique
of like I never make an argument. I just make faces.
This is the first debater who is a deaf blind mute. He just emotes
at the camera and never professes any idea or belief. The is
happening.
He just emotes at the camera. It's all he does.
It's so embarrassing. The demon mama school of debate. Yeah,
but this is a grown man. It's not like a Well, actually, never
mind. I should find an actual distinguishing factor. Um,
I'm going to hit play. Actually, don't want that one to slip
through or I want that one to slip through. Oh, it's muted. What?
Why do I [__] a standard of decency with respect
to other graders to give caveats, etc. But that is a different
ethical violation than culpability for the act itself, which
I want to get to at some point. >> We disavow that comment.
That comment was uncalled for for unrelated reasons. If you're
watching a Twitch chat, head over to kick.com/jastk.
That's where the stream will continue. Okay, we got at least
another hour of content coming up. Please head over to kick.com/jdk.
We'll see you guys later. Bye. >> You let me um put that
out. Well, now I want to test your ethics here because like Okay,
so you know, for example, we've we've had um there's been an
example of of of a LLM that um enabled someone's unaling ideation
and then that person went on to un >> Dude, LLM's be coming
for my job. What the man? LM's be coming right.
They be coming for my job, dude. What the That's my job.
alive themselves. Now, the ultimate culpability for the taking
the decision to unal alive themselves that that would be rest
on the person, right? Like ultimately they're the one that made
the decision, but like does the LLM and the software company
that engineered that uh model have any culpability there. >> Yeah.
So, we're talking true. >> Now, I want Hutch to basically
Pisco should say actually I think it'd be really really cool
to hear your opinion on that Hutch. How would you go about figuring
that out? How would you go about when it's not clear, when it's
very difficult to understand, how would you go about like doing
out responsibility there? And how would you hold them responsible
based on whatever probability you thought there was that they
were culpable in some way, right?
Like why
how would you engage in that exercise?
>> That is the the context of products liability. And um
there I I think that you can make an argument that if the usage
of the device itself
um constitutes an unjustifiable risk uh such that we can reasonably
foresee that this kind of would happen uh based on >> Oh
look is it could you foresee it? Is it foreseeable?
Right. Is it
Wow. I just think you're close to making that empirical case
uh for this kind of conduct and and certainly not the conduct
if it's merely negligent in the context of these kinds of statement
to to like if someone who's negligent on that you're going to
get a civil judgment or something in the again we're talking
ethics here so we're just removing it from it context but I do
acknowledge that there can be causes of action and uh culpability
for for negligence and stuff but but not when it's being like
the causal chain here is being broken by the clearly culpable
actors who do the bad thing here. And so, for example, I'll give
you I'll give you an example. Let's say that you have
um some kind of inherently dangerous
>> Okay, that's so that's not difficult to understand,
right? Dude, I feel like I feel like graphics could make this
really easy for people. Um like like just drawing out the the
causal chain like Hutch could understand, right? Like what P
what Pisco is saying here is not difficult to pick up, but he
is a little wordy and it can be difficult to follow in the moment.
So he's saying that like obviously you'd have to decide how foreseeable
it was given what what they were using it for what the advertised
purpose was there'd be like a whole bunch of factors you draw
into this and I think those factors those exact factors we're
talking about with regards to denims kind of place her outside
the chain of culpability like she is essentially negligibly culpable
here right he didn't understand after product liability yeah
I just don't think there's like that is there's legitimately
I think Hutch could be coached into understanding what Pisco
is saying but he does not have the ability to intuit it on the
fly like to hear what Pisco says and understand it on the fly
and then engage back with it. He tragically lacks the spark.
He is not he's not been in sold to the level that some of the
people in this space have. He lacks the spark. He does not have
the light in his eyes. And when this conversation is happening
and Pisco is laying out his reasons, criteria for how you determine
liability in that case,
I think Hutch is just like not really there's nobody home, man.
There's nobody home. device.
Okay, so you have a lawn mower that um it contains a product
defect. All right, contains a product defect and it is dangerous
to maneuver and sometimes the [__] flies off and
then so someone is operating it and uses the lawn mower to
their own kid on purpose. Would you say that that lawn mower
which has the defect which could you know >> this is 100%
a thought experiment Pisco has had in law school he did not there's
a 0% chance he just came up with this on the fly. Okay. Absolutely
0% chance he didn't know this one before. This is like a very
complex example that I think is going to illustrate his point
very very very like well and I'm almost positive that this is
like one to one from a textbook >> is operating it and
uses the lawn mower to
their own kid on purpose. Would you say that that lawn mower
which has the defect which could you know cause the death of
a child in certain circumstances carries with it a risk you would
not. Exactly. Right. So you have to understand that there's this
notion of uh in the in the damages context in in in log and we're
but I think this also applies to our own >> foreseeability
ethics there's this notion of proximate causation okay that in
order to really feel liable for the kinds of things that we are
talking about here and we're talking about like big lawsuits
and from an ethical perspective but in the civil damages context
for whatever harm is being caused that there's some kind of attenuation
and and often times the >> as in the I I think it's going
to be as it becomes less foreseeable as you become less responsible
actually as it becomes less foreseeable essentially you become
less culpable
and I guess I there's approximate cause as your causal link to
the actual event happening the actual thing happening becomes
less direct and and less um obvious you lose your liability becomes
>> causal chain is cut off by the culpable conduct of other
people so for example let's say that um you There are two actors
involved in some kind of lawsuit. >> Oh, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. But if you found
out, right, if so, Pisco has to add this part for us to understand.
If you found out that that person watched Denim stream and as
a direct cause, if you knew that omnisient knowledge as a direct
result of Denim's stream that
that he decided to do it, that he decided to do this call.
Oh, would she then gain like slight? No. No, I don't think so.
I don't think in Pisco's mind she because it's about what Denims
knows, right? Denims would have to have some understanding that
that person's there or that like some concept that that would
be happening. Some concept that that could happen.
That's why I would give like a little bit like a negligible but
like totally negligible amount of culpability to her because
I think there's probably an argument that she does know about
moderating you know calls to action in her community and you
can't really know if she saw this or not. There is some world
where she did see it. She didn't say anything and I think there's
like some negligible amount there but it's it is totally negligible.
It's like completely insane to suggest that she has like a significant
portion of the responsibility or culpability for this >> and
one really they did something horribly intentional. >> But
do you see how I could actually have this conversation with Pisco
and like interact with the terms he's using, interact with the
concepts he's talking about
and not just be completely incapable, not just be completely
lost.
>> Uh she talks about not tapping the glass sometimes.
I know she talked about that after, which is why when I say she
disavows the call, she clearly categorically disavows any touching
the poo. Okay, that's what I like to say, the Kiwi Farms notion,
touching the poo. >> This notion of approximate causation,
which is I think reflecting our intuitive notions of morality,
that is going to notwithstanding potential reckless conduct of
others, we're going to see uh the cause and source of the harm
as uh being too attenuated to to track to the specific actor
who was negligent but not intentional and malicious. And so that's
what I'm trying to describe here is no doubt that there potentially
is some like source of of negligence here or some kind of uh
bad statement that's made by Denims. I would agree with that.
I even agree that like she is implying that she agrees that it
was negligent. What you're failing to provide is a close enough
proximity to the malicious conduct. You're not even close to
>> So basically the thing that I think connects this maybe
connects this, okay, is that there could be the concept of like
gross negligence, like provable gross negligence where you could
say Denims is held responsible for something, right? And that's
probably what Hutch would would aim at is like he was intentionally
negligent in some way or she was intentionally negligent in some
way, but there's just no evidence for that, right? Other than
vibes, other than I really hate this, I think she really hates
Ethan Klein. I think she would totally refuse
to moderate anything if people are calling to inclined. She wouldn't
even moderate that in her chat. Right. Yeah. So I think I think
that's what like Hutch probably believes that we've reached that
level of bar where that's sorry just for me it's like approximate
causation like the the
proximity of Denim's
and how causal she was to this is is very far away. Okay. Very
far away.
And Pisco is saying that essentially you no longer say under
legal circumstances that she is responsible or culpable. I think
there's Hutch is speaking in a more colloquial way where he's
talking about like percentage. Realistically, Pisco is probably
at like.1%.
Like approximate cause causation, right? Like how much of the
cause did she contribute to? Contributo uh was it called contributo
causality? He had a word for it, but basically like how much
you've contributed. Okay. He probably believes it's a little
bit, but it's so weak that you can't really hold her responsible.
You can't say she's responsible. It's like actually more dishonest
to say she's responsible than to say she has like some tiny part
to play here, right? There's just a way better way to say it.
So, you don't say she's responsible or culpable. You say she
has like some tiny shared amount of responsibility, but it's
like not worth talking about cuz otherwise you're just lying
to people. ascribe the kind of malicious intentional culpable
conduct that would justify these kinds of things and you know
bankrupting people. I mean that that's what you found. >> I
don't know how to but I don't know how >> he did say approximate
causality. I guess approximate causality is like a density map
from like the the event and you map out basically what every
contributing event what every contributing factor and person
like what they added up to to make like uh 100%. Somewhere in
the middle. >> Um I think of things in density maps and
you guys have no idea what I'm talking about. But I'll just keep
going. >> I don't know how to reconcile what you just said
with with respect to culpability and this idea that it's absurd
to suggest that she had any culpability. I don't know how to
reconcile that with the fact that you called her negligent. And
I don't know how to >> Oh, I perfectly predicted exactly
how Hutch would misunderstand. I'm in the golem's head now. I
can control it. I can control it. I know the code phrase. >> Reconcile
that with the fact that you said that by not moderating. No,
like I'm telling you he he thinks like there's somewhere here
there there's like gross negligence and that could be a cause.
He he doesn't understand that basically Pisco is saying we've
we've reached the wrong verbiage, right? Like basically under
5% or under like 2% Pisco believes basically you no longer say
someone is culpable. That saying they're culpable is like a lie,
right? like
in terms of their
how
I guess in terms of approximate causation. If they're if they've
contributed very very little to say they're culpable is stupid.
It's like actually probably unethical to say they're culpable.
That's like what he's running into. So there's like a there's
like a floor on how much you need to be culpable for an action
for somebody to be able to ethically say you're culpable for
that action.
And he that's what he's describing. So basically once it gets
below a floor which Pisco is saying is this is below his floor
he says it's actually wrong to say they're culpable. So that's
what Hutch is misunderstanding. >> You increase the risk
of something happening like you you seem capable in one moment
of understanding that someone can be that someone can have um
can indirectly
like contribute to something happening. You you you seem to be
able to comprehend that over here. But then when we get to the
point where I say she's partly culpable just like all those creator
creators are, you fall back on this idea that >> Hold on.
Hold on. Pisco literally decided to draw it out. Oh [__]
He's drawing it out right now. >> It's preposterous to
>> uh Ry, if you have a minute, could you go grab the time
stamp of him drawing this out because he's talking about literally
like proximate uh Yeah, approximate causate causality. I lost
it. I lost it. >> Let me build a case so because clearly
I'm not explaining myself.
I would think that you're making an argument that's not dealing
with what anyone here is saying. Velvet Moss, you literally just
had to invoke lefties. And so I started reading your argument.
If you want to make an argument about what anyone here is saying,
what Pisco is saying, what I'm saying, I'd be perfectly happy
to engage with that. Also be happy to talk to you in the Discord
if you disagree. >> You understand there could be different
ethical obligations, correct? >> Generally. Yeah. So like
you have an obligation in life like you have an obligation uh
not to infringe the rights of others. You have an obligation
to take due care when you're driving the car. Okay. And a viol.
>> Yo, venomous villain. Thank you for the five gifted.
Let's go. Let's go. That's another hour on the stream. What's
up? What's up? Thank you very much. Appreciate it, dude. >> Violation
of one ethical obligation doesn't necessitate a violation of
some other ethical obligation that is distinct. Correct. So,
like the fact that I Okay. So when I say that you could have
a self-standing violation of an obligation related to responsible
moderating and that doesn't entail culpability for the specific
act, what I'm telling you is the following. You have a self-standing
ethical obligation not to pursue frivolous CPS calls or um you
know harassing uh false reports to CPS or whatever. And that
>> listen to take a second to listen. All right. So there's
a little wordy sometimes. Okay.
I honestly I do think and this is something um this is the one
thing I think I got respect in multiple workplaces for doing
this exact thing that nobody's willing to do. I don't think I've
ever really done it on stream and streamers just can't do it
because of ego. Um I swear to God and engineers respect the out
of this. I'm so willing to go hey man I didn't understand any
of that. I don't know what the you're talking about. I'm basically
a Can you explain that to me again? Like I am a child cuz I didn't
get it. I literally didn't get it. I'm I'm behind and now if
you don't catch me back up, I'm [__]
So please catch me back up. There's nothing better than somebody
who will literally tell you, I'm lost. I'm lost. Help. I'm lost.
Help.
Right. And I regrettably in this conversation I'm almost positive
that Hutch is saying, "I'm lost." And he refuses. He based on
ego cannot say, "I'm lost. Help. I don't know what you mean.
Right. So, when Pisco is talking about all these things, a self-standing
obligation, I don't know what a self-standing obligation is,
is that's a self-standing obligation. I would assume something
you have to hold yourself to that is not like required by law,
but something you do because it's a moral right to do.
A self-standing obligation is an independent duty that is not
contingent upon the actions or performance of another party,
nor is it merely an aspect of broader non-binding principle.
The term has specific applications to both legal and philosophical
contexts.
Okay. Uh, example, a tenants's obligation to pay monthly rent
may be independent of the landlord's duty to perform timely repairs.
Um, the tenant must pay rent even if repairs are delayed. Okay.
Oh, so it's like an independent self-standing is just an independent
variable. You you should do this thing regardless of how other
people act. So, you have a self-standing obligation not to dox
people. You can't go, "Oh, well, somebody I think somebody docks
me. I can't prove it, but I think they dox me or my friend, so
I'm going to dox them." No, you have a self-standing obligation
to act with like
I don't know like
moral purity like in a moral way. Yeah. So, it's totally independent.
All right. But like I wouldn't I don't know that. I'm like inferring
from context when he says it. It didn't seem super important.
But I'm saying if I if I'm missing that I have a feeling Hutch
is probably missing a lot of things here. You know what I'm saying?
And I just think I think that's where the conversation is suffering
is. I'm pretty sure he's like actually kind of lost in a lot
of these cases. Also, Matt NLT, thank you for the five gifted
as well. We're one gift away from another hour here. Um, we already
added the one more hour, right? So, we can add another hour.
We get one more gifted. Let's go.
Destiny must not be familiar with self-standing obligations.
How could you tell?
But yeah, I think that's the big thing. So, Hutch says you're
a little wordy, bro. If you just said like, I don't understand
what you're saying. He legitimately just doesn't understand.
And maybe you want to say, okay, well, that's on Pisco to be
better understood. It is a little bit,
I don't know. I'm not I don't do this as a living for a living,
right? I don't have debates for a living. I'm not a political
actor for a living. I don't on a weekly basis on a weekly cadence
interact with Pisco for up to three hours a day in that day,
right? Sorry, for up to three hours a week. I would
to be honest, that if you are somebody who's a co-host of his
podcast, you're probably familiar with some of these terms that
you shouldn't be getting lost. So, I don't know, man. Ethical
obligation number one,
do not falsify maliciously PP or state things to CPS that are
frivolous or not bases for genuine concern or something like
that. Okay? Or not sufficient. >> Ethical obligation number
one. >> Ethical obligation number two,
>> do not needlessly
increase uh risk by failing failing to responsibly moderate.
I just gave you two different ethical obligations. Yes. >> Yeah.
Yeah. And you would agree that violation of one ethical obligation
does not entail in any way violation of both.
>> No, not necessarily. Nobody. So, one one could violate
one and not the other, right? One could not moderate responsibly
and do the malicious call. One could do the malicious call and
not responsibly like these are not they don't entail each other,
right? They're they're separate. So when I say there is >> independent
variation >> risk yet. >> So the funny thing is is
like Hutch wasn't sure where to go there. He kind of just gave
away that he didn't understand the word right like cuz I didn't
I didn't have I didn't pause and read it. I just went and did
it first. That's actually a wild time to go and check what that
word meant because then Hutch pushing back on that means he doesn't
know what Pisco means when he says self-standing obligation,
right? Which to me he said it quite a few times. I think if I
was having like a rigorous debate with somebody, I'd probably
go, "Whoa, I don't even know what that means." I I don't think
I'd risk inferring it from context and then just being wrong.
But it's kind of funny that that was my thesis and then we checked
what Pisco meant when I didn't understand something he was saying
and then we have Hutch in real time show us that he didn't actually
understand the
It's kind of neat. >> They're not culpable for the violation
of the ethical obligation. What I'm telling you is they're perhaps
culpable for something else. you know, failure to responsibly
moderate. But human beings and you and I see the culpability
of that conduct as a lot less significant than the one person
who intentionally, maliciously, maliciously violates this obligation
on the CPS front. Okay.
>> So the so the person who made the decision to make that
call, that is the much bigger violation in my opinion. like that
person committed
something that is more immoral. >> My contention >> than
being than being negligent, but that's not the same thing. >> Now,
here's the fun part, okay? How morally culpable is Tyler Robinson
for shooting Charlie Kirk, right, for the person who did the
action, who planned it out, who did the action, who took the
time, how morally culpable, right, in terms of of a percentage,
right? Because Hutch is like, "Oh, I think 5.25% for denims."
It's like, okay,
so like the murder of Charlie Kirk, how culpable was he? And
then when you look at the person who called CPS, I have a feeling
Hutch would want to say similar percentages for Caseyron and
Frogan and Hassan and Bad Empanada, right? And so how low will
he go on how culpable the direct actor
Right? How culpable, how low will he go? Will he be like, "Oh,
well, the person who did it is only like 50% culpable."
that this is why you engage in this intellectual exercise though
so that you understand the things you're saying and you like
they drive in the world they they actually do things right uh
I know two legs I know it can be a little bit but I think it's
cool so it's also like other really cool things you can do with
it so
I like it we could have like the I think eventually with the
um with the avatar it would be like quite cool maybe not maybe
we could move the mouth back to the way it was before but if
we had like effects on like the orb or like little effects going
on in the avatar that aren't related to just the mouth moving.
That would be cool. And they're just like consistent between
the frames on all of the different gifts. I think that would
be pretty neat to be honest with you. >> Okay, we can That's
not the same thing as saying that that denims is has 0% culpability
because if you acknowledge that creators wield influence and
if by not setting an example they increase the risk of someone
in their audience doing something then they of course
>> necessarily
have contributed to that. They don't necessarily do that just
merely so if I increase so I'll I'll give you an I'll give you
an example. All right. So, this should be very
Someone says to their, this is an unfortunate example sometimes
that these we have to do these. Someone says
uh to their daughter, their child,
hey, you know, go out into the bad part of town. I think you'll
be okay if you go to the bad part.
Negligent parental advice there.
>> This is a very good >> I'm I'm going I'm I'm going
to >> analogy, by the way.
Someone That's where my mind was going too by the way. Sorry.
Someone does something.
>> Oh, this is going to be basically
so if I went around the question here is going to be after this.
Hutch. If I went around to a bunch of streamers who had 3,000
4,000 views and I was able to type uh somebody should call CPS
on Ethan Klein in like 10% of them without any push back from
that creator, without anything else going on.
How many times
would CPS get called Ethan Klein?
How how directly causal do we think those unmodderated chat messages
are? Really? Okay. Really? How bad? I guess there's with Denim's
the video, too. Might be hard to reproduce, but it's like, okay,
how foreseeable is it based on Denim's actions that the CPS call
happens? 5% is crazy. They talk about culpability morally or
legally. Morally. Entirely morally. Yeah, a V velvet monster.
You're going to have a hard time catching up if you haven't been
here the whole time, but I do appreciate someone here from the
Hutch side. Would really love if you came on stream and discussed
it, but
it's all right. I'm going to hit play here. I have to go grab
my phone. Give me a second. >> Horrible to this person,
a murder. And someone says,
"Mr. Father, sir, you are culpable." You agree?
>> Partly, yeah. >> Having a bad
saying. If a father told his daughter, I want you to go to the
bad part of town where people get killed and then the kid and
then the daughter gets killed and you don't think the father
would have any culpability >> ethical culpability for the
murderer. All right. Not because they contributed to a risk or
the murderer. You understand what I'm saying? >> As in
does the father need to go to prison for murder? Does the father
have some level of culpability that they need to share in the
murder sentence? I would assume kind of where you go there, right?
It's like, no, because he didn't do the thing. He didn't have
the intent or action there,
right? Why aren't we talking about morals? Well, >> I understand
that the father in this situation didn't literally murdered the
daughter, but people would rightfully ostracize that father.
>> They would say yes. Yes. What they would say is you're
culpable for imperiling perhaps your your daughter with bad advice.
They wouldn't say that you share culpability
in the murder.
not legal culpability, >> ethical culpability in the murder.
Okay.
>> Exposing yourself. >> So if you if you think murder
is bad and you want your daughter to live and you are you are
just like a punch and you tell her to go to that part of the
city, like make it make it a less obvious example for him. Okay,
there's a rave in the really bad part of the city and you tell
your daughter to go there, right? You tell your daughter, "No,
you can go, but like be careful." And then your daughter gets
murdered, right? and you didn't want it. Okay. So, the intent
there is you don't want her you want her to be safe, but you
also want her to express like um like independence and
and like making her own decisions. Okay. So, she goes and then
she gets killed. Are you liable? Are you culpable for
ethically? Like I think that's you can't just make it black and
white, right?
Pisco is just assuming his moral intuitions are generalizable.
Well,
he's saying that this is the way the law, the funny thing is
they're saying legally or morally. And I think Pisco's
moral leanings tend to go with the law like really significantly,
especially in terms of like like I'm sure he thinks the United
States legal system has the exact perfect way of understanding
culpability in crimes and bad actions, right? Like I'm pretty
sure there'd be very little for him to change there. I think
I think
so. I'm guessing this does line up with like legally. this is
how he analyzes it legally. And he's probably heard a lot of
good counter examples for why you don't do things differently,
why this should be your opinion.
And yes, he's he's not uh he's not doing a great job of explaining
basically should what retribution should be taken against the
father
who allowed their par their kid to go to a bad part of town and
got killed. What should the penalty be for them? That's what
the an that's what the question is. Okay? as in you let them
go to the bad part of town and there was like a risk like a 1%
chance but what is his what is his what should you do to him?
No, no, no. Morally, what should you do to him?
As in what if you did something to him and somebody went, "Oh,
yeah, I get it. You punched this guy in the face, you cut this
guy's hand off, how much punishment does he deserve for the for
the percentage of the murder that he was involved in?" The answer
has to be nothing. that his bad action is his bad
right? His bad action is his bad judgment. Punish him because
he made a very bad judgment that led to his daughter being hurt,
right? That led to down to negative consequences for his daughter.
Trying to grasp what this combo is about. Not sure if it's quantifiable.
The combo is about um Ethan Klein holding Denims responsible
for the CPS call to his house. Even though probably there's no
way for Denims to really foresee the CPS call happening, that
she probably didn't do something that rises to the level that
she should be held responsible for the CPS call. >> Okay.
I >> Hold on. But but the murder in this situation, right,
would not have happened if the father didn't give that horrible
advice, right? >> I understand that there are but for cause.
No, you have, just to be clear here, I understand in the example
I just provided that the father is a but for cause. You haven't
even shown in any respect that she >> he has no intent
to harm his daughter, right? Like what if what if you can mind
read him Hutch and you know he wants the best for his daughter,
but he thought the way he okayed it, the way she asked and the
way he okayed it, she'd like come to him and said, "I'm going
to like I'm going to take precautions. I'm going to like do all
these things to stay safe. I'm going with my friends. I'm going
right." You have to add things to this hypothetical for it to
translate into Hutch's brain cuz he only sees things in emotion.
>> He is a butt for cause for the CPS call. You haven't
even start. I just want to be clear. You have I just want I I
just want to make I just want to make clear to the audience that
you >> Well, hold on. To be clear, evil Johnny Bravo, Pisco
is going to believe innocent until proven guilty and he's not
going to take the basically the idea that Ethan that Denims wanted
the CPS call to happen with no direct call and her never saying
like anything that suggested it, right? He's not gonna he's basically
going to say you have to prove that. Like you can't you can't
find the father guilty
without being able to prove the intent if he had no intent for
his daughter to be hurt. Right. But I I agree you could maybe
say here it sounds like he could have done this intentionally.
>> You haven't even started to make the >> I'm not
making No wait. I just want to make sure that audience understands.
All right. So I'm just going to make sure the audience understands.
All right. This is not for you audience.
No one has even started make the claim that Denims, Caseyron
or Froggen are but four causes for the CPS call not eat started.
So an example yes for sure the father is a but for cause for
the death of what how is he upset about that eat started. So,
an example. [clears throat] Yes, for sure. The father is a butt
for cause for the death of his.
>> Wait, Hutch, hold on, Hutch. To be upset about this,
you would have to insist that but for denim stream CPS doesn't
get called. Are you out of your mind? You just said 5% chance
she she has 5% culpability, which was already insane if you actually
think about it with any intellectual rigor whatsoever. Right.
That was already insane.
Pisco loves this for the audience bit. It's a less insulting
way but still very insulting way of saying you're too hear what
I'm saying hutch. So I'm going to speak to the audience because
you're too
right? Like you're too dumb to understand. So I'll just explain
to the audience cuz you literally are incapable >> daughter.
We don't say in the typical course of analysis that the father
is partly culpable for the murder of her of his daughter. What
we say is he's responsible in negligence and parenting. He is
uh you know culpable for creating an environment where that type
of thing could occur, but he's not culpable. >> By the
way, I'm sure Pisco has done this whole soy rant for Destiny
before cuz I remember Destiny doing the what do you call it?
He did the same rant in reverse about his like how foreseeable
is it that if I share this video, it gets leaked online. And
he did that before you realized when he had still been telling
everybody he knew that person for months and was like really
close to them. But then when you find out that he knew them for
like a week and they were a random worker he started texting
off of Twitter, it's less less appreciable. But I'm just saying
that it would be funny to see him react to this and and try to
soy out about Pisco. I'm just saying that because I expect him
to react to this and and look at the Pisco stuff. So we'll see
if it happens. >> Four is the malicious and unlawful of
his daughter. Agreed. Yes or no?
>> Uh ethically I do think he's culpable in this spot.
I totally disagree. I mean there's there's a >> well there's
a different scenario that we could we could we could use right
like um >> again I think Pisco could have perfectly disconnected
this by doing my hypothetical that I said like I think it's really
important she learns independence and independent decision-m
and she's given me a whole bunch of reasons why she should be
able to allowed to go to this event in the bad part of town even
though I know it's the bad part of town and so I'm going to let
her do that right and then she gets and then it's like is it
his fault right
now with those two situ situations.
How much of everything I just said
is knowable?
How much of that is provable? How much of that is on its face
just understandable or provable? Probably very little, right?
Like how secure he was in knowing and and like his decision-making,
it's just he's saying, right? It's just saying. So like realistically,
there's not a knowable difference between those two
>> Something more direct like what about um firearm storage,
>> right? Like let's say your parent has a firearm and
they don't properly store it >> and then a kid finds a
firearm and starts using it like a toy accidentally kill himself.
>> Is the parent culpable? >> I think that culpable
for um negligence and for creating >> I see. So this is
where the gross negligence bridge comes in where I think probably
depending on what happened like if you if you your kid like studied
lockpicking videos for months to go and kill themselves with
your gun that's not the problem, right? The issue is like if
you got drunk while you were playing with your gun, you left
it out and didn't even put it back in the safe, right? It it
comes down to that. Like how gross was the negligence? But I
do think the gross negligence part of this comes in here where
Pisco's Pisco is saying something and I understand what he's
saying with the floor in terms of like uh was it approximate
causality or whatever? Approximate um contributo.
Oh, it was like contributo
contributo something. Whatever he was saying, but a an unjustifiable
and substantial risk. >> Huh. And you don't think that
a father telling his daughter to go to a part of town where people
are would would be a similar kind of logic? >> The same
logic applies in in the course of the the parenting advice. What
he's not culpable for is the murder. Do you understand the distinction
there? The murder. So, >> oh, Pisco also does just totally
proximal culpability. Maybe that was it. I can't remember. But
in um in Pisco's defense, he says like, "No, no, no. You might
have like ne like there would be negligent homicide or something,
right? Like for somebody who's young enough, you might be able
to get negligent homicide." Like he's just saying that you don't
say he's responsible for the murder happening because like he
didn't form any of the intent. The element of murder is like
usually with some intent or like gross negligence like attempting
to get your daughter killed. if you he needs to introduce the
element of like if you don't know the intent, if you can't guess
at the intent. I don't know. There's like a lot of things going
on here. And Pisco's
unfortunately Pisco, this is one of those things where he has
an intuition how he feels about this is not um is not like easily
transferable. And so he's saying this and
now unfortunately I think he's a little off base here. Before
he was like totally on base. He was totally nailing it the whole
time. And now I can see how a lot of people would pull away here,
right? And so Hutch has been doing the performative the whole
time, but now other people in the audience might have a hard
time like agreeing with this or understanding it. And so the
performative is going to start working overtime against him.
>> I don't understand [laughter] how these.
So do you understand how societ >> I just personally if
I wanted somebody who's going to analyze the news, analyze politics,
analyze what he thinks hap is happening in the world. I wouldn't
want the guy whose main debate tactic with somebody who's more
intelligent than him is to go, I'm a please don't hurt me. I'm
a please don't hurt me. I'm a please don't hurt me. Right?
Like like that's embarrassing.
That's like a boxer who steps into the ring, gets hit once, and
immediately like like shells up, and refuses to ever throw a
punch again in the fight, hoping the ref will disqualify Pisco.
Why would you Why would you ever want to watch that boxer? That
that sucks. That's like the worst that's the worst attempt at
boxing I've ever seen in my entire life. ID views death in the
abstract, accidents in the abstract, the causing of death of
someone else as uh generally bad. But they view murder as something
horrific.
>> You understand that distinction between someone dying
for example of natural causes and murder. Okay. So >> So
there are instances in which people can be have culpability or
the death of somebody. No doubt have have culpability and and
usually when we apply culpability and this is another case that
this totally fails on only when you're uh failing to adhere to
a substantial and unjustifiable risk. Okay, sometimes there are
justifiable risk. Sometimes it's not a sub, you know, substantial
risk. Let's say for example, you know, you tell your kid to go
out into the good part of town, but for you telling her to go
to the good part of town where she would be safe, uh it happened
to be that the killer was there in the good part of town. You're
a butt for cause there, but you haven't uh
Okay, got it. >> I understand what you're saying. >> So,
just because you share potentially some culpability in the death
of somebody um >> in in the case in which you've done something
unjustifiable and you're substantially increasing risk, right?
Not just moderate increased risk, substantially increasing risk,
right? You tell your daughter to go drive a car down to the [__]
supermarket. Now, you're increasing risk, but it's not substantial
and it's not unjustifiable. So, but in the case in which you
are doing those things, I'm I'm going to finish. Let me finish.
I know I'm worried. You're culpable for increasing the risk.
You're not culpable for murder. That's that's the difference.
>> You're culpable, I think, partly culpable for your daughter
dying. You're not maybe
>> we're quibbling about the words here, right? But like
>> Yeah. So like when you do snarking on Hassan, you'd
be like partly culpable for anything that happens to Hassan.
>> Yes. But like like partly in in that like if something
bad happened to his son, you might have part part culpability,
right? In terms of well, you were kind of pushing a whole cycle
where was Yeah. Yeah. I I kind of identified this where Pisco
was the way Pisco was talking about it. It was like the the concept
was just throwing him, right? Although it's a little different
than just quibbling about words specifically because it's like
Pisco is saying you actually drop out of the concept of culpability
here that like he he just has like there's there's moral indictment
that comes from increasing the risk from doing something that's
so negligent that you probably should have expected your daughter
to die, right? But you morally indict I think Hutch is if Hutch
understood I think what he would say is well I actually think
the increase in risk here is that she's guilty of is worth financial
ruination. So her updating the risk that CPS gets called by on
Ethan Klein by 1% is worth financial ruination for her. That's
what Hutch believes, right? In terms of Pisco's worldview, like
in terms of how Pisco sees this, but he can't translate it. And
I don't I think this example actually obiscated slightly. >> Here's
the distinction, Hutch. What Ethan wants >> Hold on. I
almost had something there. Hold on. You you you figured out
where I was going there, right? So like >> So So
>> I was like totally cooking there, bro. what you're saying
is like literally not culpable for um like the act of calling
CPS, but
this analog >> the really really bad thing >> she
could be culpable for the fact that CPS was called. >> Okay,
so she could be culpable for the uh for the increasing the risk
on that and the fact that it was called. Here's the problem.
You haven't even begun you haven't even begun to make the empirical
case for that. And that's not so the reason that people are mad
are is the malicious aspect of it. The the incriminating conduct,
the call to CPS, not the the fact that you've, you know, increased
the risk minimally or you there's a potential risk, right? >> Hold
on. Wait, wait, hold on. I I really am trying to explain it in
the best. >> But you're filibustering, bro. Every time
I'm trying. >> Yeah, you are. Like, so are you telling
me right now that there is a 0% chance? You're saying she's 0%
culpable? So, you're No, please don't. Please don't. Please don't.
Please don't. >> That someone in Denim's audience called
>> No. No,
dude. Hold on. Hold on. Did I Did I keep this picture or did
I throw it away? Hold on. >> Oh, thank God. I kept it.
>> No, I'm not saying >> Did you Did you understand?
So, when you say could you're going to say logical,
>> dude. I swear this is like the only thing I get that
this is [laughter]
dude Hutch. What are you doing man?
Oh my god. >> Introducing the >> wrong video. Sorry.
Wrong time stamp. >> Do you understand suggesting that?
>> No. You stop. So she could be partly culpable for CPS
having been called. >> No, not in my opinion. No. By unless
by by what you mean by could. >> You just said it was not
0% though. culpability does not totally turn on >> I'm
going to I'm putting that in whether or not someone happens to
emerge from particular causal pathway in which they come from
the community culpability uh relates to someone's actions at
the time that they're taken and whether so right at the time
that she takes these actions that's the time at which we analyze
whether she did a bad thing correct yes or no >> of course
okay at the time at the time she takes the action that's the
point at which you have analyze the culpability of her conduct
at the time she says that is there a significant chance in your
mind right or have you >> significant no don't add that
word I didn't say that >> so so when when all you say is
is there a chance that's trivially true there's a chance someone
interprets your words like the people are crazy what do you mean
like if all you mean by chance is logical chance that and that's
crazy >> it's not it's not trivial because we can't know
and so in the absence of certainty now if no Literally, it's
trivial because in the case where you're absolutely certain that
they did call CPS, it is still trivial because it's about the
foreseeability that somebody would call CPS based on her actions,
which is basically being negligent, moderating her chat, and
maybe doing a well, bad empa goes off. >> Ethan knew for
sure, >> if Ethan knew for sure whose audience that person
came from, and it did come from one of their audience. Okay,
this like surely you would agree like the fact that the the the
the that CBS was called like within a week of that stream like
like and and then and she wasn't the only one watching that.
Um like so it came from that space of the internet. Would anybody
even deny that? >> Is there a chance that it came from
is it a chance? Is there a chance it came from your community?
Hutch.
>> So you're just cultural denim. >> It's do you
think that the chances are anywhere close to uh the idea that
it came from one of their audiences? >> I don't I mean,
do you have an intuition for that? I My intuition is >> I
have an intuition. >> My intuition came from my my intuition
is that like um it's probably more likely on the margin that
um it came it comes from one of these particular communities.
The point is the mere chance that it comes from a particular
community isn't enough for you to say that that there's culpability.
So you acknowledging you hang on a second. you acknowledging
that there's a distinction between the risk >> that like
how culpable she should be for the action should be about like
as a rule how risky was that action so like essentially whether
if CPS wasn't called
how much trouble would you expect ens
foreseeable that problem is that's how you should be punished.
The fact this is the act versus rule utilitarianism thing where
it's like you can't just [__] you can't just rap
a woman because she might have a fetish. If you a woman with
a fetish without actually having any conversation beforehand,
she happened to like it. That doesn't mean you did a good act.
You did an act that is in 99.9% of cases more like 90 though.
Am I right guys? Uh going to be a significant problem for the
other person. It's going to harm them significantly. Okay. factor
with respect to you versus denims is you acknowledging that significance
of risk matters and that's why you can't ignore significance
of risk. When you say I don't want to talk about significant
of risk, well then you're just not playing the same game because
by your lights if significance of the risk doesn't matter. You
and I are both culpable because it's possible. I guess it's something
we said triggered some crazy person. So you need to talk about
significant risk if you even want to get close to culpability.
here. I just want to I'm I just want to get like cuz cuz I feel
like it's been 2 hours now about like we're trying to get what
we're what we're ultimately trying to get at was, you know, was
Ethan justified in being furious with these creators. No, no,
no, no, no, no. That's not what Ethan did. Ethan wasn't just
furious. Look at the sweeping. The just the the obvious little
slide over. We haven't seen a slide in a while cuz it's mostly
been Pisco laying out his world view. But notice that nifty little
slide. Nobody's mad that Ethan's mad. If Ethan got CPS called
on him and he was furious with anybody who laughed about it.
That's totally understandable.
I get it, dude. I understand conservatives who are that Charlie
Kirk got mocked for dying.
That people talked about like the fountain that was pouring out
of his neck that people did like little soule tins around that
fountain, right, as photoshops. Gross, man. That sucks.
Everybody understands that. Literally, nobody's mad at him for
being mad. They're mad at how he handled his emotion at what
he did because he was mad obviously collectively. Like that's
the point that I'm trying to get at. >> No. No. >> That's
that's like what this conversation is all about. I'm trying to
because Hold on. Don't go. Hold on. Hold on. Because Because
we're trying to unpack like whether or not Ethan's actions were
justified or they fit what happened is like basically what we're
trying to get at here. And in a >> Hutch isn't very smart.
One can argue that him even covering the CPS story increases
the chance of CPS being called a second time. I mean, you could
argue that um he's going to argue that intent means a lot. And
that's what it's going to come down to is ultimately
all these people think Denubs wanted CPS called and that she
was pushing it as far as she could until
she would get called out. Basically, like she wanted plausible
deniability, but she was going to tow up to the line as much
as possible to maximize the chance that CPS got called. That's
how they see it,
And Hutch doesn't have that intent. So, he's going to forgive
himself all of his wrongdoing like this where you can't know
and you'll never know. There's no way unless the person came
forward. >> I bet if we had all the clips, it' look even
more like that. Clips of what? Even >> And and admitted
it and said whose community they came from. You just can't know.
And so if you're in Ethan's shoes and you see a pool of I'll
make it up like a dozen creators and they're all making light
of the situation, tacitly encouraging it, justifying it, making
jokes about it.
Again,
I think what would be good for Hutch is to like
write
a little more of Denims during that stream. I'm sure this does
the stream not exist somewhere. Could we not just go watch the
full stream? Um, but again, if you're just kind of assuming that,
that doesn't make any sense.
>> So, what Hutch would have to do here is he'd have to
lay it all out, right?
He he would have to lay it all out. You have to lay out what
everybody did. Everybody you want to hold responsible for this
thing, you have to say what they did and then hold them responsible
for that. That's like the best way to say it, right?
Hold them responsible for the thing they did.
Now, there is probably some amplification based on that system
of people, right? But realistically, you do not believe in punishing
based on that system. Basically, nobody believes in that. That's
like a perfect way to invite bias. If you really dislike the
people in that system, in that collection of people, that's the
perfect way to justify harming a bunch of people who have done
nothing really that wrong on some totally trumped up pretext.
You know, could you imagine shutting off water for like a region
of like 5 million people, 10 million people, 10 million people?
Just kidding. That would never happen. can't know which one specifically
that it it came from. The point is it could have been like any
of them plausibly it could have been any not a fan of increase
in doxing of doxing CPS calls online recently. Jesus, nobody
is also I don't think CPS calls broadly is like a thing or a
thing. There a lot of CPS calls going on or
audiences and so in that moment I understand being angry with
like everybody at the at the very like the very least I mean
surely even less you are just totally wrong. You are wrong even
less. There is a totally
like calculated campaign to make it seem like Denims was way
more responsible than she was. Like you're just wrong. No, you're
actually wrong. That there's totally bad faith people who wanted
to make it seem like she was way more culpable than she was and
edited this clip and blasted it all over the internet explicitly
to make it look like she was way more culpable than she was.
Yeah, that's where you're wrong. Oh man, there's no way that
people think Denims is this responsible based on the clip I saw.
No, that really that really is it. That' be how it is, man. Um
Ethan deserved way more. I I tend not to blame the victim too
badly on that, right? Cuz especially cuz he came out and corrected
it shortly after
like he realized he spoke poorly spoke poorly and he does a lot
of content. It's going to happen
>> Attack it with a Oh, whoops. Wrong video. Wrong video.
Back to this. >> You mean understand his human emotion?
I mean, I would understand. >> No, no, no, no, no. Beyond
beyond an emotion, I can understand in that moment wanting accountability,
wanting to
>> dude. Literally, he still hasn't said anything anybody
disagrees with. Like, like Pisco is trying to somehow explain
to this guy that you're like a total and complete [__]
Nobody disagrees. No. Well, sorry. Nobody saying disagrees. Hey,
you had CPS called on you. You want accountability for people.
You're angry. They're looking for a target to swing back on.
Yeah, we all get it. We all get the parent who's mad that their
kid got killed. Nobody is like, nobody's angry at that parent
for being angry. It's the responsibility of the people around
them to make sure that they don't do something stupid that far
outweighs um like what they're allowed to do or what they are
morally required to do, right? Like I totally understand a father
who has their daughter predated on by some and blows that brains
out. Sorry, I think that's a case in Texas, right? The guy from
the phone booths. Like I totally understand that. It doesn't
mean I support vigilante justice, right? Because there's always
a chance in some of these cases. Well, probably not in that case
from what I heard, but there's always like a chance things get
[__] up and you it's like just not something you
could support as a thing.
That's Hutch is basically supporting vigilantism here. It's kind
of crazy, right? Like the same pretext could be used to support
all kinds of vigilantism unless you want to say, "Oh, I only
support this for legal acts." But then hold on. I only support
this for legal acts. Where would that go?
Um,
like what if it was really petty? Like actually really petty.
Like let's say somebody accidentally spilled a little bit of
their like lawn clippings onto your lawn and so you went and
found where basically somebody was online. Oh, this is a good
one. You went and found someone online who they violated the
copyright of and
essentially the person who you picked off went and let the copyright
holder know you violated this copyright and actually here's a
way you could sue them for the maximum amount of money. Would
that be totally justified?
Oh, [__] around and find out. I guess is it only
that it's them directly violating Ethan's copyright? I actually
don't know. >> Isn't to impose consequences for that violation
done to me? >> The question Hutch isn't whether you understand
the feeling or wanting it. The question is, is it right do is
it right to file lawsuits in this context or to do whatever act
that we're going to if we haven't even breached yet and talked
about if you're not sure whether a particular person is culpable
for the action or is is either for example intentional about
what they're doing or significantly increasing risk. Right? Would
you ever say that it would be justified to do something like
otherwise bad or malicious towards an individual who doesn't
a have evidence that they intentionally incre like increase risk
or try to do it or b uh no evidence that the risk that they imposed
was significant? No, you wouldn't. You have to examine the quantum
of risk here. Is it possible to to ignore it? >> I think
I think we evaluate
responsibility
just way differently.
I think this is an irreconcilable difference. I don't agree.
So just to be clear, is it your position today that uh denims
significantly increased the risk that someone called TPS?
>> Uh in virtue of what?
>> In virtue of the what do you why are you asking me this
question? >> In virtue of what do you think that >> significantly
factors? I'll say I'll say them again though. Do you want me
to say them again? I already said this. It's the three factors.
>> What's the What's the empirical case? Number one. Number
one, she platformed the bad empanada video and uh co-signed his
claims.
>> Okay. So, basically
what Hutch is going to have to get to here is he's going to have
to say if somebody did these things all like
not to Ethan Klein, that they would still deserve the punishment
they're getting, right?
So, if we can find somebody who has platformed a bad empanada
video, >> co-signed onto them and and and and expressed
very in my opinion explicitly that she agreed with the claims.
>> She then said that Ethan's kids
>> he he just sneaks things through that are his emotional
opinion, right? Like like basically Pisco's never agreed to this
and Hutch sort of like basically goes, "Why are you questioning
this? Why are you It's obvious. It's obvious. It's obvious."
His only argument for this was I feel emotional about this, so
it's obvious she's like agreeing and co-signing this. You just
I forget the guy's name now.
Ralph's best buddy. That's his thing.
>> Why'd you just copy paste that into my chat, you weirdo.
>> Die. And she saw people in her chat, >> your Hilton
posting in my chat, you weirdo. Making a call to action to like
somebody needs to call CPS and she refused to moderate. >> Wait,
do you have any do you have any evidence that she saw those?
Do you have any evidence that she saw those messages? Do you
have evidence that she saw those messages? >> You can't
know. You can't know that she was refusing to moderate responsibly,
>> She constantly stares at chat. It's like a meme with
her. It's constantly. >> You just said on your on your
own lights, you're not aware that she saw the message. >> Do
you think it's plausible? Do you think it's plausible that she
wasn't looking at chat at all? Had no idea what was going on.
>> If by plausible, you think that it's reasonably likely?
Yes. I mean, I don't look at chat. I haven't been looking at
>> Likely? No. Come on.
based on in virtue of what you know that she like steadfastly
intentionally refused to moderate. Are you telling me that you
see every one of your chat >> Have you watched a lot of
her content? >> No, I haven't. Watch it. Most of it >> Hang
on a second. This kind of blows my mind. I've watched a lot of
Denim's content. You're saying you haven't watched a lot of her
like at all? Like at all? >> No, I haven't watched a lot
of Denim's
>> Why are you speaking so confidently on this then? Like
I don't understand. Why? Why are you giving your opinion? >> Oh
no. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no.
Okay, this is the one. Hold on. This is the one where I saw We'll
just We'll watch through this really quickly.
This throws me back to um this throws me back to the Hutch sorry
the the Pisco Destiny debate on socialism or whatever where it
was really unhinged for Hutch to demand examples like immediately,
right? When
really did I say Pisco? Yeah, when Pisco is demanding examples,
right? Hey, it's so unhinchy to ask for examples or demand that
like I know what I'm talking about. Is there's no way people
called Pisco for this one, right? Hutch asking for like examples.
By the way, Pisco is just perfectly willing to talk through all
of the examples Hutch had, right? So, here's the real question.
Hutch basically gave his best example after lying about what
it was. He gave his best example. Okay? And Pisco picked apart
that best example. And Hutch is basically going,
"Oh, you just haven't seen as much as I've seen." Visco has seen
as much as you've been willing to present to to make your case,
and you've made it horribly. Your best piece of evidence was
totally trumped up, and you lied about it. So why don't you just
keep presenting the evidence you have, Hutch? Instead, he goes,
"Well, you just haven't seen what I've seen." A very weird, very
weird tact to take, man. Very, very weird tact. >> A lot
of hurt like at all. Like at all? >> No, I haven't watched
a lot of Denim's
Why are you speaking so confidently on this then? Like I don't
understand why why are you giving your opinion about like well
it doesn't seem likely to me if you don't know anything about
her >> So there usually is a requirement right if you're
going to make a case that she intentionally it's your claim isn't
it that she intentionally >> so if if Pisco had come in
here and gone Hutch you're totally wrong. You're totally wrong.
You're totally wrong. You're complete [__] for thinking
this. I would understand Hutch's criticism here, right? But what
Pisco did was he came in with intellectual humility. He said,
"Why don't you show me your evidence? We'll go through it and
I'll comment on it." Right? And then they did it. And Hutch didn't
like the outcome.
But Pisco didn't come in and say, "Hutch, you're stupid for believing
this." And then say, "But I haven't seen the evidence. I just
believe other people." Pisco went, "I I haven't seen this, so
could you show it to me?" And then when Hutch went to show him,
he went, "Oh, I don't really think that's enough to say this."
Okay. So, Pisco wasn't being as to you. He looked at the evidence
you presented and disagreed.
>> Refuse to moderate those calls to CPS. Isn't it your
burden to show that?
>> Is it your burden?
>> I'm I'm just a little burden trying to process what
is your claim and your burden experiencing with you right now.
>> I mean I mean you can you can make all these appeals.
Don't you think Don't you think it would help you in these conversations
to spend some time like familiarizing yourself with these people,
their character, their burden? >> You don't think that's
how the analysis? >> If you make a claim, if you make a
claim, is it your >> dude? Isn't it really relevant to
get your biases like in order? Don't shouldn't you? Like I think
a mandatory 800 hours of Nicholas Yorio content for Pisco. Okay.
He has to watch the past six months of Nicholas Yorio streams
back to back. Actually, concurrently. We can get it done in like
four hours concurrently on one monitor, okay? Just tons and of
little screens. He needs to watch all of the Nicholas Yoro content,
consume all of it, and then he will understand what he's supposed
to think. Okay, Pisco, get your
brain in order. Okay. What What are you doing, man? >> Stares
at chat and interacts with chat. >> Do you constantly stare
at chat? Do you constantly stare at chat and respond to >> Yes.
Do you read everything that the chat says?
>> Not all the time. No. >> Okay. So, in virtue of
the fact that someone tends to look at their chat a lot
of the fact if I'm having a conversation with you, but if it's
just me and chat and I'm watching a video, I'm constantly watching
chat. >> Okay. So, but the mere fact that someone tends
to look at chat, don't you have an additional burden to show
that they actually disregarded
uh uh you know this this risk and that they actually saw it?
>> You're waiting. asking question
I hutch I chat that's what you're saying >> hutch I ask
you a question is it your claim or not and do you have the burden
that's the question you haven't answered >> I'm not interested
in this line I'm >> not interested in this line of question
preposterous I find it preposterous
>> dude it's I find it prep Hutch is literally going yeah
>> these people are so cooked like they're actually just
cooked entirely I hope Ethan can see this I hope Ethan sees this
debate specifically
and is like
absolutely mortified about like what's coming for him. Okay,
it's so rough. Pisco goes, "Hey, you made a positive claim. Could
you back that up?" And Hutch is like, "This isn't this is such
a sad conversation. This is such a weird conversation. It would
serve you to watch a little more Denim's content." It's like,
"Okay, wait. If you had better evidence, I would take that better
evidence. Are you serious?
Just give me better evidence, man. What are you doing? >> That's
what you're saying." >> I asked you a question. Is it your
claim or not? And do you have the burden? That's the question.
You haven't answered it. >> I'm not interested in this
line of >> I'm not interested in this line of question.
You don't have the evidence. >> You don't.
>> Here's another like performative ignorance. Oh, it's
so insulting that you would even ask this, >> bro. Are
we debating religion?
Are we debating religion with somebody who is like a leader of
that religion?
Why is this dogma to you? Why are you treating it like dogma?
It can be questioned. Okay. I can I could say, "Hey, I think
Ethan made all of this up. Could you show me some evidence?"
I could say that. I don't happen to think he made it all up,
but I could say it. And then I think if I didn't believe it at
all, if I if you couldn't show me a single clip, if you went,
"Uh, actually, you should educate yourself, pick it." I go, "Well,
I I feel like that's telling."
You know what I'm saying? You don't have to show me everything,
but I would just be like, if you can't show me anything, if you
can't even like send me a video that I could watch, dude, that
might actually be a fun thing to do.
Hold on. Do we want to get 10 subs? Oh, this would be horrifying
though. I was thinking like if we did 10 subs and we just watch
like a Willy Mac or a case a video on like this case CPS. Okay,
can I go watch like a Willy video and just see? Like I understand
10 subs to watch a Willy Mac video. That's not really a good
deal. But it's like at this point
I want to go see what people were talking about. Like the CPS
call stuff specifically. The latest Willy Mack video is insane.
I'm sure it is. >> Find you make a claim that you don't
>> you. I don't think you should have such confident opinions
when you don't know anything about these claims. >> Who
made the claim? Wait. Who made the claim? Did you make the claim
that she disregarded and and intentionally didn't moderate or
did I make that claim? Who among us made the claim? >> Why
wouldn't you familiarize yourself with her out of curiosity?
between us who made the affirmative claim about
>> Um,
you're saying this black man committed this murder, but I don't
really know anything. Uh, excuse me. Do you want to familiarize
yourself with that person's rap sheet? Do you want to familiarize
yourself with the FBI crime statistics? Excuse me. Why are you
telling me what's up when you haven't even read the FBI crime
statistics report for this month? Excuse me. You're not really
informed, are you, Pisco?
>> I don't Hudge. I'm not going to move past it because
you're making a claim and saying that I'm doing something uh
weird by not watching all of Denim's
>> You said it before though. You've said it before.
>> Actually, another perfect question. What did Hutch think
about the Arena Zerusa?
What did he think about the policies that led to that guy being
back on the streets?
Right? Because I would argue
that the judge at the very end who put that guy back on the streets
while not culpable under Pisco's model would absolutely be culpable
under Hutches.
Right. Right.
>> Here's you made this conversation about >> simple
question. As between us >> as between us who made the claim
about >> I don't I'm not going to go down this road with
you. >> I'm not going to not go down this >> You
made this conversation about like >> Oh, also we don't
have to do Willie Mac. I'm just saying like there's got to be
a video on the original CPS drama that we could watch and just
see like what people were being shown at the time and see how
it was presented. Like I want to just hold on. Denim's CPS.
If I put Denim CPS in, she just nuked her own case. This is 5
months ago. Is this Is this CPS? What the is wrong with her?
Asmin Gold Clips
just nuked her own case nine months ago. >> Is this the
uh the Ethan thing? I remember somebody told me about this. I
think it's embarrassing for Ela here to be like this is so traumatic
for the kids. You're trying to traumatize the children. It's
like >> so basically these people collectively got together
and called
this is after the fact. So this is after the fact. Okay. That
one that one was the one I thought was particularly that was
after the fact. Okay. Anyway, oh we we'll keep watching. Maybe
we'll look at one of these things. Okay.
What did most people look at to determine that Denims was responsible
for CPS? How did they figure out that Denims did CPS? How did
most people come to that realm? >> I'm not going to not
go down this >> You made this conversation about like whether
or not his actions were justified or appropriate like an appropriate
response to the stuff that they did. You'll say that in one breath,
but then you'll also say that you don't really know much about
the creators or what they did.
>> it's like why wouldn't you take the time to like look
into that first?
>> So, this this is an inful thing that you're doing. The
mere fact that I haven't watched all of Denim's content. >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, hang on. The mere fact that I haven't. So,
I'm just going to address what you just said.
>> I thought he was arguing. I thought a whole bunch of
people were arguing it wasn't important.
>> Weren't these guys trying to do the whole Weren't there
a bunch of people? Maybe not Hutch. There were a bunch of people
who were like, "Why do you acting like this is important? Why
do you care? You're like a loser. Why do you even care about
this?"
No, you haven't. YOU CAN'T HAVE THIS CONVERSATION. YOU HAVEN'T
WATCHED ALL OF DENIM'S CONTENT. IT'S IMPORTANT. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO WATCH ALL OF Denim's content. Uh, I am going to go back to
my line so you're not you haven't distracted. >> If you
think it's important, Hutch, I think it's minimally minimally
required of you to tell me what I've missed that you think so
important. What have I missed? Back to me from that. The mere
fact that I haven't watched all of Denim's content or all of
Caseyron's content or all of Rogan's content, that is not any
contradiction between me and my opinions thus far. Can you identify
a contradiction or some kind of thing that doesn't make sense
on that view? >> Well, you seem to take it on. Can you
or can you not? Can you or can you not? >> You got you
you got taken off guard. >> You made You just made an additional
claim. You You just made an additional claim. You said it was
weird that I had
all of their content. >> Generally think speaking though,
you don't think it would behoove you to like familiarize yourself
with these creators and what they said said and did during that
time?
He said
I think Ethan was lying about his motives. This has turned into
oh well do you don't think denims did that much? He said prove
the denims thing to me. Right. He literally was just like, "Yeah,
like I don't know. I haven't seen any evidence of that, but if
you want to show me, you didn't have the evidence. You can't
show it." Doesn't mean it's not there. He just nobody could show
it to him, right? To say that Denims was culpable and she deserves
this, which we all suspected from the very beginning.
But his opinion was like different than this. Hutch wanted to
go down the Denim's path. Hutch thought that this was the Pisco
path, okay? That he was turning Pisco down alley. Little did
Hitch Little did Hutch realize that entering the debate like
country, okay, the country of debate, that whole country was
Pisco's like country, okay? Hutch found this one ality. He's
like, I'll get him down here. No, no, no, no. When you enter
when you entered the country, okay, before you took your two
flights to get to the middle of the country where Pisco is, when
you entered the country, you entered Pisco's like domain expansion.
Okay. By agreeing to have the conversation, you already [__]
yourself completely. You had no way. No, there wasn't any trap
card you could pull that turns it around. You seem to have not
like looked into it very much, but you also have these strong
opinions about the scope of
the scope of my claim of like what he did compared with what
he was responding to. >> For for the scope of my claims,
I believe I've done appropriate research for the scope of my
claims. I haven't made broader claims that would require me to
do the kind of research that you're talking about. You made Wait,
did you So, so hunch hut hut. I just answered all your concerns.
I would like you to answer I just hutch hutch hutch hutch. I
just answered your claims and >> not claiming she's taking
it too far. >> I just I just answered your concerns. Did
you make a claim about Denim's intent or not?
>> Isn't your Isn't it your Is it your >> I think
to a to any reasonable person
who is familiar
>> Isn't it like common sense that Denims is a total and
obviously wanted Ethan Klein's kids? Isn't that like common sense
that Denims is just an evil who wants all of Ethan Klein's kids
dead
and crucified? Actually, shockingly,
you're the first to know. Okay, I'm reporting to you now just
for the same time that Denims actually wanted these kids beheaded.
That's why the skulls were sent. She actually wanted these kids
beheaded.
Yeah, I know it. And any reasonable person knows it, too. Obviously.
What? Are you an unreasonable person? You don't know it. You
don't know that. with her any reasonable person would come to
the conclusion that she did see what was going on in her child.
>> Is it so is it your is it your burden to demonstrate
that >> beyond a like beyond a reasonable to a reasonable
certainty to a reasonable >> I'm not >> preponderance
of evidence. Just prove to me that it's like a thing that you
think is the most likely thing that happened. You don't have
to prove it to me beyond a reasonable doubt. Prove it to me that
you think it's the most likely thing that happened. >> I'm
not here to try to convict in front of a jury. I'm just saying
a reasonable person would come to the conclusion that she was
watching a chat and she saw what they were saying. >> So,
but I'm not asking.
I'll give you something to support the claim. I'm not asking
that. No, no, no, no touch. So, first I want to establish it
is your burden. You agree it's your burden to demonstrate your
claim.
>> is it your burden or not? Can you answer >> I'm
tired. I'm I'm tired. >> Dude, come. >> Dude, ACTUALLY
KILL ME.
JESUS. I'M trying to eat and I'm just trying to chill. Dude,
there's no way. There's no way.
Is it your burden? Who cares? I'm really tired right now. Hey,
Hutch, you just made a claim. Isn't your burden to like try to
prove that claim? Who cares? I'm tired right now.
I don't think that that
he's totally disqualified from being a political commentator.
He's totally disqualified from having these conversations as
a job. He's a complete That is the most embarrassing [__]
I've ever seen. At the very minimum, just go do your react content.
Do your react slop. Stop interacting with other creators or pretending
you have any unique or or like
special thought process. There's just nothing there. This is
crazy, dude. >> She saw what they were saying. >> So,
but I'm not asking.
I'll give you something. I'm not asking that. But no, no, no.
Hutch. So, first I want to establish it is your burden. You agree
it's your burden to demonstrate your claim. Correct.
>> Is it your burden or not? >> Who cares?
Who cares?
Who cares, man? Uh, everybody, literally everybody cares. This
is the strongest H3 golem right now. Okay. This is the This is
the strongest one.
Uh, you just said Denims should like be financially ruined because
of her culpability for the CPS call. Isn't your responsibility
to demonstrate like some level of culpability on her part? Who
cares, man? I'm really tired right now. I'm really tired right
now.
Dude, I'm so sleepy. I'm just
man,
why do you make me say the things? Come on, man. Bro, Ethan Klein
is so cooked. It's so over,
dude. It's so over on like every single aesthetic level. The
only response these people have is it's just like every reasonable
person knows we're right.
No, I'd like you to demonstrate it. No, I'd like you to demonstrate
Ethan Klein isn't a totally psychopathic, like insecure, spineless
Yeah, demonstrate it for me. Go ahead. I feel like I've demonstrated
that I think he's a total psycho, right? I've I've demonstrated
why I think he's lied about his rationale for these lawsuits,
why I think these lawsuits are bad, right? Why Denims, Caseyron,
and Froggen are nowhere near as culpable for these lawsuits or
or the the things that they're being blamed for as so as to go
ahead and justify these lawsuits happening. I've explained all
of these
Hutchkins can explain was Denim's doing the the largest streamer
doing the CPS speculating arc at the time. Well, I don't even
think she was doing the CP. She watched a bad empanada video
to [__] with Ethan.
It's like a move,
but like I don't think she ever even came close to advocating
somebody call CPS.
Disagree on that. Don't think it happened. Don't think it was
close. >> At least from what I've seen, I'm I'm >> dude.
Come on. This would go by a lot faster. sizzling cakes. Go ahead
and hop on the stream if you're not a weak spineless like Ethan
Klein.
We can just talk through this. It's really easy to see. This
guy's like, "Wait, you think Hutch is wrong here?" When Hutch
said when Pisco was like, "Hey, you just made a claim. Don't
you think it's incumbent on you to prove that claim?" And Hutch
said, "Uh, who cares, man? I'm really tired. That was compelling
to you. That's amazing."
I personally, if I were on Hutch's side, I would call him out
on Twitter. If I was Nicholas Yoro and I watched this, I would
say, "Bro, never talk about H3 again. You make Ethan E look stupid.
You are a loser. Stick to politics, dude. Stick to making Democrats
lose elections. That's what you're good for." Okay? You make
Democrats lose elections. You take views and revenue on Twitch
and YouTube and you produce Democrat losses in midterms. You
do that, Hutch. Okay? Do your job. Stay in your lane. >> If
you just acknowledge obvious if you make a claim, you got to
justify. Don't >> do these lawyer tricks. You're tricking
me. lawyer trick, bro.
>> Stop doing your lawyer tricks. Stop doing your lawyer
tricks. I'm just a small bean. >> Any reasonable person
thinks that she was looking at a chat and anybody you can say,
well, was 100%. So, you're saying Are you saying that you assume
it? Are you assuming it? >> I think it's a safe assumption.
>> Are So, so you're So, an assumption, in other words,
is something that you don't justify. Fair. >> It could
I could be wrong. Okay. So, so but you made a So, here's the
problem, right? If you make a claim about a
>> dude, this is just this is literally just justifying
bias because like you feel like it's right.
Hutch would absolutely
have strung up black people in the south in the [laughter] He
absolutely would have he would have lynched all kinds of black
people. Um listen, it's just how they are. Okay? Don't we all
know that that's just how they are? Hutch has the black person
lynching physio. Okay? This is what he is 100% capable of. That's
everybody who acts like this. It's that's who these people were,
okay? No internal thought, no internal like um spark, no internal
monologue, just I'm gonna follow along what everyone else says
cuz that's what they've been saying and I think that's the safest
way to get through life.
So cool, dude. >> Intent. And this is, by the way, not
too dissimilar to what you say of me, right? Like don't you say
the same thing to me? You're like, you can't say you know Ethan's
intent. You have to prove that. And now when I come back with
you and say, "Hey, listen. Uh, when you're trying to speak about
Denim's intent, don't you need to show that? You're like, I don't
want to answer that question. I'm You made me tired. I mean,
what the >> Okay. Do you think it's possible that she didn't
see anything in her? >> By possible. Do you mean logically
>> Plausible. Plausible. Do you think it's plausible that
she didn't see any of >> So, so I think plausible. I think
it's plausible that she didn't see enough of it that she thought
it was a problem. I think it's probably implausible that she
didn't see a single CPS message, but in terms of what she was
hearing and in terms of like hyperbolic reactions, she probably
saw something, but was it like enough for her to go, "Whoa, pause
the chat. Let's roll this back and I have to tell you guys never
to do that, right?" >> Was like, you know, is there a decent
chance she didn't see it? I think it's
>> Okay, because guess what? The reason I have that intuition
is because both you and I agree that we don't see the entirety
of our chats. And there are you would agree by the way between
you and I the we don't see the vast majority of chats that that
come on our chat.
>> I I think I see most of the chat. It's only when I'm
having conversations like that like now where I'm like really
invested in what I'm watching. But at this point in my career
back when I was playing video games, [__] no. I barely
looked at the chat. It wasn't that often. These days I constantly
look at both chats. And so does she. By the way, >> I think
that >> that's her whole thing. She's constantly interacting
with chat. That's her pattern. That's what I know about her as
a creator. Wait, hang on, hang on, hang on. I'm trying to support
the claim, okay? Like, I know this about her as a creator is
that she is constantly interacting with her chat. Like, con >> EMTT
till he whistled at all kinds of white ladies.
That's what I know about him. I know his pattern. I own the grocery
store. He would loiter in front of. Okay. He that that heed whistled
all kinds of white women actually. I think he's guilty >> instantly.
Like they're they are a big part of their content. like some
creators like I don't know if Destiny necessarily does it in
the same way like he he interacts with chat but it's like he's
off doing his own thing he's doing he's kind of doing his own
react or whatever like not everybody works that >> I try
to make a concerted effort to look at my chat and I miss like
50 plus percentage of everything that comes up >> you say
it's plausible she missed it
>> but but even even putting that aside even if I granted
it Hutch even if I granted that she bears culpability her failure
to mitigate um you know these kinds of risks failure to moderate
it just doesn't extend to the act itself, that kind of thing.
We we don't have that that normative intuition that um you know,
a failure to adjust for for risk that this is a substantial risk
that based on this content someone's going to call CPS. You couldn't
justify that, man. You couldn't justify that there's a substantial
risk that uh you know, given that statement that someone as a
>> I think I understand where the differentiation is now
or where the where the problem is.
So, you actually need just a second. You actually need an example
where the person is innocent to show, right? What if somebody
really hated
your dad? Okay, we'll go back to the hypothe going across town.
Your dad lets you go to like a raid or sorry, a rave, not a raid,
not World of Warcraft, a rave across town in some like dangerous
area. Okay, you've given him a whole bunch of reasons. He thinks
it's important to let you make your own decisions. He's actually
as a he's acting as a good father. He's like made sure that you're
basically going to be safe. He's pretty confident. Like obviously
it's in the bad part of town, but you know, like you've taken
every precaution.
You go, you get killed. Okay. Now, somebody really there's a
prosecutor in that town that really hates your father. He's going
to send your father to to jail for prison or to to jail for life
or whatever. Prison for life
based on that decision. Do you think it's reasonable to be held
culpable for something that's like trying to take your intent
into account like just going to treat you as if because you had
a small portion of like culpability there? Is it reasonable that
you be held liable for that decision for that like for somebody
else's decision? Like you did a contributing thing,
but is it reasonable for you to be held liable for somebody else
forming the intent to murder your daughter? Right? Because that's
where the fairness element comes in is like how fair is it for
the person who's actually innocent. So, let's say Denims didn't
see any of those chat messages. Let's say hypothetically if she
if you knew for a fact she didn't see any of those chat messages.
Would you still think she's like majority culpable?
Let's say hypothetically you knew for a fact she didn't want
CPS called that she like absolutely does not want and she didn't
even though she hates Ethan Klein, she didn't want CPS called.
Is it okay to find her culpable for this or sorry to find her
like guilty to
her up her life up based as if she or based on the idea that
she was responsible for the CPS
Is that okay? I think that's really the question that answers
it, right? Um this is literally not connected to the situation
at all. Velvet Moss, this is like a weird like out of context
attempt at a dunk that doesn't make any sense. It's weird cuz
someone su someone cuz suing someone is based on personal desires.
That doesn't What are you even saying? Did somebody say otherwise
or is this Is this supposed to fit in the hypothetical somehow?
Oh man, Velvet Moss, do you just want to hop on stream and talk
through this? It'd be really cool if you hopped on stream because
you're saying like really dumb things and you kind of don't want
to be called on it. It would just be cool to have the conversation
in real time, right? Cuz you're you're basically just arguing
that
we're defending bad empatada or we're saying something about
bad empanada. Nobody's even mentioned bad empanada. You brought
that up off the top of your head. You just you're looking for
a way to not have to change your opinion because you're seeing
into the the horrifying eyes of the person who's like your intellectual
thought leader and seeing how embarrassing it is to have the
opinions you have. Right? Like when you say this,
nobody here, nobody involved in this video, nobody involved in
any of these communities is doing this that saying that bad empanada
doesn't know what he's doing. But you decided to say that because
that feels like a statement you can make that nobody's going
to push back on you with that you could just like get it out
there and be like I'm still correct on this. No. Um regardless
bad and could literally be it doesn't mean that Hutch is any
more correct on this. It doesn't mean that you thinking that
Denims deserves this or Caseron deserves this is any less incorrect.
Right. Yeah. I just I think it's like very embarrassing to have
these opinions to be honest. Or I mean you could just admit you're
like a total incel who hates these like vile rotten
and you you would take like literally if they just got murdered
it would also be fine. Like you just want any retribution you
can get on them which I think is just most people's real opinion
to be honest.
Yeah. I think that was related to what you're talking about.
Okay. Yeah. You just threw in the chat. >> Result of that
is the natural and probable consequence of that is that someone
call CPS. It just isn't tailored to it. I can easily justify
putting myself in Ethan's shoes and looking at the whole space
that dog I could just easily justify putting myself in Israel's
shoes and nuking Gaza like right like you've been bombed by them
there's October 7th I totally understand how you could be in
Israel's shoes and nuke Gaza right I understand dude I totally
understand how every was really mad about October 7th and probably
wanted blood for it what am I what am I doing there when I say
that right Like we're arguing that the response was too heavy-handed.
What are you arguing for when you just say, "Well, I sort of
understand why they were enraged and they had like this righteous
anger that they needed to put onto some target." Yeah, I'm arguing
they're targeting poorly.
You're you're justifying that when you when you do it in that
progression. I'm saying these people are picking bad targets.
they don't have the level of culpability, the least the level
of like um responsibility that they'd need to to enact or possibly
enact like life ruination on them like like to put their finances
to ruin their lives like like right cuz they they talk [__]
on the internet. I I don't think so. And your response is, well,
I understand why they're really mad. I understand why Ethan's
really mad. You're just justifying it without actually wanting
to take a moral position because you're a spineless
>> and joked about it and egged it on and justified it.
>> I can easily justify
in that moment feeling like they all share culpability for contributing
to that >> to to their collective audience's culture
of like >> but that's a separate
>> unrivaled levels of like we're beyond hostility at that
point. It's just it's just uh it it was one of the most like
>> they do that >> pylons I've ever seen in my entire
career going back nearly two decades. >> The lefties do
that to you?
>> Not not not like listen I've had I've been on the receiving
end of some vicious and nothing came close to what the clients
went through. I mean do you >> No no but I'm not >> Do
you acknowledge that the act of like Hold on let me let me CPS
is bad. That's why I said you're like, why are you talking about
it? And yes, I did say >> All right, I have a different
question. Yeah, go for it. >> What do you think was what
do you think is worse? Like, what do you think is the most significant
action? >> Oh, he's going to ask something totally,
isn't he?
>> He's going to basically do something that implies that
Pisco doesn't think CPS calls are bad right now. He's going to
be like, "Oh, you get mad about this, but you don't get mad about
this."
>> The lawsuit or the CPS >> calling CPS vindictively
and
>> Okay. But um in terms of the consequences, like the
likely
absolutely life ruination,
right?
Like I'm sorry, the consequences are way worse. The argument
is the consequences are like legal. The other one's an illegal
act that is like immoral on different levels, but the consequences
of like the the totally life ruining. It's like that's it's mitigated
by the fact that they actually engaged in the conduct that could
enable that, right? It's not mitigated totally, but it is mitigated
a little bit in that it may be a difficult decision. But I think
in terms of just the consequences, if you didn't look at any
of the the reasoning for why the why it's happening, the consequences
having your entire financial like state with you basically
you lose your house, you're homeless, you don't have any money,
right? That is a far worse situation than having CPS called on
you as an affluent parent, right? If you look at it that way
now, I don't think you have to look at it only one way. But I'm
telling you that it's not exactly like it's oh CPS by a mile
easily every single day of the week in my opinion. >> That's
not the question. The question isn't uh between these. >> No,
it's not. You need to connect the creators to the culpable actions
and uh even if by the way you you did >> all culpable in
my mind,
>> including yourself, right? Because there's a chance
it came from your
>> No, listen. like for for egging it on, for making light
of it, and for joking about it >> and for that
so so
that community. Yeah. >> So I I I am so pleased that I'll
see this. You apply this standard to liberals. You apply this
standard to all sorts of creators who have, let's just put it
modestly, less than stellar reputations and actions when it comes
to >> the collective guilt standard is very >> Moderation
of their communities. Let's just to put it mildly. I mean like
you argue by the standard people out >> called them out
>> that that they're culpable. >> Wait, why would
that why would that matter? If those people are advocating for
like really bad, why would you why would calling them out be
enough? Shouldn't you like totally totally disengage from them
entirely? Shouldn't you pretend they don't exist anymore? >> So
someone someone crazy does something to piece >> if Denims
had just gone, "Oh no, Badam Pada, he's just really bad, bro."
Would that have been enough? >> Good. because they say
that he's, you know, whatever they say, you're going to be like,
"Oh, all these people who are making false claims and piling
on Pisco, these people have collective responsibility for the
murder of Pisco." You would never say that. >> Surely,
Surely you would agree that that when we're talking about like
>> that that kind of culpability that would be spread out
like amongst hundreds of thousands of creators and people with
with platforms and influence. It's a little bit different in
this situation when we're talking about >> Republicans
argument about Charlie Kirk that after the fact the Democrats
are fostering communities where they're doing things that with
their natural consequence is it causes crazy people to So I just
want you to know this entire thing I've been trying to show you
that the standard you're applying is the conservative standard
on Charlie Kirk and you just said it perfectly. Yes, it's scattered
across that's the Republicans theory for why Democrats deserve
culpability for all these crazy lunatics doing crazy you just
described. I think if you think I'm being inconsistent, you should
just ask my chat. What was I saying about
>> There's no way. Like hypothetically, if you apply your
standard in this way, that's the same standard as conservatives,
right? No, I call people out though. >> No, but like in
terms of determining guilt, not as in you're guilty of it, but
in terms of determining guilt. Your standard for determining
guilt, you egghheaded. You have the same standard as Republicans,
right?
Uh, no. I actually call people out. I actually call people out.
So, it's like totally different. Okay. Like totally different.
>> People that were making jokes about Charlie Kirk. >> You
were not saying they're culpable for murder. You were not saying
that. >> No, no, no. What I was saying was >> You
weren't saying that, right? You weren't saying that, right? >> No,
that's not what I was said. But like again, this is not analogous
at all. But what I was telling my chat, >> hold on. No,
actually show Hutch how he just provided a totally non-falsifiable
argument about being a part of a community that enabled CPS or
allowed the calling of CPS
because without a doubt Democrats have fostered an environment
that facilitates like people joking about Charlie Kirk getting
merckked. Does that mean something Hutch?
Do are dem is it is it significantly more Democrats and Republicans
who laugh at Charlie Kirk's gaping neck hole? Hutch,
Democrats have absolutely facilitated that environment in a lot
of ways. Is that a meaningful statement? >> Like that day,
the day after, like I didn't find any of the jokes funny. Like
I was telling people that this was a time for everybody. >> I
don't agree with the jokes. I condemn the jokes. >> No,
but that's me being consistent though. I'm saying like we all
>> calling them culpable. You're not >> condemning
the jokes doesn't matter, man. You built you literally condemning
the jokes, condemning the murder, condemning any doesn't matter.
You built the system. It's literally the same because it's the
you built the system that allowed this to happen argument that
Republicans are most significantly using against Democrats, right?
Because it doesn't matter if you disavowed, doesn't matter about
anything. You're already guilty. And it's the most common line,
including the line that Ethan Klein himself
used against Denims and Hassan, right? When we saw this uh we
had some Hassan clip here before or some H3 clip with them talking
about Hassan.
Um, yeah, that was the standard they used was like you enabled
Hassan enabled like the community that led to like acceptance
of CPS calls or something. It's like, dude, what what it's so
stupid. Uh, no, this is about celebrating after the fact and
how stupid it is to talk about the culture of Velvet Boss.
>> no, but like you would be culpable in a much more abstract
sense. >> Let's beating to that kind of culture. And the
only reason that I'm picking on Destiny here is simply because
he has the most like I don't know um spicy takes on the Charlie
Curry. >> I called him out. >> No, but you don't.
>> I told I So >> So here's the question. I'm not
saying
>> dude, [clears throat] it's actually just all kinds of
it's wallto-wall.
No, I had like French toast for breakfast. No, I had like French
toast for breakfast. Hey, Hush. I think like based on the standard
you're applying probably people could say Destiny is responsible
for murder. Uh, I call Destiny out though. So why are you doing
this?
Uh, because I'm talking about like the standard you apply to
other people and really whether or not you like actually are
consistent in terms of your actions and calling people out. It's
basically the the consistency with which you would call people
out. Not how often you would actually disavow somebody doing
it. So you can't be called inconsistent yourself, right? So basically
if you were going to say somebody violated the rule, right? How
consistent are you in seeing them violate the rule and calling
them out? >> And you did you call them out or not? Don't
confuse the issues, Hutch. And I'm not going to get confused
by it. So, just be clear. >> Uh, actually, I just I just
followed the rule one time. And so, you can't say you can't ask
about how I would apply another standard cuz I follow my own
rules. I follow my own rules. I follow my own rules. Oh, actually,
hold on. Wait. I guess the answer is just saying like when you
called him out, when you diss about him, did you say he was responsible
for Charlie Clark K's murder or not? Right? Isn't that the question?
Isn't that just the whole question? What did Hutch say when he
called Destiny out? Was it you're responsible for Charlie Kirk
getting killed? >> Cuz that's basically what he's doing
with Denims. Yeah. >> Is Destiny culpable for the murder
of Charlie Kirk because he joked about it afterward in ways that
you find reprehensible. Is he culpable for the
that jokes about it after
some kind of funny
enough.
>> No, but even what I'm not talking about like so there's
culpability for like a shared responsibility for fostering communities
where this sort of behavior is encouraged and celebrated and
joked about. Like that's one thing. And then there's like culpability
for the act itself. And then there's like joking about it after
the fact.
But no, but I'm saying all of these things are relevant considerations
when we evaluate.
Was was Ethan justified in taking
extreme action? >> I totally agree. But here's the problem
>> here's the problem. The culpability for failure to moderate,
the culpability for failure to to making light of stuff, right?
And when you shouldn't do it, it's being conflated with the malicious
act of the call itself. That's the sneaky part. That's the part
that doesn't that
>> whether you are or not people are and they're saying
well and you almost did I actually think you did it here by by
saying well don't you acknowledge by failure to moderate you
acknowledge that there's some culpability therefore >> uh
Hutch just said he's not conflating it he's absolutely conflating
it he's just lying now at the end of the call like he's [clears throat]
completely lying he's absolutely saying denims is culpable denims
is culpable denims is culpable
I just I don't I don't understand he's like absolutely conflating
it has been the whole time. In fact, he said directly Denim's
called for CPS to be called. It's what he said when he first
opened the conversation >> for this for the actual act.
>> No, we cannot conflate these. We We really can't >> I
don't I I'm not conflating it. I feel like you're trying to do
this thing where you're conflating it to try to like uh make
the point that you >> uh actually like now that I don't
think about it and I just like pull something out of my ass.
How about no you? Huh? How about like now that I'm like not thinking,
I've shut my brain off entirely. How about uh no you
>> how about that? >> Well, it's absurd to say that
they're responsible because ultimately it's up to the person
that did it. But that's not what I'm saying. I'm saying like
if you are irresponsible in your lack of moderation in in your
own words, increase the risk
for that. You're responsible for that. But but
if that conduct if that conduct doesn't >> rise to a certain
level of significance, it's negligible. Right? So you need to
make the de so right. It's not enough to say you increase the
risk.
You you accept you will accept this Hutch. It's not enough that
you raise a >> I don't it's not none of it's not trivial.
Not none of this is trivial. I don't think any of them have >> Why
is Hutch trying to answer a question before Pisco asks it? Why
would you just let him ask the question? This guy is so
horny to never answer a question directly
in this situation. >> That that's not my point. You would
agree, wouldn't you, that raising the risk
minorly isn't culpable content, right?
for the active lit literally according to your standard. No,
but you but you have >> No. No. On your view. I'm not asking
on my view. On your view. On your view. If you raise the risk
just a tiny little bit, that's not culpable conduct. Is it? >> Not
necessarily. No, but like >> Well, like No, it is. It Oh
my god. He's like actually letting Pisco talk about of how the
he views the situation. Under Hutch's view, it would be Hutch's
view is just basically there's a there's a infinite unknowable
number of factors that led to the CPS call happening.
Is there some amount that Denim's factored into it or what is
the chance what is the like probabilistic chance that she factored
into it? And then I guess to what contributo level that's that's
basically
there's like some equation he has in his head that is really
difficult to define. I understand what he's like trying to say.
their systems could be translated between each other, but now
he's just lying and saying like, I guess not. I guess you wouldn't
be culpable there with like a really minor thing. It's like,
no, you have to say yes or else just say you're going to use
Pisco >> Here's the thing, though. >> Yes. Yeah,
I can smell it. >> Is something
there? No, they painted they they there was a pipe that burst
and so they had to >> Oh, man. Uh, this just made me realize
wait signal. This should be like who has a bigger history of
lying on the internet? Ethan Klein or Denims? Ethan Klein or
ah Casey Tron? Maybe. I don't know. Ethan Klein or Frogan? It's
Ethan Klein. Ethan Klein has a long and storied history of lying
to people on the internet.
It's like if we're going to do the the what do you call it? The
um we're going to do the the like
I don't know like character evidence. We're going to do that
then. I think Ethan's character is unquestionably
>> Governor smart cookie. I He might not be trustworthy,
but uh I like I like him after that interview with Ezra. Just
I'm just saying, you know, he's >> I've liked him for a
while. Yeah, he is smart. He's very sharp. He's super >> but
I know that that was like that interview was Democrat. Just wanted
to that out there. >> Oh, yeah. I was like insulting anything,
but it really like in order to show >> Don't worry about
me. >> Okay. Okay. I'm not taking it personally. I don't
take >> I Pisco should take it personally. Hutch is like
Hutch thinks he did a good job
Bro, I How are people cool with that, man? Dude, it's like it's
so transparently bad.
My god. >> I But I I really want to emphasize that it's
not enough to show some trivial risk, some insignificant risk.
If you want to demonstrate that there's culpability in the context
of increasing risk uh in this context, maybe I would grant that
there's some uh nominal duty to impose these kinds of standards
of moderation on your own community. Absolutely. But to race
for culpability uh with respect to risk of the underlying act,
you're going to have to show some significant risk increase there.
And I don't think that you even started to make that case for
for any of the creators like Caseyron. What the [__]
What what is the evidence that Caseyron contributed to this?
She she was um justifying it and joking about it just the same.
They were after the fact. >> Dude, are you kidding me,
man?
What is happening?
What is What is happening? >> On no different terms than
someone on no different terms than someone after the fact joking
about Charlie Kirk's assassination.
But you would not say, "Wow, you've contributed to um his death."
You would say, "This is in bad taste. This looks bad. This is
independently a wrong thing to do, but it's not just >> No,
but it's not just a CPS call. Like if you are if you as a creator
and you have a platform and and you're making jokes about the
CPS call or whatever, you're you are contributing directly
to a culture that is being fostered in that community of celebrating
something that I find to be like really reprehensible,
>> and people should have their lives destroyed for doing
things that you find reprehensible. Hutch, is that how that should
go? Feel like that's probably not how that should go, but hey
man, I don't know. What's up? Uh, dickers people, thank you for
the raid, dickers. Appreciate it. >> Disgusting behavior
and anybody in Ethan's position would have been furious. Like,
do you understand that? Like, even if we found out, for example,
even if we could even if we could say for sure that person came
suffering through this as well. Oh, it's actually You would be
shocked at the level of content you could get out of this 4 and
1/2 hour debate. My god, Hutch is like a truly reprehensible
person. Like a terrible friend. Like a totally terrible friend.
He basically um he sought to basically try to emotionally signal
to make Pisco look bad on every single point and never made an
actual point of his own.
It's it's actually incredible
just how bad this was.
like just how terrible a friend he is. It's very
Yeah. No, it's over and over again. Wait, but don't you understand
that Ethan was like really mad? Yes.
So, like why are you mad that he's ruining people's lives? Cuz
I think it's wrong to ruin people's lives because something bad
happened to you just cuz they're the only people you can pick
out that have any responsibility whatsoever.
But like why?
When October 7th happened, I thought that it was really understandable
that were mad. Yeah, I know they knew Gaza, but like I just thought
it was they had like a righteous anger and then that was fine,
right? Isn't that fine,
guys? Is it like fine? It's understandable that they're mad.
They have righteous anger
>> from bad empanadas community >> Oh, you would
still justify to >> I would still in my mind. >> Why
are you making him sound like a gay? Well, the impression works.
>> No, no. I would still in my mind be um think and and
say that they're all culpable because they're all contributing
in their own ways. And it's like obviously we're getting very
abstract here, but that's that's where my mind goes with it.
Like it could have been regardless of could have been >> regardless
of the significance of the rest, right? >> Any of them,
right? Like it could have been any of them. So,
>> um, no, Velvet Moss, like I said, you just weren't paying
attention or you weren't here from the beginning. Um, it's like
two hours of Hutch refusing to answer any hypothetical. I I honestly
by the end am like pretty certain that Hutch, like if they talk,
what it should be is Hutch should apologize for doing all these
signals that like Pisco is being unreasonable when he was asking
totally reasonable questions. And then Pisco needs to admit that
he is speaking at an intellectual level Hutch can't reach that
like like he probably is making Hutch look a little bit bad because
he's speaking at like a collegiate level like a collegiate reading
level and expecting Hutch to like know some terms and stuff and
Hutch doesn't know them and he's too embarrassed to ask. So Hutch
just didn't understand large swas of the conversation was completely
incapable of engaging. Right. So, I think that's on Pisco now.
Now that he knows that Hutch can't intellectually engage in that
way, I think it's on him to very much dumb things down. No, no,
no, no, no, Missy. I'm He was totally like it's totally unacceptable
that he would not engage. And instead of going, I don't understand
what you're saying, he would just go like he would make faces
and try to make Piscll look dumb or unreasonable. I think that's
totally up. That's wrong. He should go, I don't know. Uh, I don't
know what you're saying. Right. But he really didn't. He really
like categorically didn't understand what Pisco is saying like
30% of the time. So that is where it's like I'm not even calling
him dumb because maybe a lot of it I had to look up some of the
terms Pisco is using like but he he doesn't even know that you
like have to stop somebody when you don't understand them to
continue having the conversation. like he's so certain he's correct
without proving anything that he was just willing to let Pisco
talk and use terms he doesn't understand and it's just nothing
nothing connected for him >> so people calling Charlie
Kirk a fascist and saying >> stop don't stop
>> you know
>> stop making good points dude what debater what person
who engages in political debate political conversation talking
about trade-offs you know economic social policy when when somebody
is making a good point goes stop making that point. I don't want
to do this anymore.
Stop. [screaming]
Are you serious?
The lawyer The lawyer trick of Hey, Hutch, you just made this
claim. Don't you think you should have to substantiate that?
No. It's obvious to any reasonable person. You're doing lawyer
tricks to try to make me say something else. Uh-huh. It's like,
man, I'm trying to think of like who I've ever seen astroturfed
worse than this.
Like, I straight up think
if anybody who was mad at people who said Lav was smart, if anybody
if there's anybody out there who got upset when someone said
Lav was smart,
if you've ever let someone say Pisco is smart without like actually
reporting their stream immediately, sorry, not Pisco, Hutch.
If you ever let somebody say hutch is smart without reporting
their stream immediately, like leave. Just get the out of here.
Like it's actually so rough, man. Doesn't understand. Basically
says, "Hey, can we like um can we can you stop stop arguing?
Stop making like obvious points. Stop making obvious points.
Why are you doing all these hypotheticals, dude? Why are you
doing all these hypotheticals? Why are you doing all these hypotheticals,
man?
>> That's why you
know I don't. No. Charlie Kirk was a national figure who had
way more way more. But like if you're going to ask me is not
>> Wait, if Charlie Kirk had implied if Charlie Kirk had
said something that led people to believe that he might have
been abusive to his kids, what would you have said? Hutch, what
would you have >> Not a national figure. Like what what
is the distinction here? >> Hutch Hutch is the kind of
guy Hutch Hutch would be like in the seminary. Okay. And somebody
comes to him and is like, "Hey, this priest is like touching
kids." And he's like, "No, THAT GUY'S A GOOD GUY. HOW DARE YOU
SAY THAT? EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT GUY'S A GOOD GUY. You I have like
videos and pictures of him abusing this kid. You and just you.
Okay, stop talking about it.
>> I understand how that priest would be mad enough to
you right now. Okay. >> Critic, what are we talking about
here? >> Are we really making a distinction on that? like,
okay, like Ethan, I don't even know if that's real. I mean, maybe
in our bubble, but I don't I don't know that Ethan Klein is lesser
or more popular than Charlie Kirk or more wellknown. They're
comparable, aren't
>> Ethan's pretty popular.
It's so hard to know cuz Charlie has like both a social media
presence and a non-social media presence. Ethan might be the
more known person. No, cuz people are going to know Charlie Kirk.
People might have heard of it. If you say like, "Have you heard
of Charlie Kirk or H3H3?" No, it's not close. No, it's not close.
That was that was crazy. I was I was going to say it for a second
and I'm like no. Like Charlie Kirk's got outreach programs on
every campus in the United States, right? That like have his
face on every single booth at at he's got his face on every single
campus in the United States in terms of merchandise,
right? Like let me just ask you like >> Okay, so you have
family, I assume. So like yeah, >> let's say a bunch of
like like a deranged MAGA person who who who followed you. Mh.
Um, there was a bunch of smaller creators, you know, or big bigger
creators, right? Like, and they all started like memeing about
how, you know, one of your family members was like abusing their
kids and then CPS showed up at the house, right? Like, and are
you telling me you wouldn't be like almost equally that like
everybody who
again
I I wish Pisco should be better at seeing this like emotional
appeal and just saying, "I understand why you're emotional. I
understand why that makes you feel really bad. I understand why
that. But your job as a human being is to take your feelings
and moderate them and then do things that allow you to handle
your feelings but maybe aren't, you know, the absolute harshest
expression of those feelings. Okay,
that's like I understand that that's upsetting and you only have
some people you can blame. You feel like nobody's really like
concretely to blame. But that doesn't excuse you losing your
mind and trying to pick out individuals to punish so that everybody
else so like you engage in this collective. You pick individuals
to punish who may or may not be have any culpability like you
can't even say in a lot of cases other than they're vaguely on
that side. They thought it was funny that you had felt that you
felt pain.
That's crazy man. >> Possibly indirectly responsible for
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean I think that would be the people
who are making light of it. People making if I had evidence that
they were encouraging it. If I felt that they were like spreading
lies that uh someone could take that way. That's a different
you keep trying to find different ways to ask the same question
which is could there be independent
>> Yeah. I'm trying to explain like you're >> No,
it's not working on it's not working on Pisco. Pisco is like
not hearing it well or Pisco is not getting it cuz Hutch has
said it for like the eighth time now. Like don't you understand
why Ethan would be mad? I don't remember Pisco's responses, but
it feels like he's not engaged in just going, I dude, I get I'd
want to kill someone if that were me, but like I couldn't, right?
I definitely couldn't kill someone. There's a line for his conduct.
It's probably basically the line we always had for his conduct,
right? We don't go like, "Oh, now it's actually acceptable to
go punch somebody in the face cuz you had CPS called." Like,
we don't really do that, man. Like, probably it's still the same
line, right? >> Indirectly responsible for that. >> Yeah.
I mean, I think that would be the people who are making light
of it. people make it. If I had evidence encouraging it, if I
felt that they were like spreading lies that uh someone could
take that dude that they were encouraging it. If I felt that
they were like spreading,
he does the shrug.
Huh? Yeah. So, you just agreed. So, Ethan Klein can totally whoever
he wants then, right? CPS call happens. Ethan get to do anything.
CPS call, Ethan do whatever he wants. Very simple. Hutch argument
win. Let's go. >> Lies that uh someone could take that
way. That's a different view. You keep
>> We had a lot of We had a lot of pictures tonight. But
unfortunately for Hutch, he was outdone in facial expressions.
Okay. Because nothing will match the soul torture of this picture
right here. Okay. This is when when Hutch goes after Pisco spends
20 minutes explaining exactly how he dains out like culpability
for crimes and Hutch goes, "So, you're saying there's a 0% chance
that someone in Denim's audience called CPS?" Pisco like Pisco's
soul was not okay. Okay. Pisco's soul was
significantly perturbed by this. Okay. Not [clears throat] good.
Not good at all.
My god. find different ways to ask the same question, which is
>> is that a sticker yet? I might have to go find the time
stamp so I can figure out where the emote is. I put it in Pisco's
Discord. I think they're going to make it an emote there, too,
but I might have to find a higher resolution >> Could there
be independent obligations?
Yeah, I'm trying to explain like you're finding different ways
to ask it, but fundamentally you haven't crossed a divide which
is the mere increase of a risk in violation of some ethical obligation
to you know moderate or to be wise with your words or not say
stupid [__] that someone could take a certain way
that does not translate culpability for the malicious vindictive
acts and we cannot conflate those levels of responsibility or
culpability and what's being used to justify these lawsuits.
Um, again, putting aside the issue of whether his intent is to
protect the React community, which is so bizarre and up and not
true, but even putting that aside, the the argument you get is
that doesn't even matter. Like that analysis piece, who cares
about it because these people are just so awful because they're
culpable for the CPS call. That's what I'm what I'm hearing.
And I just think that that is just a totally wrong-headed >> I
don't say listen, I think they did awful I I think they did an
awful thing. I think all of them contributed to a really awful
thing and they all mocked it and trivialized it. I think it was
>> Was it disgusting for Destiny to ridicule Charlie Kirk's
death? >> I think so. Yeah, I said so at the time. >> I
said it was disgusting. >> What is he culpable for? >> I
had people I had DG in my audience that were pushing back. I
said, I don't think this is funny. I don't think this is a funny
moment right now. >> And what is he culpable? What is he?
I think I even I think he's culpable for in that moment for um
>> don't say being reckless with his words. Don't say the
literal thing he did >> to a culture of political violence
through his rhetoric. >> Isn't that the Republican argument?
>> No. The Republican argument would be like Destiny himself
is like directly responsible because of this that or the other
thing. But we're getting into more abstract kind of ideas, right?
>> Why were you getting so mad when Pisco said not culpable?
That's the scope of >> I I think Hutch no Hutch needs to
say culpable for the murder of Charlie Kirk,
right? Because it is that reverse thing that he is applying here.
>> My claim with respect to Denims is you cannot conflate
the moral ethical obligation with respect to the substantive
act with some kind of >> I didn't but I still think what
they did was disgusting. I think it was
>> He spent so long doing it. This is like another level
of meta gaslighting. This is another point in Hutch is actually
very smart. Okay, that category has not been getting filled up
very much, but that is another point where like if this was performance
art and Hutch was doing this just to troll Pisco to like torture
his soul as much as possible, this would be another point.
Wait, what do you mean? I think Denims is culpable. I never said
she was culpable. Are you insane? Are you Are you out of your
mind? I never said that thing. I think it was so dehumanizing.
I think it was antisocial.
And I think all of those creators
abused the influence that they had. They're all like drunk with
power on their in their own like way. And I think they they they
knew that they have that power. They know they have that influence
and they all knowingly used it knowing full well that the risk
was would go up of something like this happening and they did
it anyways. >> Let's deal with Casey Tron. What act? So
the
vindictiveness or the aggression or the anger at Casey Tron is
justified
>> they all did the same thing is my point. They all justified
the CPS claims, joked about it, continued to say that it was
>> What if anything did Casey Tron say about it? You know,
>> I I'd have to pull up the videos. It's been a minute.
But all of them did. >> You don't want me to do what you
did to me, right? Because I'm going to say, "What? You don't
even know the basic things of what they said and you haven't
done your bare research. Haven't >> I know for a fact you
can ask my >> You understand that's annoying, right? That's
that's annoying to do. Like you don't have >> because I
can't remember particulars. But I'm telling you, like you can
ask my stream. We've we've watched plenty of Casey Tron clips.
We've watched >> I just think you should probably have
some if you want somebody like you want somebody metaphorically
like [__] like you want her you want under threat
of homelessness her to have to make like whatever statement client
Ethan whatever statement Ethan Klein deems necessary, right?
You want her to do that. If you have that opinion, you should
have some understanding of what she's responsible for. You should
have something there, right? That needs to exist.
Man, I have to go back now because I think I want to do a couple
tweets about this. People were like, "Oh, is there really performative
ignorance going on?" Man, I still think I don't know about you
guys, but in terms of moments in this debate, unless there's
something to come, the worst part for me was Hutch saying that
Pisco was being like absurd for wanting to discuss
how what level of culpability Denims had, right? I said figuratively.
I said like not literally, figuratively. Like figuratively, like
making this person homeless. like at what point is it okay? And
he basically argued Hutch that I don't need to know how culpable
these people are to want them to be homeless. And I'm like that's
actually disqualifying to even be a political pundit. Like you
you've missed the core part of the issue in terms of the morality
here
so badly that I can no longer trust your opinion on anything.
And you have no idea. And you're calling the person who's identifying
this. You're calling that person
absurd for caring about it. Like it's it's like you're a part
of a pro-life debate and you're like basically trying to argue
when consciousness begins and the person's like, "I don't care
when consciousness begins. What? I don't care. I don't care when
that person becomes like a person. What are you talking about?"
It's like, "Well, you're here at a pro-life debate. Don't we
have to discuss when life begins?" And it's like, "No, I mean,
dude, obviously
obviously you just don't do abortions.
I don't I don't I don't It doesn't matter where it begins or
ends. You just don't do abortions. They're bad.
Like, no. No. You You're sidesteping the entire purpose of our
discussion. What are you doing?
Watched plenty of videos dissecting what all these various creators
said. I smoked a lot of pot for a lot of years and I can't
>> particulars, but they I'm telling you, they all joked
about it. just there's no way that like I swear to God I made
fun of so many people for having these kinds of arguments when
it would come to actually basically everything I argue on stream
right where they're like I I know I can't prove it but I really
feel it and I'm like I know you really feel it man and that's
what we got to deal with that's like actually that's
that's mine comp okay that's my struggle that I have to I have
to go through and explain to you guys that you don't know why
you think what you think you were actually way more brainwashed
than you think is possible and I'm trying undo it. I'm trying
to be understanding, but oh my god, it is tough.
It's tough.
The creators aren't supposed to be like the worst chatters.
Oh my goodness. Literally, extreme dad, can you shave your head?
I think there is soon to be an opening as a limit liberal commentator.
Okay, I think you got this.
I think you got it, man. I feel like Hutch could give that same
interview that Extreme Dad did like the exact same one.
just like
what the did he say? Oh, he basically said like, "I suck. I wouldn't
hire me." Oh my goodness. What even is the evidence even a community
member is responsible for the visit? Uh there is no evidence
of that. It could easily be their nanny. I mean, I I think it's
somebody with a grudge, no doubt. But it could be somebody like
a nanny. It could be like that that nanny situation. It could
be
Oh, man. I don't know. In fact, I think probably in terms of
evidence, in terms of objective evidence that's not from Ethan
Klein and has only been relayed by him,
wouldn't it be against a community member being the person? Because
literally like the CPS part
of this like the actual report is
I believe it says that there's like a somebody close to them,
right? Like I believe the CPS CPS themselves thought it was somebody
close to the clients. So, man, when you when you factor that's
like the piece of evidence I have that I feel like is objective.
Now,
he claims that that was an impersonation and if he was correct,
that would mean they were committing a crime. Well, I know he
claims it's a an impersonation.
I know he claims that, which makes the report no longer anonymous.
Oh, wait. Why didn't they file a police report then?
Couldn't they have just like called the cops and said this was
an impersonation and then the cops would investigate it? But
then, but then if it if they found out it was an impersonation,
then he'd have to be honest about that. And if they Yeah. Well,
well, wait well well.
>> Huh. I just said they made Riyle. I just said that.
Yeah.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> Justified it. Continued
to justify it. That's the point. >> Okay. And given that
the fact that they joked about let's let's say assume that Casey
joked about TPS call, right? I'm going to assume that for the
purposes of the next stage of talking about that she joked about
the the CPS call. Um therefore it's justified to supposing this
is the motivation
um to sue her on that basis alone. >> I think it's justified
to want to impose consequences and the debate would be about
like is this an appropriate consequence and I've already told
you
>> Hello. I'm going to just drop in for two seconds. Did
you know that in California nannies made not I'm not sure about
ms nannies are usually considered mandatory reporters and mandatory
reporters in California have to report cases of giardia to public
health officials? >> No. But if there's I isn't this whole
thing understandable if you could just say mand mandatory reporters
in California have to report Giardia to Isn't that just like
oh it's game set match. Ethan said they all got giardia.
>> Well yeah that that's the thing. Yeah.
So mandatory reported to the health system. Sorry. Mandatory
reporter to the health system as in there's a potentially like
>> but the thing is Yeah. So it's not obviously that's
the case. Yeah. >> But I could totally see if they're a
manage reporter and they know they're a managed reporter and
they they usually think, "Oh, I I need to report Jardia but don't
know to report." I could totally see him just calling CPS or
something. Or or if they have,
you know, if they had reason to suspect negligence, they would
probably go to
But yeah, that's that's all because I looked up earlier. I found
out that you have to report Jardia if you're a manager reporter
and I was like, okay, well, you know, I feel like this is very
murky. I thought this is not, you know,
I watch like Pisco debated DGs earlier and was like basically
seeding that it's likely that it was a a snarker. It's like,
is it is it any more likely than >> I think in terms of
placing your bets, I'd put it on one of these communities, but
then these communities are different, right? Like realistically,
if I had to put it on a community, if I had to pick one community,
it' probably be bad empadas, right? Like those guys seem like
the reputation's there, but it's one of those things where it's
like it's actually I feel like it's similar to Pisco's Hassan
argument about why he was detained. It's like while I think you
know him getting marked by the government is the most likely
reason, I think it's like one of a lot of reasons that sort of
none of them have a huge percentage. So saying it's anything
seems pretty unlikely to me. Like I like while it might even
be the most likely thing. Like I think maybe the most likely
thing is a snarker or or like some snark some you know negative
community that hates the clients because there's all the Trisha
Pis people too, right? Although I guess those are probably snarkers
but like there's there's hate.
Like why even
when there's so much up for question? How are you like it is
most likely a snarker? Like what are we doing? Is that just a
numbers game? We've got evidence pointing away from that. Ethan
saying that it was some CPS over someone close. >> Yeah,
that's the biggest thing to me. >> I I don't know why why
do we take it as given that it's most likely a snark. I don't
see why that's quite at all. I don't see how you're making a
real determination there given the conflicting evidence cuz it's
like sure you can say oh there's so many snarkers and they were
all talking about it >> but yeah but we have like positive
ev like like objective piece of evidence that points away from
that directly
>> I really after Kilo said that if they think it's an
impersonator that's a crime and why didn't they file a police
report if they didn't file I actually think that's why anything
about any process incredibly suspicious >> this is the
worst thing that's ever happened to Ethan his whole life. >> Well,
it's the impetus for all of his negative any process about that.
It's just we just hear about copyright, >> dude. Like,
>> it's unironically why everybody forgives him for trying
to bankrupt these people. And if it's what everybody's using
as the reasoning and he's not willing to like pursue that, I
think you got to drop it. >> I think I think it
disclose what what he's done since it happened to pursue it.
Show some kind of documentation.
prove that he's actually made any effort to remedy the situation.
Otherwise, you don't get to use it as a pudgle.
>> I think they like I think you have to go after the
Yeah. Holy [__] You have to go after the impersonator
or at least like Yeah, cuz the a name would have been filed,
right? So, it's like the cops obviously just show up, they go
talk to the person who filed. >> Yeah. Let's Let's say
they hidden their identity perfectly. They found proxy spiff
number, fake name, like, you know, >> that's enough to
say snarker. That's Well, it's enough to say not somebody close
to them. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, we we would we would know that's
that's an impersonation, right? We would get to that point at
least. >> Yeah, I'm sure someone would be held accountable,
but we would know
>> Yeah. If they've like heavily hidden their identity,
I assume it's not somebody who knows you. I assume it's somebody
from online. >> Exactly. Yeah. Pursue an identity. Like
why would why would you know Klein's low paid Hispanic nanny
that she pays to raise a kid to rush to retire do herself? Like
why why would they use a fake name? That doesn't make any sense.
>> Wait. Um, I know CPS reports can be anonymous. Do they
know how it was filed? And if they know how it was if they if
it's somebody who's anonymous, what made them think that it's
somebody who's close to me? >> Well, no. I'm chat every
It's just a rhetorical question. Like I actually don't know.
>> Like if they How are they knowing that it's someone
close, right? Is it that they're describing the layout or something?
Yeah, I know the agent told Ethan it was someone close to the
Klein family, but I'm saying like how did they know that? Was
it just that the person said it or >> Yeah. Is it is it
them saying is it them coming up saying oh hello I am the maid
for the clients like is it that sort of or we
you know did they actually give a name give a business or whatever.
>> I've never directly accused Kathy of filing of of filing
the CPS claim like that but you >> I wouldn't be surprised
if if he did. >> It's pretty crazy man. [laughter] Jesus.
>> Oh boy. Dude, I I genuinely feel like this is like disqualifying
for Hutch as somebody I could take seriously as a debater or
anything. >> This is like this should be qualifying for
like being institutionalized. You like shouldn't be allowed to
live on your own. >> Dude, [laughter] I legit in my head
I'm like I think there's a chance this is so I'm unironically.
>> Yeah, I I I do think there is a level of dishonesty
going on where it's his big YouTuber friend. He doesn't want
connection. So, he's just never going to accept anything Pisco
says and he's just willing to sell Pisco out for Ethan
>> I think there's a real chance that like if Destiny were
to review this despite all of the biases at play here. >> Yeah.
Yeah. You know, it's one of those things where he just lo back
up something. Yeah.
>> One of his classic moments when he's talking to Dan.
I could totally see that >> And it's just it like kept
getting worse for like two and a half hours. Like it finally
tapered off somewhere and it kind of got okay again. like it
stopped getting worse, but it like kept getting actually worse.
Like when he accused Pisco of being a debate bro while refusing
to engage in hypotheticals.
>> There's so many moments where he's just being like a
condescending prick as well. It's just like unbearable. >> There's
so many moments. I It's the real tragedy here is that it went
four and a half hours. So like probably nobody will react to
it even though it's all almost all worth reacting to. Like I
actually haven't had a lot of downtime in this. >> Like
bad things happening all the time. I got I got bored with it
towards the end. I was just like, "Okay, this is I get it now."
Like Archers
never going to get it.
>> And he's just going to sit there smug the whole time.
>> It was rough.
>> It's like watching Adam friended, man. He's actually
that stupid. He's like Adam friended love. Maybe more. >> I
think that's incredibly rude to Adam. I think that's incredibly
rude to Adam.
>> I think Adam has the Adam has the good grace to burst
into tears and leave his own show when he's getting totally
Pudge just sits there like soy jackacking the whole time with
a smuggler on his face. [laughter] It's just unbearable. >> It's
just like dude the whole time and every single face is like why
what is this saying? That's like every single >> dude I
can't believe peace like dude how does peace got lo
infinitely more patience than me. I literally would lose at the
f the moment pulled a single face of me. I'd be like
>> like yeah it's actually offputting. It's like why are
you doing a face? Like I'm the reason for saying this. I literally
just asked you like and the sad thing is it's so obvious. You
could just walk through very slowly and say this is the question
Pico's asking. This is how it ties into the greater point. This
is like what's going on here. This is why he's asking it. And
then Hutch just goes
that's just analogous man. >> Oh, you need to tell me why.
You need more than that. >> Oh, dude. The best. Hutch.
Hutch. Hutch. You're making a You're making a claim. You should
have to back up that claim, right? Who cares, dude? I'm tired.
>> Yeah, man. I was I was blown away that you actually
the Oh, I'm tired now. I'm tired now. >> You've gone and
made me tired. The Peter Coffin out of nowhere. You never expect
that one. Never expected.
My god. Yeah.
>> Yep. I'm going to go back to watching. I'll catch you.
>> All right. See you later. Bye. Damn. All right. Where
are we going here? >> Someone dude. Dude, I'm seeing a
screenshot of what this YOLO swag conversation that Pisco had.
I watched like a little bit of this one, too. The YOLO swag guy
who he's talking to. That was pretty rough. That was a pretty
rough conversation.
I noticed I got mentioned a few times. Hold on. Ryle sent me
some clips. We're probably near the end of this anyway. I'm probably
going to go through like a bunch of this stuff. I do kind of
actually want to watch all of it, so it's rough for me. I don't
I don't want to just like log off. Hold on. Um, let me see here.
I think this is it. He's talking about like people in his community
or something. What is this? This is it.
Oh,
why does it Oh, Riyle was sending me clips without sound, right?
Hold on. One of these has One of these clips has sound in it,
right? Hold on. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking.
Oh, maybe I don't have this yet. I'll find it in just a little
bit. Pisco talked about like um his community >> agnostic
on that. Like I'm >> somewhat conflicted because
>> Pisco calls you just ilk. Yeah, but he always called
me Justilk like all the time. He called me that when he would
come on my stream. >> I'm sympathetic to his desire for
like a sense of justice or a sense of like wanting to >> That's
like the meme. I used to just tell people like say it however
you want >> to punish the people who who you feel contributed
in their own way to your family like suffering in your own personal
suffering. But I'm also sympathetic to um like I don't want you
know I don't want denims to be her wages garnished for the rest
of her life or >> like you wouldn't want them to be financially
destitute, right? For
>> I mean I don't wish that on my worst enemy, you know.
>> And and obviously like >> they shouldn't be beat
up for for joking about it, right? They shouldn't be beat up.
They shouldn't be um you know, they shouldn't be banned for it.
Should they be banned? >> Well, I wouldn't I wouldn't be
I wouldn't condone violence. I mean, I I you know, as far as
they should be banned, like uh I think it would be I think it
would be justified for for some kind of like some kind of um
penalty. I I never I don't know if I've ever advocated that people
be permanently banned from Twitch, but the fact that like those
that crew >> here's the time stamp I was talking about.
I un in an unqualified fashion said as I like I'm thinking about
it >> I remember thinking strongly that he was malicious
about certain things but I don't and as I sit there I'm not able
to produce those examples um but so that's that's why I qualified
to the extent I did although I un in an unqualified fashion said
yes after I I gave the initial he has a bad reputation and was
thinking about it but like it's kind of the people who >> oh
they're talking about bad and >> who are like you're not
condemning the genocide hard enough. Have you heard those people
by the way? Like you call it a genocide but people who are like
you're not condemning the genocide hard enough. Have you heard
those people by the way? They're like you call it a genocide
but like that's what you guys are or not you specifically but
certain of the commentators are like oh my god I can't believe
and all the [__] you're like I can't believe I ever
like pe what the [__] he's
so unreasonable
you on this little bit. I can't meet you on this little bit.
Right. So, and if you know, correct me if I'm wrong, but right,
you didn't cover every, you know, miniseries in this 5,000 part
series of, you know, Ethan Klein drama and Hassan [__]
drama stuff. >> Why would you have to? Wait, this is this
is like stupid. If you can't prove out the things you allege,
you can't act on those allegations. Okay? You can't you literally
can't say well these people all deserve this and then never be
questioned on it when they're like getting like threats of total
financial ruination for it right that cannot be how things function.
Then it's like, oh actually you can never question anybody whenever
if somebody has, you know, some dedicated focus, right? Somebody
watches every piece of content from a certain creator and then
they say, "This guy deserves to like actually lose his platform,
his kids, everything." What would your response be? Well, you
can only contradict that if you can if you've watched all of
his content. That that can't be the answer, right? Like obviously
if you're saying that he deserves to lose his kids and his home
and his finances, his every everything he owns, right?
Then you have to be able to prove what he did wrong.
That's all we're asking, >> right? You cover very little
of it. >> I covered the So So the only reason I'm having
this conversation is because >> you jumped in because it's
a legal issue and you have >> I had an interesting expertise
to bring to bear. I mean, I don't claim to be an
>> but I don't claim to be IP. And also, I'm seeing this,
Jen, like and and people are adding me with this, like you have
certain people in your server. Uh, >> hey, why why is like
Hutches and
moderator arguing like trying to pressure Pisco to like not have
me around? That's really up, man. I thought that was like actually
wrong to do. Hey, Counterpoints, wasn't that like wrong to do
to pressure someone to not associate with another creator? I
thought that was like wrong. Isn't this like your mod or
Hey, hey, counter points. Counterpoints. Hello. Thought that's
how that worked, >> Uh, that and so that means that you
are okay with these. >> I don't understand you guys can
watch six hours of this. Six hours of what? I'm watching references
to myself. They haven't happened yet, but yeah, I can watch as
much content as I have to to hear references about me. >> People
that you interact with these people. This is all too. Okay, my
server and the people who are in my comments, I don't ban people
in general because of their views. So when someone says, "Oh,
touch in my comments." Are you telling me that I should ban that
person for saying touch? I let them say, "You pisco." I let them.
So in general, I I like hearing that speech. >> I I'm not
on that bandwagon. >> And so I let people who are pro-
destiny and and pro-justicle
be in my comments. And you guys seem to >> Oh, why did
he say it that way now? That's like a different way of saying
it. That's like a totally different way to say it. Just stickle.
He usually says jistilk. Just stickickle is different from jostilk.
I don't know why he chose that way. >> I have an issue
with that. You know, Destiny was in my Discord the other whatever
month and and we had a conversation about uh the the socialism
conversation or whatever. And if it's I didn't know at the time
someone was adding me is, you know, is so and so is is are they
in your server? Whatever.
Because guess what? The server has rules. If you violate the
rules, >> the Okay, this is not Pisco's fault, but by the
server rules, I know if I'd said essentially anything, I'd be
out.
And Destiny was able to make all kinds of comments about stuff
about me, stuff about Cherry. And I'm like, I'm like literally
messaging him while this is happening. It's like, I'm cool to
respond. Like, if you guys want this, I'll respond in here. Make
fun of this guy, but like I feel like if you're not going to
ban him, then I'm going to respond,
right?
Like I'm okay, but this guy gets to like take all kinds of shots.
No bands, no rules, no nothing.
Oh, what can you do? >> You're banned. It's >> I'm
like I'm like an underclass. Okay,
Oh, I need the Fentto's clip. Hold on. I can't find the clip.
I can't find the clip. No, I can't find it.
I'll find it later. >> It's not I'm not going to do this
whole thing of well, you know, I'm going to ban everyone who
says touch in my comments. I'm going to ban everyone unless you
guys think I ought to do that. Should I do that? Should I ban
>> I don't think so. >> Who dislike? >> I think
you should farm I think you should farm them for super chats.
>> Okay. So, like if if there are people in my chat who
say Destiny or have opinions of Destiny, you're not suggesting
that I should ban them, right? >> This is me in like every
non every discord I don't own. Okay. >> But can a live?
Can a live please? This country sucks. You can come here. You
can eat cats. You can eat people. You can drive your car into
a store, a stolen car.
Gang killings. Gang killings everywhere all the time. Can stream
a little reaction to the major party convention.
Can I sell a hat?
>> Without getting doxed, you know. >> Can a breathe?
I can't breathe. Ben Shapiro. I can't breathe. Breathe. >> Take
your boot off my neck. >> My neck.
It's crazy.
>> I go ON FRESH AND FIT. They get de Sorry. I
>> True. That crowd. They get away. They >> It's
fine. It's fine. It's fine. Sorry. I was back on this. I By the
way, that was the wrong clip. Just so we're clear. That's like
the clip I wanted was a different one. Okay. I wanted the clip.
I wanted a different clip, but it's >> Just like, by the
way, people who are in uh other communities that Pisco, I do.
You hear me going around saying that they should ban those people
or, you know, that I have some moral fault with that? Yeah. They
come into my chat. I don't adopt and agree every single person
who's in my chat and says an unhinged thing or says something
I don't agree with. I agree with what I say I agree with. I adopt
what and I have all sorts of people in my chat, including conservatives,
including MAGA people. And my preference is never to really ban
people unless there's violations of toos. Um, even the most unhinged
people who constantly say, "Sorry, I do find it very funny. There's
a there's a meta thing happening here where there's cereal for
every meal in this chat. But I would never say that like Aridator
is responsible if some of her haters show up and start hating
on me. Even if she says to stop, right? Well, well, I recognize
some of the names. It's just ironic. I recognize some of the
names in this chat and then she said that and then it's just
it's just a little it's funny for >> things that I consider
to be lies about myself I don't ban and this is the standard
like the amount of unhingedness and in my opinion pecode derangement
syndrome regarding uh the people who happen to show up into spaces
that are open these are open spaces my comments are open to people
who want to comment my discord is open to people who follow the
rules it seems like what people are suggesting is I should preemptively
ban certain groups of people because of their perspectives and
other things even when there's not a violation of the rule with
respect to the you know server conduct. Um I think that that's
you agree that's crazy, right? That's crazy.
it's like it's it's it's more pathetic than crazy. It's so cringe.
It's like pathetic kind of thing, you know? Like that's how I
feel about it. It's like pathetic to like care. >> Kylo
won her over, huh?
>> To like go into piece like I'm in your Discord, right?
Like,
am I going to go and like look at the members and then like see
where else they go? >> That's what they were doing.